welcome to the science technology and
energy commission committee session for
tuesday april 12
2022 i'm representative michael vose and
i'd like you all to
stand and join me and representative
peter sampson who will lead us in the
pledge of allegiance
okay thank
you have a public hearing today
scheduled for five different bills
we also will be
conducting an executive session today
at the conclusion of our public hearings
however if any of our public hearings go
short
we may conduct an executive session
during the day
if we do so i will poll the members
before doing that executive session
so that is our plan for the day
and i hope you have made
arrangements this day as long as it's
necessary to get our work done
so with that i would like to
open a public hearing on senate bill 263
establishing the new hampshire youth
environmental education and conservation
council
representative thomas has reminded me
that we have some substitutes today and
i should introduce them
which i forgot to do so
um
okay so
uh if you are a substitute today since i
don't have a written
i don't have them written down it's over
there it's it's over there
the written list so
out okay representative gottlieb is in
for rebecca mcwilliams
gottling
okay
representative uh sheehan is
substituting for representative plett
and not only is she substituting she's
going to do the clerk
as well which is act
and representative laflame is
substituting for
jackie cretion
and representative tim lang will be
substituting for janine knotter
once we get to executive session time
okay so with that we can now move on to
the introduction of senate bill 263
and
substituting for senator waters and
introducing the bill this morning will
be cameron
lapine or lepine i'm not sure how that's
pronounced please correct me good
morning mr chairman member of the
committee uh my name is cameron lapine
i'm the legislative aide for senator
waters
um unfortunately he is double booked in
house transportation right now
so he asked me to read
his testimony
senate bill 263 establishes the new
hampshire use environmental education
and conservation council
as a declaration of purpose states like
all new hampshire citizens youth rely on
the benefits of a clean and healthy
environment and the related recreational
economic and employment opportunities
decisions made today on environmental
policies will affect their lives for
decades to come so this council will
give use an opportunity to learn
about environmental educational and
conservation in order to advise the
legislature state agencies in the state
board of education
a version of this bill had a favorable
reception in senate education two years
ago but it was put aside in the effort
to consolidate and reduce the number of
bills sent to the house
due to the covid19 epidemic
this session it passed unanimously in
senate energy and natural resources and
on consent in the senate
the bill is timely due to the passage of
the legislation representative ladd and
senator waters developed to include
environmental education and outdoor
recreation education
in the state educational adequacy
standards
it is also timely because of the
increased interest by use and
environmental issues
outdoor recreation careers and land
conservation
during the work on the adequacy
standards bill we learned of many
schools including charter schools with a
focus on this education
over the past two years the office of
outdoor recreation in the new hampshire
department of business and economic
affairs
has hired a director and the granite
outdoor alliance is very active in
coordination with it
included in the adequacy legislation was
a requirement for new hampshire career
and technical education system
in coordination with the community
college system of new hampshire
to develop embedded credits in outdoor
recreation fields
cte programs can also focus on careers
in forest ecology marine ecology
fisheries as well as interests in
fishing hunting and various sports
as you may know there is an existing
legislative use advisory council that
advises the governor on issues across
state policy
that council is an impressive group that
has done some work on issues related to
this new council
however the l y ac felt that it could
not adequately give needed attention to
these issues
so it has formally endorsed the creation
of this council an important difference
for this council is the engagement with
state agencies and the
legislature
thus the proposed council is an
educational opportunity on many issues
as well as a means for developing ideas
about workforce development through the
curriculum
as you can see on page 2 starting on one
on line 20
members shall be between the ages of 12
and 25 with a procedure for their
selection in the following lines
on page 3 the duties include considering
scientific reports about various issues
consulting with groups and making
recommendations
it shall issue reports and have an
opportunity to meet with legislative
committees
the council work itself will be a
vehicle for education and for leadership
development
it is important to know how this bill
was amended in the senate to address
concerns about the diversity of student
opinion
the openness to various positions on
environmental issues
and a careful consideration of the
potential costs and benefits of policies
to address the issue of a selection
process that will ensure a diversity of
representation and opinion
please note on page 1
lines
23-24
that the county representative will be
selected by the chair of the county
delegation
for all students as noted on
line 20
selected students shall have
demonstrated academic competency in
science and other fields related to the
council duties
this is meant to ensure that there is an
educational background for evaluation of
the information the council reviews
perhaps the most important part of the
amendment is page 2 lines
7 through 12
note quote scientific reports from a
wide range of sources and viewpoints
unquote
note quote any costs or negative
economic impacts on businesses and
industries and the economic growth and
employment opportunities dependent on
such features of the new hampshire
environment end quote
senator waters is grateful to senator
gaida for developing language that
ensures diversity of opinion and a
recognition of the economic issues
that youth when they become adults will
need to consider
especially the costs or negative impacts
that might be associated with
environmental policies
as a lifelong educator senator waters
has great confidence in use to take the
duties of this council seriously do
their research have open debates and
offer valuable insights
he knows he and other members of the
legislature in both parties will welcome
an opportunity through this council to
engage with new hampshire's use
senator waters will be here as quickly
as possible from health transportation
to take questions after others have
testified
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr lupine for introducing the
bill to us and i think it would be
inappropriate to accept questions
from the committee for uh
yourself so we will thank you and call
our next witness
the clerk would like your like your
written testimony i will hand it to her
okay
so next we will hear from
finn graff
representing the seacoast students for
sustainability
welcome to science technology and energy
don't forget to turn the microphone on
thank you
okay good morning committee members my
name is finn graf from barrington new
hampshire and i go to dover high school
i've come here to urge you to vote ought
to pass for sb 263 on behalf of seacoast
students for sustainability this bill
would establish the new hampshire youth
environmental education and conservation
council and is incredibly
relevant to our organization because of
a belief in the value of youth's
perspectives
sb 263 is so important because it
integrates the voices of young people
into legislation this is invaluable in
the process of reaching a stable global
climate before it is too late a deadline
that the union predicts will reach us in
11 years
but we are not fixed in our predicament
an adaptive group of passionate young
people such as this is a crucial part of
the mobilization it will take to solve
this problem
but this bill has immense value even
outside of political action allowing
young people to engage in a non-partisan
education in science and policy making
there is a widespread interest among new
hampshire's youth not only in climate
change solutions but fish and game
regulation outdoor recreation and
wildlife education this builds this bill
allows for these passionate youth to
receive a first-hand education in these
topics
we have seen a similar education take
place with the useless youth legislative
advisory council which has allowed youth
committed to public service to engage
with the legislation in a way that was
previously inaccessible
a new hampshire youth environmental
education and conservation council would
provide a similar opportunity but
specifically engineered for youth with a
passion for nature
this would provide not only a forum for
an informed discourse on this topic that
many young people such as myself want
but also an avenue to unbiased data and
research on new hampshire's ecology that
most students wouldn't have access to
otherwise
while some are nervous that too much
youth involvement in governance would go
south because of the because of the
impulsivity or the inexperience often
attributed to young people i believe
that this urgency would only ensure that
every variable contributing to a
decision is considered and weighed
correctly
taking new hampshire's youth into
account when policy making decisions is
vital to preserving our ideal of a
governing body that is truly
representative of the governed beyond
politics beyond education young people
have watched enough decisions made
without at least having their voices
heard the youth of this state those who
will inherit the consequences of the
decisions made here should be part of
determining the future instead of
watching it taken out of our hands i
will not take any questions
well thank you that was excellent
testimony we appreciate you being here
to offer it
and we do have some questions from the
committee representative samsic as one
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming today
um
we hear a lot about
in the news media and various sources
about the lack of optimism for the
future that many young people have today
um do you think something like this
would help
empower more of them to
be more proactive and trying to create a
different future
yeah i think um
official avenues for people to take
action
for causes that they really believe in
would increase optimism
for just generally because
if you're working towards something it
feels like it's like reach you can reach
it
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
thank you
uh
i'm not sure what dover has but i'm
going gonna ask you does dover have a
member of
the youth on the school board
uh
i
don't think so
okay
portsmouth does and i know that
that the groups
like yourself eco sustainability
have many times come to the
city council
and talk to the city council and become
involved in political action so
i'm what i'm asking is
do you believe that now
there is
a road for you to take political action
without it becoming
superficial
um i think the road exists but i don't
think it's accessible to everybody in a
way that it should be i think that
making it accessible like very clearly
and very officially would be a better
course of action just because then
people
have a very clear way to get involved
and make differences or at least educate
themselves on the process of policy
making
thank you
further questions for this young man
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you finn
for taking my question
um i my question is around if you're
working in sustainability whether you
have any familiar
familiarity with the term place
attachment because
what i'm thinking of in terms of
the request for this council
is that it would provide an inroad for
youth to become engaged in state
policies around the sustainability of
our forests
um in our you know our open spaces and
um
and what place attachment actually
refers to and it's a relatively new
thing so folks that are studying
conservation
at the at the act you know at the senior
level at college level
is about the fact that many youth are
not connected to nature and therefore
are not engaged
in its preservation they don't really un
they don't understand it because they
don't have a connection and when i look
at this bill
that's what i think of i think wow this
would be a formal way for us to engage
youth who are even peripherally
interested and that way
it would help us with our sustainability
efforts so
in your work do you see that there is um
that formal ways for people to get
connected with the outdoors
and its preservation are lacking
that there's not enough places for young
people to be involved i would say
absolutely um in my experience just like
you know doing cleanups and trying to
organize things like that
people are less likely to get involved
just because they're not
very ex they don't
they have not engaged with nature from
like a young age and so they don't
necessarily care as much about it and
it's hard to get people to um
have an interest in that later on
especially just in high school when you
have a lot of other things going on and
yeah
yeah i i just thought i'd ask you about
that point because i think that that is
where this fits as far as um
uh if you're not
teaching people
um
what different aspects of their
their state they can be involved with
and showing them
you know places that they might care
about if they knew more about it if we
don't have a place for that then it
doesn't
doesn't work is there a follow-up
question
uh no
okay thank you
uh representative thomas has a question
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question i'd like to get questioning
back to the essence of the bill
not anything else
um
in
looking at the
at the um
the bills uh statement on who should be
on the committee
i see there is a very wide um
age difference between um the lowest to
the highest
and so i would like your opinion if this
bill
is
going to establish a council with such a
wide
age disparity that there could be either
common ground or
an issue with how say your 12 year old
might be interacting with a university
student on that council
do you think the bill
uh has the appropriate type of people
that will be on this council or do you
feel that there might be some tweaking
that that could happen to it
i think that that is a fair criticism um
i think maybe the age range is more
about
engaging young people like on the lower
spectrum with nature and then as they
get older within that system they become
like the college age students who are
actually making
organizational decisions like
participating in conservation or
education on a high level and so i don't
think the age range is
wrong or maybe
i don't think the age range is a problem
but i think that
the capacity in which different ages
would participate and what they get from
the organization would be very different
thank you
could you let us know uh are you a high
school student or yeah i'm a junior at
dover high great thank you
additional questions
anybody else have a question
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you um
just because i was very much involved in
scouting i wonder if that still plays a
role among a lot of young people today
because when it comes to outdoors and
feeling confident being outdoors and
doing projects and so forth
that seems to be an empowering thing to
do in the past
um in my personal experience scouting
has been a really good way to engage
people with nature but unfortunately it
has kind of fallen
out of fashion with young people i think
parents are also less interested in
enrolling their children in scouts but i
think you know if there was a way to
get more interest in that that would be
very good for engagement in nature and
also like a
community building
any follow-up
i guess not
additional questions for
the young man
seeing none
i'd like to thank you very very much for
coming to see us this morning thank you
we appreciate your testimony
and now we get to hear from
another young person laura lay godfrey
who is here to represent
herself and the legislative youth
advisory council
so welcome
nice to have you here
thank you so much
good morning everybody my name is laura
godfrey and i'm 17 years old from
portsmouth new hampshire
i am also the youth co-chair of the new
hampshire legislative youth advisory
council
which is a statutory committee made up
of youth all across the state with
varying political beliefs
to help
advise policy
to the state legislature so i'm going to
start off by reading two shorter
versions of statements written by the
legislative council and then one room by
myself and i have also emailed the
committee my statements for reference as
well
so the new hampshire legislative youth
advisory council has voted to support
senate bill 263 an act establishing the
new hampshire youth environmental
education and conservation council
having youth voices on environmental
legislation is incredibly important
because young people will be
significantly affected by the
environment in years to come
despite environmental legislation
disproportionately affecting youth
oftentimes young people are shut out of
conversations on the environment as many
are too young to vote or run for office
and this council would be a necessary
tool as it gives a space for youth
voices to be heard on an issue that
directly affects their futures
although the new hampshire legislative
youth advisory council already spends
time advising on environmental
legislation
there is a need for a council that can
dedicate all of its time towards these
discussions rather than the sliver of
time that the legislative council can
currently dedicate it would also discuss
more issues than just environmental
policy ranging from outdoor recreation
to scientific research as well as
educational curriculums
the section of the bill that requires a
person to be a member of both councils
bridges the gap because it is important
as having a member of the legislative
council an already established group can
help to guide the new youth
environmental council towards running
smoothly and further having a link
between the two councils can help the
groups collaborate and combine their
work to further the impact of youth
voices on environmental issues and for
these reasons the new hampshire
legislative youth advisory council
supports that you vote ought to pass on
the amended version of senate bill 263
now as for my personal statement
i'm going to start off again by thanking
all of you for listening to me
and begin by saying that new hampshire
youth are the ones who are going to
inherit the environmental legacy that
you leave behind
and since this is the case they deserve
the opportunity to have their opinions
taken seriously
for our political system to be
representative all members of our
society must be included in the
decision-making process and when young
people are disenfranchised or disengaged
from government processes a significant
portion of our population has little or
no voice in decisions that impact their
water their air or their school
curriculum
and it is essential that new hampshire
youth have the necessary knowledge and
capacity to participate in government at
all levels because as youth becomes
stakeholders in their communities they
bring perspectives that can lead to
better decisions and more productive
action
and only youth are the ones who can tell
you how effective a sustainability
curriculum is or whether the policies
you make today will hurt them tomorrow
this council has the potential to
establish capable and civically engaged
leaders that can improve policies
not only would this council address a
fundamental political and democratic
right it's also crucial to developing
stable policies that respond to the
specific needs of younger generations
right now as i mentioned earlier i serve
as the youth co-chair of another
statutory committee created by our state
government the legislative council and
our members are geographically and
politically diverse citizens of new
hampshire of all ages and for the first
time our members feel as if they have a
voice that will be listened to in
government
furthermore they become educated on the
accessibility of our government and how
they can make an impact on their
communities
i want to personally attest to the
impact that this council or the
legislative council has had on my life
joining it changed my life for the
better because as a teenager who often
felt powerless when it came to political
action i learned how to express myself
and make a difference i've been exposed
to our state legislature in a way i
never would have had with any other
extracurricular and i've learned how to
collaborate with legislators government
staff and peers with varied political
beliefs i've become a more well-rounded
and more well-informed citizen who is
eager to participate in the democratic
process
and voting this bill as ought to pass
will only secure the leaders of tomorrow
as granite staters
while the legislative youth advisory
council's focus is narrowed to
legislation this environmental council's
reach includes state agencies advocacy
groups scientists and more they can make
recommendations on environmental
education and outdoor recreation
programs or concerning new hampshire
land conservation and this gives youth
unbridled access to have a say in
protecting the environment they will
grow up in
there is a need for this council and the
youth growing up in new hampshire are
the ones who must carry on the torch of
our current environmental policy and it
is only essential that they be given the
opportunity to educate themselves learn
from today's leaders and have a voice in
our state government and for the sake of
representing youth and enabling our
future leaders to protect our future i
urge you to vote ought to pass on the
amended version of senate bill 263 thank
you and i will take any questions
well thank you very much for that
excellent testimony
and congratulations on your public
speaking skills there thank you they are
excellent very very well honed
and i'm sure we have a few questions
that the committee members would like to
ask i would like to ask
if you could give us some perspective as
a member of the youth advisory council
about the age range on your council
versus the age range specified in this
bill
and also the list of activities that
this council would undertake versus the
activities that the council you
currently serve on yeah does
so in comparison with the age range i
believe our council is 15 to 22 and i
think this council is 12-22 so it does
allow a little bit more room for middle
school in the uh middle school-aged
individuals to participate i can attest
that our council has been very
successful with the varied age range
because 15-22 allows high schoolers to
learn how to interact with our college
student members and it actually allows
for a lot of productive conversation in
a way for people to
interact with knowledge or ideas that
they're not typically familiar with and
it helps having you know a system of
established leadership that allows them
to participate and collaborate
effectively
so i don't see that why that would be
any different with a 12 to 22 age range
as i think it would actually make it
more representative for younger people
who are
you know just trying to get into
government or learn more about their
environment
and then as to the second part of your
question what was again i apologize
the difference between the youth
advisory council and what this council
would do yes so our legislative council
as it says in the name focuses
exclusively on legislation for the
current session but this environmental
council would be able to meet with state
agencies meet with scientists meet with
researchers and help develop educational
curriculum that directly impacts them uh
it also can be involved with you know
agencies that help work towards
conservation or sustainability in in
terms of our forests or our land so it
has a much wider reach on the entire
continent enviro of the environment in
new hampshire beyond just policy
very good thank you
representative thomas has a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
so your
very well spoken thank you very much
your comments involving the democratic
process and having a voice
and his viewpoints uh opens the door for
me to ask you this question involving
the committee so
or the council i should say
would you advocate vigorously
for when there the selection is made for
students to be on this council would you
vigorously advocate for for there be a
balance between students with opposing
points of views
um on on this council so so that there
could be discussions of pros and cons
absolutely i think that's actually part
of the reason why
the legislative council has been so
effective this past year is we have had
varying viewpoints and that allows for a
lot of discussion a lot of of
consideration of other viewpoints and
sometimes that leads people to change
their minds and other times it
makes them stick to their opinion all
the more resolutely but ultimately it
ensures that all the members are more
educated and it creates a pattern of
civil discourse that i feel can often
feel is not seen in today's modern
political sphere
thank you excellent anybody else have a
question as opposed to making a speech
representative callie pitts
[Laughter]
uh my question to you and is part of
this council and it's part of it is
personal do you belong to the portsmouth
eco club uh no i do not but i am also a
part of the ceco students for
sustainability
i think i may have seen you on a
portsmouth blue ribbon sustainability
committee meeting a while back
and my question is
do you feel that there is a place for
youth and that youth is
listened to
now
um
if you reach out
and i'm saying that i'm gonna qualify
why i'm saying that and that's not a
speech it's because i have been here for
many years and have not been reached
no one has reached out to me on
environmental issues
except members of the eagle club and
people who
in the local schools are active and the
school board member so i
i'm wondering is this council absolutely
necessary or is it better to go on a
local level
uh that is a great question i agree that
there is definitely a lot of local
engagement but like you said you only uh
you feel is there an avenue for you to
have voices if they reach out many
individuals especially my peers do not
know how to reach out to our state
government especially on issues of their
educational curriculum and how that
impacts how it's impacted on the state
basis so i actually find this council
essential in the state level because it
will broaden their perspectives to not
just how to engage with state government
like i remember the first time i learned
what an lsr was
but also gives them access to state
agencies and scientific research
resources they wouldn't have had
otherwise at the local level as well
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman
yes i wanted to ask as i look over the
bill and i see it's a
set to be like a quarterly meeting and
um a fairly broad mandate that you can
interact with all levels of government
i wanted to ask you if you saw this as a
as a pipeline of sorts where
the inputs would be information that
perhaps we don't have time to get to
here you may be able to take a deeper
look and then the pipeline would be that
you would be making those
recommendations directly to lawmakers
and others who could in effect create
the change that you seek yes uh exactly
that's something that the legislative
council tries to do
but given the wide swath of you know
issues and bills that it tackles it
doesn't have the same time to focus on
specifically environmental issues that
impact them so i agree it could be a
good pipeline to ensure that youth have
a direct voice on environmental policy
specifically thank you
representative lewicki has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um i'm wondering
about the logistics of this and with the
legislative council we've got people
coming from all over the state how hard
is it for people to get to those
meetings particularly the younger people
who don't drive
uh that is actually a great question so
something that is actually been passed
by both the house and senate this past
year is an option to allow us to meet
virtually and that is only because our
council meets uh once a month instead of
quarterly so that is meant as an option
to give our council members increased
access to meet either in person or
through a virtual option and it could be
something that could be explored by this
committee but i think uh having
expectation of quarterly meetings uh
should give members enough time to you
know get to concord or the state house
or their meeting place
representative berezini has a question
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question i noticed that uh the
the council is made up of middle
schoolers high schools university
students and i was wondering um if uh
homeschoolers would also be included
thank you
uh i'm not too certain i think that the
bill should try i should clarify that um
i actually used to be an online charter
school student
so that did create a lot of like
logistical issues when you typically you
know try to apply for certain activities
they say you have to be you know in a
public high school but i definitely feel
like this bill should account for that
and i believe senator waters can also
clarify that question as well
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman just briefly uh
following up on what chairman villa's
question was um can you just underscore
for me how this new council would be
complementary to your council i think
you will
absolutely yeah so i i think there are
two ways in which that happens firstly
in the bill text there is a member
specifically appointed from the
legislative council to be on this
environmental council so that ensures
that
a
member the research and the knowledge
that this environmental council gains
can also be extended to the legislative
council so that ultimately it's youth
helping make a difference for youth and
all everybody involved in the process
can make more informed decisions and
then secondly it also goes back to the
idea that they will you know research
more expanded uh resources and narrow in
more specifically on the environment
thank you
i have one additional question for you
i'd love to get your perspective on this
the council envisioned by this bill
focuses exclusively on
public sector
organizations the legislature state
agencies etc
is there a similar organization that
focuses on private sector
organizations and provides information
or advice to them that you're aware of
uh not that i'm aware of off the top of
my head unfortunately but thank you for
your question
okay
thank you
see no further questions we would like
to
applaud you for your appearance here
this afternoon and thank you
profusely for being here thank you all
so much you did a great job thank you
and i have one final speaker on this
bill and that is represented
state senator david waters
who uh
was able to join us after a visit to
transportation the transportation
committee so senator waters thank you mr
chairman members of the committee
senator waters district four and um i
actually have to be down back in
transportation at 9 40 but i did i know
cameron uh presented my testimony
and so i would be happy to see if there
are any follow-up questions i'll just
say from what i heard that um you know i
had
i meant any student
uh charter
private
uh home school to be eligible
both for for this um so
and i also will say that just as a kind
of an aside on this i want to
re-emphasize that
you know representative ladd and i have
worked very hard to
improve education particularly through
the ctes
and through outdoor recreation and
that's why our bills last time
put some of this into adequacy
we've got the office of outdoor
recreation we have
the granite alliance and um you know
sixteen six six million dollar industry
the outdoor recreation industry in this
state
so i've been concerned
across the board about young people who
might want to go into careers
so there's a to me a lot of this has to
do with workforce development if we have
this inadequacy now how is it that we're
going to shape our
education and give some insights into
you know the kinds of careers that young
people could go in
related to conservation the environment
broadly so um to me
you know kind of looking the wrong view
um
that that this is a
you know the environmental issue is
great you know i think that's that's
great to learn about and so on but i i
think that we have the opportunity
because of the changes in in the
educational system on outdoor recreation
other areas to really let students um
see how they might
see a career and stay in new hampshire
too so sorry for that little additional
speech but it's okay representative
harrington has a question
thank you mr chairman thank you to my uh
question senator i you know reading over
the bill i see there's a lot of
different things going on here we have
memberships we've established in your
council we have assigned duties and
reports and meetings and so forth i see
nothing about funding though where is
are these people going to receive
mileage when they go back and forth to
these meetings uh who writes the reports
or is this just all done by the people
on their own time and own dollar
thank you for your question you know
this is pretty boilerplate in terms of
how
uh commission is set up and legislative
members get mileage on commissions not
the public members so you know there's
no legislators on this i'm i'd be happy
to others to serve as an advisor in
capacity but um and there is no funding
involved no and and most commissioners
don't have any funding for reports so
that's just
you know kind of it's a typical
commission thank you
representative thomas has a question uh
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question i
i think you just about answered my
question previously but just to be clear
uh is there any
uh legislative representation are there
gonna be any uh representation on this
council at all because as i read the
bill it only allows students between 12
and 25 to be on the council but it
doesn't talk about any advisors or or
anybody like that
so what's your
can you clarify it for me please
thanks for your question and you know if
i i just say on the age range on that
issue
um if there's anything in the wisdom the
committee you think maybe ought to be
improved
um i kind of felt that
legislators could certainly and others
doe folks too in particular i think
would be happy to serve as advisors um
and
help in in various ways
but i also thought that you know kind of
the point of this is to let the students
learn what it's like to do the work
and have their own leadership here and
that puts a responsibility on them to
develop leadership and not be able to
kind of turn to
one of us or an adult um in that in that
way so that's why it's there but if you
you know if you feel more comfortable
with another kind of
uh age range or
or having a legislature a legislator or
maybe somebody designated you know the
commissioner education could designate a
member from the um
from the department i mean those
i can see what you're saying
follow up
thank you thank you for the follow-up
yes i actually i agree with you on that
point um
i thought it might be good for
the council to have
some
department or somebody to turn to
for advisory like in writing a report
who to send things to
um maybe certain ways of just some other
a person that wouldn't be a voting
member but they'd be like an advisor
on something like that which i i get
your point which is i totally agree with
uh just someone else would turn to that
that someone could be thank you
useful ideas useful ideas yeah and i do
have to i think i've got to go i can
come back i'll be back later today
okay we'll uh will hold any future
questions until later sorry i'm sorry
but thank you so much for indulgence we
understand
many members of this committee will be
leaving at some point to go testify on
uh bills and before the senate as well
including
representative berezni who's on his way
out right now i'll be leaving at some
point to testify on hp 1469.
representative bernardi is already in
senate commerce so it's an it's a
an open door on a day like today so
well we have no uh additional
pink cards for this particular piece of
legislation so i will close the public
hearing
and ask representative white to read the
blue sheet information for us
okay
so we are done
and it is now 9 44
which gives us 16 minutes before the
next public hearing
so i would like to gain a sense of the
committee about entering exec session
on
house bill 256
what
does the committee feel
about going into exact session for this
bill
house bill 256 to refresh your memory
is
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility of replacing the site
evaluation committee
and
representative oxidant
you have a comment i yes i do thank you
very much mr chair we have two bills on
the site evaluation committee one is
we've been told it's a short-term fix
and the other is a long-term look
could i think it would benefit us if we
considered those two bills together
could we do that and have something
simpler um like the one that we said
yesterday could probably be passed in
two minutes
okay you think that the bill is too
complicated then um
not too complicated but i think it would
benefit from from considering the two
bills together
i'm not sure i see that point but um or
is the second one only going to be heard
today
um
how about senate bill 270
would you guys have any appetite for
executing that bill
establishing a low moderate income
community solar program
okay there is an aptitude appetite for
doing that could i see a show of hands
of people who would support
a motion to ought to pass on that bill
okay given that reality i would like to
now
open an executive session on senate bill
and recognize
representative lewicki for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move out to pass
on
senate bill 270.
the chair recognizes representative cam
brills yes i would like to second that
motion mr chair it has been moved and
seconded
that we
judge senate bill 270 to be ought to
pass and our clerk
is going to be putting together the
required paperwork here and while she
does that
i would open the floor to any discussion
on this bill
is there
anything that we need to say about this
bill before we pass it
it essentially fixes the
low
and moderate income
community solar program
by providing a way for
developers to get access to a list of
people who could benefit from the
program
it is
or has been described by some people as
a technical fix to the existing statute
and uh
apparently
as the statute exists today it's not
working
and
it's become kind of just sitting there
kind of useless
rep representative mcgee thank you i i
believe it's also predicated on ever
sources
set up in connecticut so that's what
they're basing it on is
allowing that availability or providing
providing that list so
is there any additional comment
on this uh
motion
ms clerk are you ready to go yet or are
you still setting up
okay
mispronounce anybody's name
i will ask the clerk now to call the
role on the motion of ought to pass on
senate bill 270.
representative thomas
yes
representative harrington
representative lange
uh representative murder yes
clerk votes yes
representative barenzi
brezhny he's not here
representative bernardi
representative cambrellis
yes
representative pleasure
representative white yes
representative samsich
representative
representative callie pitts
yes
representative mann
representative oxenham
yes
representative lewicki
representative vincent
representative mcgee
yes representative gottling
yes
representative leflam
representative pimentel
yes
representative partial
representative vos yes
18-0
by a vote of 18 to zero senate bill two
seven zero has been judged to be
worthy of the motion of ought to pass
and
i'd like to make a motion mr chair that
we put it on consent without objection
the
bill will be placed on the consent
calendar seeing no objections
so be it
395.
it's not up yet that's not on our list
of bills to exec today representative
sausage mr chairman uh could you remind
us which bill we were talking yesterday
about executing in two minutes i forgot
what the number was that i'd like to ask
if we can do that that was senate bill 2
which uh was relative to the approval of
power power purchase agreements for
offshore when did he re win wind energy
resources from the gulf of maine
and
one of our members has written an
amendment for that bill so it can no
longer be done in two minutes
so that will have to wait until later
this afternoon can i ask then that
sb 440 the other um offshore wind
bill
be considered
yes we could do uh sb 440.
so
i have not closed the public hearing on
the other one
yet have i or the executive session so
i'll close the executive session on
270 and i'll open an executive session
on 440 relative to the offshore office
of offshore wind industry development
and for that
i would like to recognize
representative thomas
thank you mr chair on sp
440 motion is to otp
and i recognize representative cambrils
thank you mr chair i would like to
second that motion
so it's been moved and seconded that we
judge
senate bill 440 fn has
ought to pass
since representative thomas and
representative kam brills both serve on
the offshore
wind commission i think it's appropriate
that they make those motions
representative partial did you have a uh
a comment about this bill i do in fact
have a concern um there's an amendment
for uh
senate bill uh
was it 268
and uh that amendment would seem to be
more fitting in a study group like this
rather than
in a bill that that is setting uh
is exerting our state rights to the 200
mile limit and uh i mean that seems like
a fairly clean bill fairly
straightforward where a study commission
could delve into some of these
technologies to a greater degree
that are suggested in the amendment okay
thank you but uh we're discussing senate
bill 440 right i
hoping to be understand before we got
into the yesterday
uh sorry you didn't make it okay any
further dis uh discussion of this bill
representative harrington yeah just to
be clear what this does is build it
gives us a seat at the table with the
feds that we otherwise wouldn't it
really isn't dependent on even whether
new hampshire pursues offshore wind or
somebody else does we know there's going
to be offshore wind pursuit in the gulf
of maine
and the other part of it it allows the
puc to approve contracts for purchase of
offshore win
that's exactly what they do now anybody
that wants to uh have a contract uh the
utilities bring the contract to the puc
they review that they look at the ones
that the utility is not recommending and
they approve it so it doesn't really
change anything but it gets us that seat
at the table so regardless of where we
go with when this is necessary
great any further discussion of this
bill
ms clerk are you ready to call the role
yes
all right in that case i asked the clerk
to call the role on the motion about to
pass on senate bill 440 fn
representative thomas yes
representative harrington
yes
representative mirner
clerk votes yes
representative
borenzi representative bernardi
representative cambrils
yes
representative claudia
representative white
yes
representative somsich
representative callie pitts yes
representative mann yes
representative oxenham
yes representative lewicki yes
representative vincent
representative mcgee
yes
representative gottling
representative leflam yes
representative pimento
yes
representative partial
representative vos yes
18-0
by a vote of 18 to nothing senate bill
440-fn
has been judged to be ought to pass and
without objection will be placed on the
consent calendar
seeing no objections
it will be placed on the consent
calendar and with that we'll close the
executive session on senate bill 440 and
we do not have time to start another one
representative oxenam
i just wanted to make known that i do
have an amendment that i'll be passing
out for sb 259 so if we're
further considering what bills are are
going to be coming up i'd just like
that to be
known thank you
okay thank you for that uh
representative mcgee
yes mr chair i also have uh an amendment
to a bill that we are planning to exec
today which is 269. this is from
representative mc williams and it's
based on uh comments that we had in
yesterday's hearing she had asked
that we add a licensed architect or
engineer
to the
commission that's being proposed
and there was i think one other change
in here that i noted earlier but anyway
i'd like to pass that out as well so
noted thank you all right
we have to start another public hearing
in about three minutes so we'll take a
brief bio break and then we'll come back
and hear senate bill 265.
see you at 10.01
okay
i did good oxen
okay ladies and gentlemen let us resume
i now open a public hearing on senate
bill 265
regul relative to the aggregation of
electric customers
by counties
and i
call on the prime sponsor of the bill
senator khan
to introduce this legislation to us
welcome back senator khan
nice to see you two days in a row
agreed a little more timely today thank
you
i'm looking for my reinforcements and i
may need to fly this solo
i
received a request from
cheshire county
select board and commissioners
to bring this piece of legislation
forward which i think is applicable for
all counties and
their interests particularly those with
small communities
as we have in cheshire county for the
record i'm jay kahn
from keene
and uh representing 15 of 23 towns in
cheshire county
um
the
improvements that were made last year in
hp 315
were significant and most appreciated i
think by our
uh towns and counties
uh
as cheshire county moved to acquire some
uh or or
enter into some
utility energy
agreements
they did so
in collaboration
with the county delegation
and the
with
the interest of towns trying to be
represented in that purchase
so when they did the power purchase
agreement to
uh provide power to the uh county jail
the nursing home
uh
and other county facilities
uh they did so with the intent that if
that pricing was competitive enough
that they would offer that contract to
the towns in the county
23 towns
we've got a lot of small towns in
cheshire county
their community aggregation just is not
going to add up to
any kind of mass
and so they would be looking to another
contract
to
be a partner to
that's what this is attempting to do
so that
should a
area a county service area which could
be a town like roxbury
300 people
wish to
be a part of that service
the town could
opt to to be an opt-in
and then notification would be sent only
to those
residents of roxbury
if they wished to opt in to the
community power agreement
so that's the intent here the opt out is
is a clear uh option as well
for towns that might be served so
hopefully
this is
clear enough uh in the
uh
amended version that
has come over to your committee
uh what the intent is and how this is
really a small tweak
uh to the legislation that she was
signed into law this last year
thank you senator do we have questions
for senator khan
representative oxenam
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much senator for taking my question
uh i was confused by the language of
this bill
and i um reached out to cliff below who
was our noted guru and and mentor on all
things
it seems and uh he explained this to me
as being a very simple change which
means that instead of having to send
notices to everyone in the county you
only send the notices to those in the
affected area so it's a cost saving for
towns
and it doesn't waste resources
do you agree that that's really the
intent of this bill i agree thank you so
much thank you for the question
additional questions for senator khan
i know you have a lot of questions for
mr bilo who's coming up soon
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator
um
so i've got
two two short questions that you can
answer it seems to me that
the the
for small towns that you were mentioning
for example um the way they would look
to partners would be
to some program offered by a county
which would be a much bigger entity
that they could join is that limited to
their county or not
and the second question is uh who uh who
who will have the listing
where does that list come from that they
will mail to
thank you for those questions
my understanding is that the list would
come from the town
of town residents so it would cover
the 300
people in
roxbury
or
no dude off the tax rolls the tax throws
yeah not renters or i i believe it could
be the property
holders
yeah
you need a follow-up i i you know and i
i'm i'm venturing here i'm
okay representative callie pitts
as i'm reading the bill it says each
retail customer so that would mean each
person that pays a bill i am assuming
um
i have a question on the municipalities
and counties shall post public notice of
aggregation
i sometimes have a problem with that
public notice because
i know that's a 91a issue but in some
counties that's on the door of the
men's room and ladies room in the county
building and nobody goes in there
because it's locked three quarters of
the time
so i i don't understand that the mailing
i certainly understand
but i i would hope that we could make a
little bit of clarification such as all
media
um all available media and would you
approve of that i would thank you
representative pimentel
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
khan um i guess
i'm a little confused on the opt-in
opt-out what
where do they when has it dropped out
and when it has dropped in
i
i'm uncertain
i mean we both know what the meaning of
the
terms are uh but i'm not sure who is
making that determination is it the
county and its
uh
proposal to
its
relevant towns i or the town itself i
i'm not sure which way that
that negotiation
is initiated
our next speaker will be able to answer
i i think so yes and and relative to
representative samson's uh uh
your other question i i i
how would it be aggregated i
uh
and i think uh
mr below is
part of that power aggregation
community and has a good handle on this
representative partial
um not so much of a question is a
perhaps more of a comment of what
happened in my own town of marlborough
where our community came together a town
meeting and voted on a resolution to uh
uh
to well push forward with being the
aggregation and to make it an opt out
situation because what we would actually
be doing would be offering lower utility
rates
of course we will be communication with
all of the people who are producing who
are getting a bill in our town so it was
thought to be redundant also to the
second mailing as well uh we're a poor
town
we like to keep our money close to us
and uh
it was just a matter of cost to make it
an opt-in situation
okay thank you for that comment usually
we ask questions but i am so sorry but i
gave you a little attitude here yeah i
would believe
representative oxendine has another
question
okay
shot yourself a note as soon as okay
okay thank you very much mr chair i did
drop myself a note and that jogged my
mind uh the suggestion was made of an
amendment to say all available media
again for small towns that could be an
exorbitant amount of money um
would you think it would be appropriate
if we were to say
two to three
major media
um you know one
social media one newspaper
one online uh i think all available
media particularly in small towns that
are close to cities
where they would be required to put it
in the manchester guardian and they
would be required to put it in all sorts
of different places uh
could could you give us some guidance on
your view on that
um
i appreciate that i might weigh in on
that but i i really your your best
thoughts on
where this ought to be posted i or if
there is a county representative here
they would be
more familiar with
their usual postings of
information to the public i i i'm just
not there thank you very much i i think
you've given us a very good uh
sort of a follow-up there the guidance
is to follow the norm of how
municipalities would be informing people
when public notices are required yes
which isn't all available and in this
case a county yeah in this case the
county's normal procedures thank you
very much
okay thank you
representative sausage
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um
as someone who is on the portsmouth
energy advisory committee and we have
voted to participate in the power
community coalition
my understanding is and i think you can
correct me this bill doesn't contradict
that
is that
the local community can decide whether
they want an opt-in or an opt-out and
i think our group is is inclined right
now to say we're offering this and we're
going to let everybody opt in who wants
to participate in it but you can opt out
anytime you don't like it
so i don't think this bill restricts
the the the
initiative at the local level to do
either one is that correct
i
am unfamiliar
and i i think that's
sounds
like good information
okay seeing no further questions for
senator khan we want to thank you
senator for being here i know you have a
busy day and you need to give your
brother three places at one time thank
you mr chairman and you know i i just uh
want to leave the committee with you
know i clearly
i'm bringing this forward on behalf of
the county
but i i on behalf of the small towns
that i represent
this is something that i i think is
important for them and i'm pleased that
the counties are interested enough in
trying to be the coordinating arm so
that each county doesn't have to
enter into this and become aware and can
rely on the county government to provide
that expertise thank you
okay thank you
all right let's move on and i will now
call to
the table
the honorable clifton below who is here
representing representing community
power coalition of new hampshire
and in new hampshire he is mr community
power so
mr bilo welcome and thank you uh good
morning mr chairman members of the
committee i am here on behalf of the uh
the community power coalition of new
hampshire
which uh comp is comprised of um 17
municipalities and the county of
cheshire um
and this as you might recall last year
when sin house bill 315 was passed it
included a new sentence in another part
of the statute that says a county plan
may provide an aggregation program for
all or a subset of municipalities within
the county that request to participate
by majority vote their respective
governing bodies so that that sort of
sort of set the stage for cheshire
county to think about how they want to
do this several individual towns within
cheshire county have chosen to go their
own route with community power
the law you know clearly provides that a
municipal program takes precedent over a
county program
uh but in thinking about their electric
aggregation plan
as i understand it cheshire county was
thinking in terms of
wanting to serve their own facilities in
the first instance and then also offer
an opt-in product probably initially
just to to primarily to towns for their
municipal facilities and potentially to
large cni customers that you know wanted
to also um
buy in on that on an opt-in basis um and
then eventually uh possibly expand that
to
serving towns that might want to do
this either on an opt-in or opt-out
basis the law allows each municipality
or county to decide whether to offer
services
well the basic default
energy service on an opt-out or an
opt-in basis um
but then you know the problem that has
been sort of daunting them while they
haven't completed their aggregation plan
is the thought of having to mail to
every single
retail electric customer within the
entire county
you know excluding those municipalities
that that have programs or planning
programs um it just made it infeasible
for them to even consider doing this for
for just county buildings and municipal
and school district facilities so
um
they
this sort of came up in working on rules
last uh june with with what was then uh
puc staff and and eversource
and the observation is that the current
language and statute that starts at line
three
says if a plan is adopted or once
adopted is revised to include an opt-out
alternative default service
the municipality county shall mail writ
notification to each retail electric
customer within the municipality or
county
and um
that the feeling was that could be read
two ways that if it's an opt-out program
then you have to do the
notification to everyone or
if the plan is adopted
it you have to do a mailing to every
retail electric customer
and um you know the cost of a mailing
between postage and printing and you
know processing is probably well in
excess of a dollar
per customer
and uh for what they wanted to do it
just it just
made it
look infeasible so
um
the the thought was uh
to clarify um first of all that's the
new words in line five um
to clarify that uh within a county
service area where such opt-out service
is to be provided that would require
notification to every electric customer
but if a program or other service is
just offered on an opt-in basis
meaning that a customer would have to
affirmatively say i want to be enrolled
in this program
then
at lines
7 and 8 says that
mailing of written notification to each
customer within the municipality or
county service area shall not be
required
uh so it's just sort of a logical thing
that if something's just offered
somebody has to affirmatively decide to
to join the program
that you not don't have to do a mailing
to absolutely everyone the senate did um
amend it to add the municipalities and
county she'll post public notice of
aggregation programs um
[Music]
and that it was just just a feeling i
mean that you know certainly that would
be an expectation anyways the the
electric aggregation plan itself has to
be publicized there has to be a public
hearing on it um
and that requires public notice as well
uh but this is just sort of a belt and
suspenders edition i would suggest that
i every county and i think virtually
every municipality has a website so you
might want to say
if if you want to add to that she'll
post public notice of aggregation
programs
in the same manner that meetings are
noticed but but shall include you know
notice on on the uh
municipality or county's website some
something that
gets it on to their website because i
think that's where most people tend to
look these days
but there would also be the regular
notification
in the public hearing process that's
required in other parts of the statute
so that that's the basic
information i wanted to share with the
committee
wonderful thank you very much for uh
clarifying all that for us this language
looks familiar to me is this language
that we considered adding to hb 315
no but there is that parallel language
that we added that's in 53 e6
that says a county may provide
a program for all or subset of
municipalities within the county that
request to participate by majority vote
of their
respective governing bodies that that
language was added i don't think we
really thought about this issue
um because this part of the uh this this
is language that's carried forward from
um
you know that that written notification
every retail electric customer was was
in the law from that point and i might
add that in response to another question
that was asked at line nine
uh through line 13 it talks about to um
allow that mailing to occur um the
utilities have to provide the name and
mailing address of all their electric
customers
um
and
that's that is something of a burden
particularly it's it's apparently it's
not too hard on a municipal basis but
that having to do it for a whole county
with a lot of a lot of small towns
and they have to get it cheshire
county's served by at least two
different electric utilities three
actually liberty eversource and the
co-op
so if you're just doing an opt-in
program that you're looking maybe for a
handful of municipalities to sign up in
school districts to sign up their
facilities for
um
you know it's it's it's a little
burdensome to ask the utilities also to
produce those mailing lists when you're
not actually
you know targeting that those groups of
people
representative callie pitts has a
question
cliff thank you for taking the question
why can't each
participating municipality
do their own
mailing
many i i don't i'm not that familiar
with cheshire county
but i know that we have a lot of people
that um
maybe part-time residents in some places
and that mailing is really the only way
that they're going to know what's going
on so why can't each
municipality within the county that is
participating do the mailing and not
leave the burden up to the county seat
i and just a thought yeah
if a municipality wants to do their own
aggregation program then they would do
the mailing or arrange for a third party
to do the mailing um
[Music]
you know this law simply has always
provided that this could also be done on
a county-wide basis the big change last
year was that it could be just those
towns that want to participate and even
that contemplated that it might be a
town that says okay we
we want you to serve our whole community
on an opt-out basis so then you would do
the mailing to everyone in that
in that
service area where where opt-out
services to be provided so everybody
would get that mailing plus there has to
be public hearing with public
notification um through the usual means
for that um
even on an opt-in basis there still has
to be a public hearing on the proposed
aggregation plan that would describe the
intent to do it on an opt-in basis
so there would be multiple
notifications
follow-up
i
i was under the impression that in
discussions that we had
with community power
that opt out
was the preferable way so that you would
increase your
customer base is that a correct
um
it's fair to say that opt-out based
programs you know assuming they launch
in every plane that's being written that
i know so far says we're only going to
launch if we can offer lower rates than
the utility default service rates um
although they may not always be lower
but but
uh
that you know the intent is that on on
average you could meet or beat the
utility default service price um if
uh if that was the um
case that
you know typically there's a very high
retention rate that you know 90 95 of
customers will
come over on an opt-out basis
there's not a whole lot of experience
with opt-in but i think the few
instances where it's occurred
uh
you know you might get five percent or
ten percent of of customers opting in
and and you know the basis for this is
this this only happens if the governing
body and then the legislative body of
the municipality um votes to to go this
route and it is and in all cases that
you know we built in working with this
committee built in a lot of provisions
within the statute that says you can't
somebody wants to uh revert back to the
utility default service you know the
price goes up after six months and they
say no i want to go back if they're free
to do so no you they can't be charged
for that as long as they do it on a
regular meter reading cycle you know
next meter reading um
so uh
it it will make it very easy for a
customer who doesn't want to be part of
the program if it's an opt-out
to to go back to the utility default
service or a different competitive
supplier
representative samsic
tom thank you
mr chairman thank you uh cliff
um
just to clarify what uh uh
represent kelly pitts's
concern was
um
there's no nothing in this bill that
would prohibit the municipality or the
entity from doing a mailing if they so
choose to do so sure i know that in
portsmouth now the our energy advisory
committee we're going to do a big pr
thing to let people know about what's
going on
and if that's what's required to get
people on the notice they need that they
have this option
that's we're going to do but on the
other hand i can see that in some cases
that might be too expensive for some
entities and they're going to have to
publicize it in a different way but this
bill would not prohibit any mailing if
they want to do that absolutely not
okay
additional questions for
mr bilo
well seeing none
i guess this is a fairly uh simple and
straightforward bill and so uh
we've learned everything we need to
learn about it i guess so
blue sheet nick can you let us know how
uh folks out there are perceiving this
bill yep so online we had 72 in favor uh
zero opposed zero neutral
to
uh to in in support signed up here in
the in the committee room okay for sure
representative thomas thank you i just
have a question um
representative white
i i'm just curious on the online
information
does it indicate
if they were all in state
yes running through it
it looks like all of them
just a quick glance looks to be all from
new hampshire
yes
thank you or at least that's the towns
they put
okay
thank you
all right so with that we'll close the
public hearing on senate bill
265 and i will remind everyone
that
our next public hearing will commence at
12 30
not one o'clock
we have scheduled that next public
hearing for 90 minutes because it's on a
very important bill
and a bill on which
i i suspect a lot of people will want to
testify
so
i just want to alert everybody to that
because normally we reconvene after
lunch at one o'clock but today it's 12
30.
so
that gives us
either
a lengthy lunch break starting now or an
opportunity to do some more exact
sessions
however
we do have a lot of members who are
absent at the moment
so uh it may not be possible to
let's let's look through the list here
and see if
there are bills we might have some
concerns mr chairman
if i could make a representative
i i think that sb 259 we had
pretty much general
agreement in the room when it was
discussed and we just we
actually talked about uh
the crux of the amendment that
i hope to put forward
it would not be a surprise to anyone
who's not here and i don't i don't think
there's any partisan divide on this
issue that's a
might be a concern
forgot to turn on my mic
let's consider doing an exact session on
senate bill
which is relative to renewable energy
and national natural gas
all those who would be in favor of an
ought to pass motion for
senate bill
424 please raise your hand
oh let me refresh everybody's memory
then
senate bill 424 is relative to renewable
energy and natural gas it uh establishes
in in law a method to
accept
renewable natural gas as a
uh
form of energy that's
uh acceptable to this in our state so
once again
we just heard this bill yesterday so it
should be fairly
fresh in everyone's mind once again if
you're in favor of supporting this bill
please raise your hand
okay so i think we can do a uh
an exact session here did you have a
comment representative callie pitts
if we have enough votes i i think i'm
very
perturbed at this if we have enough
votes to get it the way
we want it then we'll take a vote but if
we don't have enough votes to get it the
way we want it then we won't
and the people who are here are here but
they're testifying in other places
and so yesterday there was
and i i hesitate to do this with the
chair but i have to yesterday there was
a threat well we'll stay here it'll you
know
10 o'clock if we have to
but
we've got two and a half hours between
bill i mean that this just
this to me is very disturbing
okay
i have just been informed
that
senate bill 270 which we just exact
senator waters had
proposed an amendment
that addressed some technical concerns
that the department of energy raised
i don't recall seeing an amendment
submitted by anyone
but i've been asked if we'd be really
willing to reconsider the motion on that
bill to adopt the amendment but i don't
have an amendment to adopt but could it
come before it be fixed in enrollment if
it's just technical could we submit it
as a floor amendment okay i'm going to
ask
mr roberge from the
department of energy to come up and
speak to us about this amendment
i don't
i don't have a good memory of it
hold on okay
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i realized that
um there are discussions about exact
session i apologize for inadvertently
adding to the pile
um but senator waters did i believe
share an amendment yesterday that's
1396 s
to senate bill 270. the amendment was
the result of discussions with the
department uh clean energy new hampshire
and senator waters on addressing three
technical concerns that the department
had with the bill
i understand that the committee voted
unanimously just a few moments ago and
not to pass and put on consent i was
just coming back to
remind the committee that there was that
amendment and the department would
certainly
appreciate the committee's
reconsideration if it wanted to
okay i now have a copy of 1396
s
does anybody else have a copy
no
all right
i will have copies made
um
is kristin here
kristen could you make copies of this
for all of all members of the committee
uh griffin while the copies are being
made could you refresh our memory on
what the technical change sure so
in
in looking at the bill if everybody has
more copies of that than the amendment
um i'm willing to go through the bill
and identify what those changes are
quite quickly
i'll give
the amendment is 1396 s
but i was going to reference the outline
changes in the bill as passed by the
senate
i can go with whatever is easier for the
committee i apologize for this
i would i would like you to explain what
the change is sure so one of one of the
so in the amendment there was a
reference to uh the eap administered by
the commission as the committee is aware
there is a bill in the works about
transferring the eap
over to the department to avoid any
potential conflict we just remove the
language it says administered by the
commission and that's that's rectified
in the amendment
the second change um
in the amendment uh allows electric
distribution utilities to recover costs
we wanted language and we suggested
language in there that says all
reasonable
and
prudently incurred costs
that's the second change the third
change in the amendment would preserve
existing statute to authorize the
department to petition the puc to assess
fines revoke the registration of
prohibit from doing business in the
state uh for any group host which
violates the requirements of the bill
those are the three changes
okay
excellent
we did discuss that yesterday we did we
have all the changes but it did you say
the department is authorized to petition
the commission
that's correct
okay all right so while
uh kristen
gets everybody a copy of the the
amendment what we could do now
is we could vote to reconsider
our earlier
motion
it'll take some roll calls and some
paperwork to get all that done and maybe
by the time we get that done we'll have
a copy of the amendment and we can
consider adopting the amendment
yes you may ask a question
procedurally
now that the bill is in the possession
of the house can the amendment can
senator waters make the amendment does
that have to be presented by a member of
the house
because the amendment was made
it
the amendment i'm assuming the amendment
was not voted on in the senate
and that is correct it now has to
be
presented by someone in the house i do
believe
maybe i'm wrong
the way it was explained to me is that
if an amendment is made by
a sponsor of a bill on the same day as
the bill is heard in public hearing
then it can be accepted from
this the
prime sponsor an amendment can be
accepted from our prime sponsor
can we make a quick call to paul because
my understanding was once the bill is in
the house it is in possession of the
house and the house is the one that acts
on it the senate cannot act on it
anymore
correct representative thomas um thank
you um
so based on my own experience uh this
year uh
maybe terminology but someone in the
committee here would have to introduce
the amendments
and and we vote on it
so that's based on my experience this
year with one of my bills
as far as i know the amendment has to
carry on the
um
that's that's just
i'm a mensch what can i say
okay so
help me understand do you want us to
call the clerk and ask if an amendment
with senator water's name on it can be
adopted by the committee is that what
you want that is correct
representative thomas would you go make
that phone call
thank you very much and we can vote on
reconsideration right now because we've
got whatever whatever we do we have to
reconsider right
all right so i need a motion to
reconsider representative harrington
would you
having voted on the prevailing side
would you make such an emotion yes i
moved to reconsider uh sb 270 as passed
by the senate
and representative mcgee would you
second that motion yes i will second
that motion okay it's been moved and
seconded that we reconsider our
vote
of ought to pass on senate bill 270.
we're going to call the roll in just a
minute and i urge all members to vote
yes
on reconsideration
okay are we straight
on what we're about to do
uh representative harrington moved and
representative mcgee seconded the motion
to reconsider senate bill 270.
so while madam clerk is
finishing her paperwork
what we will do is if this motion passes
which i
certainly hope that it does
is then we will
need a
another motion
[Music]
to
vote
on the motion of ought to pass on 270
and ask everybody to vote no
that restores house senate bill 270 to
its original state
and then we can adopt them on a motion
a motion are you ready
all right so i asked the clerk to call
the role on the motion of
reconsideration
on senate bill 270.
representative harrington yes
representative mirner yes
clerk votes yes
representative barenzi
yes
representative bernardi
representative camberless
yes
uh representative
laugee
yes
representative white yes
representative samsich
yes
representative callie pitts yes
representative man yes
representative oxenon
yes representative lewicki yes
representative vincent
representative mcgee yes
representative gottling yes
representative leflam yes
representative pemento yes
representative partial
yes
representative vos yes
18-0 by a vote of 18-0 the motion to
reconsider senate bill 270
is adopted i would now entertain a
motion
to
ought revisit
pass motion on senate bill 270 and ask
every member to vote no representative
harrington
i move
we revisit the ought to pass motion on
senate bill 270. representative
samsich so i second that
it's been moved in seconded that we
vote again on the motion of ought to
pass on senate bill
270 and i ask all members to vote no
this time
okay madam clerk it's all yours
representative harrington no
representative murder no
clerk votes no
representative renzi
no
representative bernardi
representative kimbrells no
representative representative please
no
representative white no
representative
samsich
no
representative kelly pitts no
representative man no
representative oxen
no
representative lewicki no
representative vincent
representative mcgee
no
representative gottling no
representative laflamme no
representative pimento no
representative partial no
okay um representative vos
yeah uh no
oops
18-0 okay by a vote of 18 to nothing
[Music]
the motion about to pass on senate bill
270 is
defeated
and that restores senate bill 270 to its
original pristine
condition
and makes it amenable to
uh
an amendment however it appears that we
don't have an amendment just yet but
representative thomas has some news
about that amendment yes um well uh
learned something new every day
uh according to the clerk
the house cannot
introduce an amendment with the senate
on it
someone here has to take standard
water's amendment i'll do it down to ols
and get a house amendment number put on
it
so we can introduce it here it'll be
this it'll be the same amendment same
wording so you don't have to i think i
can call them
but we still need the actual
amendment here
with the house number on it
with a new number right
i assume they will because it has to be
a house amendment yeah it will have a
new number yes
kristen are you uh raising your hand
because you want to take care of this
for us
okay kristen we'll we'll take care of it
via email
but given the fact that it's going to
take ols at least 15 or 20 minutes to do
this uh i think we're just going to have
to wait
and take care of this
uh
executive session
later
we're not going to be able to do it now
so let's let's break for lunch now we're
going to do 4 24 or what we're going to
do for another one
uh
i thought you objected to that
representation
you asked me if i if i raised my hand i
just said no but
i don't object i thought we're going to
do score 24.
okay if the consensus is that you're
ready to
vote on house bill
or senate bill 424 then we can do that
and i will recognize
uh representative
lewicki for a motion
mr chairman i move out to pass on 424.
my representative can uh recognize
representative cam bruils
yes mr chair i'd like to second that
motion okay it's been moved and seconded
that we
judge senate bill 424 as ought to pass
is there any discussion on this question
uh representative partial
i know this puts
me within the minority with my own
caucus even but i am not prepared to
vote for a bill
that pumps more
greenhouse gas into our environment i do
not consider that a bridge technology
so i will be voting no on this
okay representative oxenam
thank you very much for taking my
question
comments
at this point thank you uh but we are in
the comments i
would second the uh remarks of uh my
esteemed colleague uh we did hear
testimony yesterday from the sierra club
that the air resources council in
california had conducted a study and
found that there was increased methane
from landfills that used this particular
technology
another issue we also heard from the
conservation law foundation that they
opposed this bill because of
difficulties predominantly with methane
leakage issues
um
and i i believe there was also a
brief discussion
about
using the natural gas on site and
transforming it into electricity and
then providing the electricity directly
into the grid rather than what what is
actually on the table with this bill the
reason liberty utility wanted to bring
it forward is so that they can truck
this gas
from a landfill to their
distribution network
so yeah and those greenhouse gas
emissions also of the transporting of
the fuel weren't taken into account and
my final concern is about increasing
more pipeline infrastructure for natural
gas
under the guise that it's going to be
natural
um i mean renewable natural
gas
when um in in fact
we're talking about a cap of five
percent so it looks to me like just a
way to expand
natural gas pipeline infrastructure in
the state
thank you representative we also heard
yesterday that flaring
that
gas
from
digestive resources
can actually
cause more emissions than
burning it in a in a clean and reliable
fashion
and we also heard yesterday that
california is mandating 12 percent
of renewable natural gas by 2030.
representative lewicki
thank you mr chairman
there are a number of technical issues
which may not have been discussed one of
which is that in new hampshire i believe
that landfill gas is coming out at a
slight negative pressure and this
business of churning the landfills is a
somewhat different situation and if
they're taking the gas out at negative
pressure i believe they're doing this in
nashua
and then generating on-site uh not
putting it into a pipeline but if that
is the case then it actually has to be a
net reduction in emissions rather than
an increase
further discussion representative callie
pitts
i'm not exactly sure of what i heard
from
representative oxenham but
i have the testimony of clean energy new
hampshire and they support 424.
representative pementel
thank you mr chairman uh there's
actually a couple issues that came up
one was had to do with the uh recovery
of prudently encored costs
related
to uh procuring
natural gas
and um
i i think the key is that it was a
may approve and not a shall approve
and that this is a pilot program so i i
don't i think we can let that one slide
it it there it may
possibly become
an issue but it on on the surface i
think
we can
go with that and the other issue which
has already been brought up
there's a lot of questions on
the the methane release
uh that is going to happen because of uh
the withdrawal of methane from these
landfills
i
you know i i don't think that's
something that we should
be dealing with in in this committee i
think that this has to go before the
commission
and that i
would hope that they would take all of
those things into consideration before
approving a project
representative harrington
thank you mr chairman um i think these
people had stated this is a coming
technology this ironically uh last night
i got an email from some group at the
bank of america which is holding a
conference on renewable natural gas and
so there's a lot of interest in this
across the country
and i think having a pilot program would
be wise for us to get ahead of it find
out the good the bad and the ugly and
see if we want to go forward but having
a pilot program would seem to make sense
because it is a technology that's being
pushed not just here but across the
country
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman
um
yes i i think we we do need to focus on
the fact that this is a pilot project
which means i think the timeline
involved was maybe three years to look
at this
uh if we don't take some action
proactively to look into it
uh we're never gonna get to some kind of
good result the the data that the sierra
club presented and i haven't read all of
it
but there are lots of information
throughout the country about
natural gas renewable natural gas and
depending on the condition under which
things are done they could be more
negative or more positive
however this
source here is local indigenous new
hampshire we have landfills and this is
one way of reaping some benefit from
those landfills and it has to be done in
an environmentally sensitive way
and that's what the pilot project will
will show what the best way to do it is
um
i don't buy necessarily this idea that
more is leaking or or more is flared if
you do that i i don't that's very
technical that has to be really verified
by a lot of organizations a pilot
project will do that we heard from
clean air new hampshire who supports
this we heard from the timberland
association that supports this
we heard from various people who think
this is worth exploring
and i think we should allow allow this
to go forward as a pilot project
representative mcgee
thank you mr chairman
um i'm i'm in agreement that i like the
idea of uh homegrown and varied you know
energy sources i i think we should be
doing that i think that my exception
with the bill is that although fuel
diversity is good and this is a
technology that's being explored
on the environmental considerations i
don't feel like the bill does put guard
rails in at the outset
even in what it's asking of the public
utilities commission it revolves mostly
around the economics and whether there's
viability or you know whether the
burdens are met that it's a value to
rate payers but again because no one is
is
explicitly being asked to determine
whether or not there's a net
in you know emissions up or down whether
those things are not accounted for in
the bill and that's the reason that i
have an exception to it i don't have an
exception to a pilot i don't have an
exception to the idea of trying to
figure out if there's a way for us to
leverage the landfills um
but i
i think i
i'm not
i think the the person who testified
yesterday who made the point that why
would we do the study after three years
because once it's in place for that long
it's it's a harder thing to undo
uh if it does have negative effects i
would like to see the bill modified so
that it says upfront
um
what we expect in terms of
the environmental impacts rather than
saying somebody down the line is going
to figure that out and it will be to the
benefit of the customer
and the environment
okay representative oxenam
thank you very much mr chair for giving
me the opportunity to correct my earlier
statement uh representative callie pitts
is absolutely right i misspoke uh if
cenh did support the bill it was the
conservation law foundation which was
the one that opposed the bill and in the
testimony of mr krakow uh for clf he
also spoke about the need for guard
rails and the fact that we're not we're
making no effort to determine what the
leakage is at the before we initiate so
we will have no baseline from which to
measure
this this is not a scientific approach
and i don't think that we should go
forward with this bill thank you
okay let's uh let's call the vote now on
senate bill 424 the motion is ought to
pass so i asked the clerk to call the
roll
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative lange
yes
representative mirner yes
the clerk votes yes
representative barenzi
yes
representative cambrils
representative plojay
yes representative white
yes
representative samsich yes
representative callie pitts
representative mann
no
representative oxenom
representative lewicki yes
representative vincent
representative mcgee no
representative gotling
yes
representative leflam yes
representative pimentel
no
representative partial
representative vos yes
okay by a vote of 15 to 5 the motion
carries and senate bill 424
is judged to be ought to pass
and with that we'll close the executive
session on
oh minority report are we going to need
a minority report
okay representative partial will create
the minority report and it is due no
later than noon tomorrow
no later than noon tomorrow okay
all right
okay we're gonna break now for lunch
representative lang thank you for uh
stepping in we appreciate it
we'll see you later this afternoon
so we're still working on an amendment
for senate bill 270. hopefully we'll
have that
in hand
we might attempt to do that exec session
really quickly
at 12 30 if we think we can do it in
five minutes
but i don't want to hold up the public
hearing on 271 for very long because
that's going to be a long public hearing
pardon
yes just technical changes okay with
that so we will now be officially in
recess until 12 30. thank you everyone
hey
you can get sandwiches
okay everybody
we're back
12 30.
time to have a public hearing on senate
bill 271.
this is a bill relative to the burgess
biopower facility we have
we have about eight people who would
like to speak on this bill today
so
i have allocated 90 minutes for this
public hearing we should be able to get
everybody in
and
i think we should get started as quickly
as possible to make sure that everybody
has a chance to speak
so i would like to begin the public
hearing by
asking the prime sponsor of this bill
senator jeb bradley to introduce the
bill to our committee and senator
bradley welcome to st e good to have you
back sir
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee glad to be back twice on
the same week
for the record uh jeb bradley from
wolfeboro and i just want to start out
by thanking
um all of the co-sponsors
of this bill
um i've been before this committee
before several times um advocating for
the biomass industry and in particular
um several years ago as the prime
sponsor of
uh senate bill 577 and i think uh
looking for representative thomas was
there he is instrumental in helping uh
get that filled through this committee
um in 2018
the way that the public utilities
commission interpreted that legislation
several years ago
with the what's called the cumulative
reduction factor
being suspended and accumulating and
then having to be repaid immediately
is causing or will cause a major problem
for burgess
when that bill comes due and the problem
that
burgess and they will be here to testify
has said it it is very likely that the
plant will
shut down
as you've heard me say on numerous
occasions
before this committee
having
75 megawatts
of
24 7 base load power
365 days a year that is renewable
and
far better than burning some of the
other types of hydrocarbon-based fuels
that
get burned in new hampshire for energy
it suits our
requirement for
not only renewable but
forest-based fuel
you've heard me talk
many times about the jobs impact
i think there will be people from berlin
today and i know there's a letter that
was sent to the city uh to the senate
from uh the mayor of berlin and i'm
assuming that
that letter has gotten to you folks too
about the particular impact that this
plant has
on the city of berlin
what this bill seeks to do
starting on line 19 the first findings
section talk about how we got to the
point that we got to the importance of
the
um bill on the forest products industry
but then on line 19 starting on line
line 19 non-withstanding the prior
orders
shall open a docket to amend any of its
orders as necessary to protect the
continued operation of the burgess
power plant
i think it is safe to say that when
senate bill 577 passed several years ago
there was an expectation
that that was a bridge to the future
but not meant as a cliff that once we
got to that point um through the way
that the settlement was structured at
the puc
that
would lead to a shutdown of this power
plant at that point in time but that's
what we're facing
um that is what this bill would help to
alleviate
you'll hear
um
[Music]
discussion i think from several of the
participants here about what it means
not only to berlin but on a statewide
basis it's about 70 million dollars
that's generated
annually
it has about it's responsible for about
um jobs
it's critically important because it's
along with the
independent wood plant in
[Music]
bridgewater yes
um the last of the biomass plants
operating
and
critically important for the low-grade
wood forest products industry if this
plant goes away that would be a
devastating impact i think this
committee has heard that testimony um in
the past
there is a cost to it i
um fully am aware of that cost
i believe that um
if this bill gets passed and signed into
law by pushing it back to the public
utilities commission with a specific
criteria
outlined in the bill to keep the plant
open
that
that will help
solve this problem and keep the plant
operating
one thing that
i hope will come out in the testimony
this afternoon
is that
this plant
over the last year since they've opened
their books for scrutiny which hasn't
happened in the past is nearly at a
break-even point because of higher
energy costs
so i i would hope that moving forward
the puc if this bill passes we're able
to take that into account
and able to restructure an agreement on
between
burgess eversource and the commission
that um
protects ratepayers obviously but also
keeps this plant um operating so at that
point mr chairman happy to try to answer
questions but i think some of the more
technical questions
probably better addressed to the folks
here from burgess
thank you senator bradley an excellent
introduction to this bill you mentioned
in your testimony that
577 was conceived to be a bridge to the
future
and i'm curious to know
if
this bill was passed and the puc
essentially forgave the 58 million
dollars
that you referred to as a cliff that
burgess is facing
what will happen beyond that will they
continue to accumulate
overcharges in the cumulative cumulative
reduction fund
and does this bill provide any way to
deal
with that
future accumulation
it leaves it in the hands of the puc
but what i mentioned at the end of my
testimony the fact that they're
operating at nearly a break-even point
because of
um higher wholesale electric rates given
the energy situation in the northeast
and quite frankly
all across this nation right now
it's at much more of a break-even point
i think you will also hear testimony
at the node
of where the power is delivered into the
grid that locational pricing
for this power plant is well below what
it would be at other points if it were
delivered in new england
and so
i think an argument can be made mr chair
that
the value of this power is being
undervalued as it gets sold back
to eversource and if that's accounted
for
the
situation that you're talking about with
ratepayer subsidies
may look a lot different i think the
other thing and i didn't mention this in
my testimony and i'd be remiss and not
talking about it i'm sure as you are
aware and this committee is aware
of the
stress
that
lack of
base load generation could potentially
have in new england per the independent
system operator now look i'm not going
to
say that 75 megawatts is the end-all
be-all but every bit helps especially
when it's a fuel source that we control
that it's not from outside this region
or outside this country that it is
renewable that it is 24 7 that it is 365
days a year exactly the kind of reliable
um source of power
that the grid operator
in new england thinks that we need to
have to prevent
you know a
rolling blackout type of situation that
i think none of us want
okay thank you additional questions for
senator bradley representative
harrington
yes thank you and uh thank you for
taking my question senator um
one thing you're implying that this
plant is up 24
7 365 days of the year are you stating
that it is 100 capacity factor
no it's not a 100 percent capacity
factor but it is a baseload plant that
can operate
um
all of the time except for you know that
kind of maintenance
and a follow-up follow-up uh you talked
about iso new england saying this is uh
essential for
um the grid security and preventing
blackouts so have you heard or
knowledgeable that if this plant were to
close down that iso new england would
insta instrument a rmr proceeding
reliability must run which they do to
plants that they say are required to run
for that because i have not heard that
maybe no i haven't heard that either but
the point i was making representative
harrington is that
at a time that the iso new england is
very concerned about
baseload power going offline
if this plant goes offline that just
contributes to
um
less reliable grid and less reliable
power in new england and i think that's
the issue that is it's generic factor
they're not specific to the yeah that's
generic yes and one final up go ahead uh
in the in your page they're on page two
and line 23
i find this uh
interesting wording it says the public
utilities commission shall open the
docket to amend any of its orders as
necessary to protect the continued
operation of the burgess plan
so we're basically instructing the the
puc to do whatever it takes how much it
takes whatever the expense is to keep
this plan operating is that intentional
and representative harrington i would
argue that was the intent of 577.
whatever it takes mega regardless of
cost
it's
the language is clear open a document uh
docket excuse me to protect the
continued operation yes thank you
okay representative callie pitts has a
question
thank you just like old times
um
can you just clarify for me
there's a 58 million dollar
i want to call it a loan
to uh burgess
would you envision
that loan being
extended in other words so that some
payments could be
worked out over perhaps a very long
period of time
or would you envision that more money
would need to be thrown into this
project
so
i would envision several things that the
actual
value of the power be allocated properly
that would reduce this
um cumulative reduction factor that's
one thing
and that the
crf be spread out over a longer period
of time so that it's not a cliff these
are all things that i think
the
public utilities commission would have
in their power through a settlement
proceeding
to
keep the plan open
okay additional questions for
senator bradley representative lewicki
okay thank you mr chairman thank you
senator um a couple of questions just
somewhat for clarification when you said
75 megawatts is that burgess alone or is
that all of the wood chip plants uh the
bridgewater plant is a about 15. so
burgess is 75. okay and you also said
that the only ones that were operating
were burgess and bridgewater that's
because i saw the one i came down 89 on
sunday afternoon and the one near
grantham was running
i'm not aware of that okay so anyway you
know
all right thank you
okay thank you any further questions
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
uh for
taking my question um
i i i want to kind of uh underscore or
ask you to
elaborate a little bit on
the
uh other
benefits that that plant provides aside
from this purely the energy component
and how that impacts all of
our new hampshire economy
and i also want to ask you um that if
that which would you agree with me that
you know as legislators whether
representatives or senators
i believe that one of our
one of our
priorities should be
to make sure we don't eliminate people's
jobs in new hampshire
so
thank you for the question obviously
there is a jobs impact um
i think that's very clear there's also
an impact on
jobs and
the health of the forest products
industry as people that work in the
forest products industry
and harvest low-grade wood have to have
an outlet for it or else it becomes
either
much more expensive or impossible i
suppose in some instances to be able to
dispose of that product
so
in order to maintain healthy forests
um where landowners are trying to
um
you know protect the long-term viability
of their of their forest harvesting
the low-grade wood to favor the
high-grade timber is very important
there needs to be an outlet for that so
that health of the forest along with
jobs
and
an indigenous renewable fuel source that
quite frankly grows in new hampshire i
think those are all pretty
valuable facets
thank you
additional questions representative
mcgee
thank you mr chairman and thank you
senator for taking my question
my question goes back to the three-year
suspension because i think when i was uh
you know
learning more about this particular
um
plant and the history
uh
i heard that there might have been a
misinterpretation on the part of the
public utilities commission in terms of
whether that suspension
uh was on the plant or or otherwise so i
wonder if you were around for that or if
you're familiar with how that came to be
if you could give us a little more
information about
what a three-year suspension was
intended to mean what it would what did
the suspension entail in terms of the
money so i did not intervene in that in
that docket at the puc so i wasn't part
of any of the discussions or what ended
up being the case but my understanding
is
that um
out of that proceeding
that was
what was agreed to and the plant was in
a position of kind of take it or leave
it and
that's why we're here today
okay
representative callie pitts
my follow-up question is the
money
that 58 million payback was suspended
was it suspended on the collection of
that payback for eversource in other
words has that 58 million been included
in rates
today i assume not but that's a question
that um others can answer
i think it might be but that's okay
thank you
thank you representative harrington
thank you mr chairman and i'm taking my
question one thing i've noticed on here
is there's no mention of the cost
there's no fiscal note there's the only
thing i see at the very end of the bill
it says
any relief ordered by the public
utilities commission not otherwise
funded by federal funds pursuant to this
section shall be fully recovered from
rate payers so i guess
first
when you say rate payers do you mean
just ever source rate payers all rate
payers in the state
of wholesale you know municipal rate
payers what is that limited to and how
much is the estimated cost going to be
it would depend on the estimated cost
would depend on what the commission
ordered for relief it would depend on as
i keep citing the value assigned to the
power which
i think you will hear testimony
representative harrington
is undervalued
and
um
in terms of the first part of your
question
the purchase power agreement is between
burgess and eversource so it's
eversource ratepayers
which is historically
for all utilities how purchase power
agreements have um
operated
thank you
okay representative bradley i have one
final question for you we received an a
letter from the office office of the
consumer advocate
in which the consumer advocate stated
that sb 271 as amended
would violate the divestiture settlement
as duly bargained by the office of the
consumer advocate on behalf of
eversource residential customers
could you explain
i don't know how to respond to that so
probably best if i don't respond to it
as somebody that was involved in the
divestiture docket
um
it was really about power plants that
were owned yes contracts like this were
involved in it but um
i'm not sure it would violate it
but that's just my opinion okay thank
you
representative oxenoum has a question
thank you very much mr chair thank you
senator
the springfield plant was uh mentioned
by my colleague representative levicky
when when when the prices get high
enough the those plants do run as peaker
plants to
maximize their uh return
and it brings up the point which i don't
think has been clarified here that this
this plant makes a big difference
statewide and the low the low-grade
timber is a problem that is statewide
sullivan county
certainly
is critically involved here we have a
tourist-based economy if we have an
accumulation of low-grade wood in the
forest that's going to impact
cross-country skiing hiking tourism it's
also going to be a fire hazard there are
numerous values that are provided by
having a market for low-grade wood that
really have
not just ripple effects have substantial
effects on representative oxygen are you
asking a question or making a speech
i'm i'm sorry i am having difficulty
moving from the public hearing to the
executive session and back to the public
hearing and not and and making this a
question so if i may ask you
do you agree with that
thank you i think that's what my
testimony indicated
okay thank you senator bradley we
appreciate your testimony we know you're
a busy man and you have a lot to do
thank you
next i would like to call to the
witness table representative edith
tucker
good afternoon representative welcome to
scne thank you
thank you for welcoming me
i
it's hard to follow senator bradley a
very accomplished
uh and very knowledgeable about this
topic
i'm knowledgeable because i live in
coast county i'm knowledgeable also
because i was a reporter for 25 years
for the coast county democrat and
covered the closing of the mills the
opening of the biopower plant
and
it is a very important aspect
economically in berlin
it is also as
people have already mentioned
very important to the forests
that we have a market for low-grade wood
it's important the wildlife it's
important to recreation
but i think at the moment
here in april of
2022 it's important that we have
redundancy
of our power sources
particularly those that are
rooted in a new hampshire product that
is the wood we grow
i think we've all experienced going to
the store and seeing bare shelves
i think we do worry about rolling
blackouts particularly in a day and age
when
the highest use of electricity is no
longer in the winter
but now in the summer because of
rising temperatures and people being
more used to air conditioning
i myself have had to buy fans
uh even in randolph
but it's that
enormous change that i think we're all
grappling with
that has happened with
russia attacking the ukraine
the kind of disruption in the supply
chains that's been going on since the
pandemic began
we really are in a different world and
we have a changing global economy
and it affects us here in new hampshire
it seems
remarkable
that we would be talking about taking an
up-to-date
biomass plant with fluidized beds and
all the bells and whistles
of an up-to-date
biomass plant and thinking of closing it
at a time when we need to know
that we have this base load
capacity right here
that we still have the forest industry
with people with cut to length machines
ready to go out and do forest
harvesting
those
investments
in the biomass plant
in all the equipment that goes out with
lagers today
i went to a lecture maybe 20 years ago
by a unh professor who said if you can't
think lie in bed at night and think
about owing a million dollars don't go
in today today's logging business
that's what you're talking about this is
an industry it's no longer
a few people going out and
with
uh
saws or chainsaws this is a big industry
it needs to continue
at the rate that it now is if it's going
to survive
and i personally think we need to
support
new hampshire products we need to
support new hampshire employees
this is a very important step
to consider closing a plant of this
magnitude
so i ask that you
give every consideration
to
preserving what is very important to the
whole state and of course to my home
county
thank you very much
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um as you spoke about um that you know
the the value to the economy
i i'm struck by i had received a letter
from a constituent who is a landowner he
owns forest land
and it strikes me that that's another
piece of the argument here is sort of
keeping land
in the hands of people in new hampshire
who are landowners because what he when
he wrote to me he said he had
450 acres
and that the value of him being able to
keep hold of that land had to do with
him being able to sell his timber and so
i wonder if if you are aware at all of
that being another of the downstream
impacts that would happen if new
hampshire's low-grade wood is not in use
because he basically said the value of
my land is in that low-grade timber
absolutely and i think we know
from the tax
property tax arrangements here in new
hampshire that that's long been known
that we need to make it possible for
keep people to keep forests we know that
the snowmobiling industry and now the
atv industries
are dependent on the goodwill of private
landowners and opening up their
properties
to
other people using it and
not
charging for that
are it's a part of the fabric of new
hampshire's travel and tourism industry
and uh
everything depends on
the other things and
the markets are just very very important
for this low grade wood i didn't quite
understand that when i first got into it
but now i've seen a lot of wood
low-grade wood drive by my house
and on route 2
and
one knows that it is necessary and it in
order to have high grade wood
which can turn into saw logs
and allow that take it
make it
important that we
have first that can grow big and tall
and thick
you have to remove
the low-grade wood you have to have some
kind of income stream to support that
owner whether it's a teemo one of the
industrial forest investment companies
that are here in new hampshire and
throughout northern new england or
whether it's an individual
who depends on
being able to help send their
grandchildren to college
by
well-timed timber harvesting it's it's
it's an integrated
and remarkably
interdependent relationship between all
these factors
in new hampshire and when i first
started reporting on it when people said
oh well it's like moving a table you
know everyone just moves it along an
inch or two and it's all together
i thought
couldn't be
but that is the way it is and this
plant
is one of those lifts that's absolutely
essential
representative samsung has a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
in light of the fact that you've been
living up there for a long time and had
reporting duties to do as well
i would assume that you have followed
the trajectory of what has happened when
the paper mills closed
and when the other biomass plants who
are no longer in business also closed
and you probably saw firsthand
what the impact was locally in your area
can you describe some of that to us
well
it's hard to describe we're talking
about thousands and thousands of jobs
and on the way we're talking about
people who lost the pensions they
thought they were going to be able to
depend on
they lost their health insurance
they often weren't paid
so on their last
jobs and loads of
of wood that they brought they never
were paid for that
and
it had a devastating effect and
remarkably
people are resilient they do find other
things to do
but we're still losing population
of course we think that
being able to work remotely will make a
big difference
that there's been a turnaround and
people
wanting to live near the outdoors and so
forth but
there is an interrelationship between
all these things that's hard to describe
the groveton mill that
took low-grade wood and made it into
uh
you know the things you pallets
so it's pallet wood too
and what happened when the pallet market
ended when people weren't shipping
things out they didn't need pallets
and
the temptation of course was to toss
them in the river
uh which i'm happy to say didn't happen
much but
it uh there is an interdependency
of our economy with the forests and the
unincorporated places
the places people want to fish
places people want to go hunting
they're here partly because of those
markets for low-grade wood so i i don't
know the technical parts that many other
people who are here can
talk to you about but i wanted to give
you the big picture
of what it's like
to be in koas koas is an outdoor place
and the forests are an integral part
and the people who depend on those jobs
they're a very important part too
thank you representative tucker
we also have another representative from
the north country representative the
verge who would also like to speak with
us
oh i'm sorry representative harrington
had a question for
representative tucker
yes please
oops thank you mr speaker thank you
taking my question
it appears looking at this build what
it's going to do is require all the ever
source rate payers in the state to pay
an extra subsidy to this biomass plant
so we can stay open and the idea is what
i hear from you is that this has all
sorts of benefits besides just the plan
itself in coast county
so i would ask do you think this is a
pertinent economic plan for the state
let's say
uh the apple growers in the central and
southern part of new hampshire decided
to come up and said we can't make enough
money uh selling apples anymore so we're
going to sell all our apple farms and
we're going to let them go to condos or
whatever should they then be a fee
charge to everybody that buys produce in
new hampshire to subsidize the apple
farmers or maybe the lobster fishermen
say they can't make enough money so
should they be able to collect the fee
from everybody to you
probably the difference is
that apples much as i love them
are not essential
to our life i think the apple farmers
would disagree with you well
i don't think the lobstermen or the
apple growers would say that
their product was in the same category
as electricity in this state
we have a place where renewable energy
from a local product can be manufactured
here in new hampshire
it is really a very special thing and
now that we see
how
vulnerable
we are to rapid change and that's what
we've been experiencing in the last two
years
so it was march 2020 that we began to
really understand what the pandemic was
going to bring us
we're still not at the end of it
we now have
a really horrific war going on an open
war between two countries
we have a very disrupted world
we have a chance here
to keep stability that is operating at
the moment
and i think
this
i know the word subsidy i'm a good
capitalist too
and that word
is not a pleasant one to hear
but stability is very important and i
think it's worth the cost
okay thank you representative tucker
representative the barge
good afternoon uh you know mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
representative robert thibos
representing coast iii
the city of berlin
uh as well as a representative i'm also
a member of the city council
i'm going to be extremely brief
i want the committee to seriously take
into consideration
the positive economic impact
that the plant has not only for berlin
for coast county in the state as well
that being said and i want to be brief i
will not entertain any questions
not because i disrespect the committee
there are people behind me who are
better suited to answer questions that i
cannot
do justice to but more importantly there
you have a time constraint and i want to
give those people the ability to come
forth and before you and testify that
being said thank you very much for
listening to me
thank you representative we appreciate
your consideration
and now i'll call on another north
country representative representative
hatch
uh thank you mr chair thank you
committee members i'm representative
william hatch representing the beautiful
town of warm
shelburne
in seven unincorporated areas my last
name is not burton so i cannot name them
all off the top of my head but
nevertheless
um
it's i'm thank you for having me and and
to me and many people throughout the
state this is a very important issue
um there's i'm not an expert in this
field
but i cannot overemphasize what has been
mentioned in terms of forest management
my family's business is cars but my
sister who runs it now
has
several
a few thousand acres of forest land in
maine
and i don't know if you remember this
when this occurred and i think it's
germane to this uh that horrific ice
storms in the middle eighties maybe
a lot of forest land was was damaged and
and
destroyed so to speak
um she had spent several thousand
dollars going into the timberland
which is mostly high grade lumber
to clean that mess up and had no place
to put it at the time and that's the
low-grade wood we're talking about um so
in terms of forest management and all of
our safeties in every county
um this is vitally important to have
available to us
the cost
well
i i serve on finance and
i was in business many years
and the relevance and the importance of
this somebody asked how did this
impact the closing of the mills how did
it impact colosse county
um
i could give you
uh this anecdotal for sure but i can
explain it this way best from my
perspective
i moved there
in 1977 i bought a business in berlin
and
it allowed me
to
raise six wonderful children educate
them all
and retire at a relatively young age and
it's wonderful and part of my due
diligence
prior to buying that business
was you check out the area you check out
the economic stability of the area and
one thing in doing that i found that
there was
between fifteen and sixteen thousand
paper workers
in the in coast county
and those paperworks workers got a
reasonable wage and there was at the
time
stability in their employment
and that was one of the things that
spurred me to buy that business and uh
through the years i employed over 30
people and
would like to hope that i was part of
the economic benefit of of that and that
might speak best to how that impacts it
was impacted because right now i believe
there's
a little less than 200 paper workers in
cowas
county fifteen sixteen thousand two
hundred and
plus um and that's
really speaks to the impact the closing
of the mills had to cost county as far
as the cost and one thing
i try to do in my position in finance
and in my life
is is i try to look cost benefit ratios
now to the question of the race payer's
going to pay this this was already
absorbed by us
just consider that
and i suspect and i'm talking about
impact of rates i suspect that one
person
had to turn their lights off for one
minute
i i suspect not one person
had to change their way of life
dramatically
um absorbing this cost because it was
spread out amongst us all
and and microly the impact
cost is de minimis
but the advantages are vast macrally we
can come up and say well this is costing
such and such million dollars over a
period of
time collectively putting the whole
thing together multiplying by whatever
period of time you come up with
and you can talk about millions and
millions of dollars depending on the
period of time and depending
on how much you collect
but i don't even know that that's
truly relevant at this point
if we could quantify the benefits
and there's many life benefits that are
hard to quantify with dollar and cents
compared to the cost um
there is really an equitable because i i
just truly believe and kind of know
the benefits from this plan for the
entire state not just carlos county very
important to us of course
it's our last horse
um but
it really um
has a
wide reaching benefit for every county
in the state
um forest management
lumber comes from low grade com london
comes from every county in the state
so there's also a widespread economic
benefit
and cost
we already absorbed it
and it really did not damage our overall
economy and i don't believe it damaged
anybody's personal position in life and
i would just ask you to really look at
that and consider that because i think
it's relevant and very important thank
you mr chair
thank you representative hatch
representative callie pitts has a
question for you
as long as it's not technical
i'm a car guy so go ahead
they just had to move mine because the
kid they were going to hit it with the
trailer um
my question uh
representative hatch is
apparently or i'm hearing that you know
they might need more money that that
burgess might need more money
i just wanted to ask you a question from
your position on another committee
is there money available
for
a plant like burgess from some of the
federal funds
that we have collected
i i i can't answer that because i
that would only be answered at the time
it comes it's it's a it's an important
question but it's not something that i'd
even be appropriate on my part to speak
to but thank you for the question
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative hatch for coming here and
talking to us about this
um
i just want to ask you obviously it's a
question that's more a hypothetical
question
but
if you knew
i mean if if you were to ask new
hampshire residents
whether they would be willing to
pay a small surcharge on their energy
use
in exchange for keeping new hampshire
jobs and securing them
do you think that people would be more
favorable uh more than half would say
that or not
well i only can speak
for myself and now in those terms and i
can only speak for my extended family
um
very much so yes and uh the circles that
i travel in
uh my friends very much yes um and i
just have to add as i'm one of those
that
send a couple dollars extra to the power
company so those that might not be able
to pay their bill
it gets paid um and
where i grew up that was part of my
responsibility to society
that we're all in this thing together
and none of us know how long
and
i want to have as much fun as i can and
keep this mind as clear as i can thank
you
okay thank you representative hatch we
appreciate
representative partial has a question
very quick question thank you chair uh
is your testimony available to the
committee
did i no i have that was um no
awesome that's fine thank you off the
shoulder
okay thank you representative hatch
thank you committee attention
mr all right
so now i'd like to call to the witness
table uh
burgess biopower
so sarah
boone boone like daniel like daniel
boone
looks like the way you wrote it here it
looks like b-o-o-r-e but that's okay
and damon becker
or is it frecker
frecker okay
they are uh representing the burgess
biopower plant and are here to testify
on behalf of senate bill 271 please hand
those out
yes please thank you
sorry
so good afternoon
as representative said my name is sarah
boone and i am here with my colleague
damon frecker to speak on behalf of
burgess biopower
i'm the vice president of public affairs
and he is the asset manager for the
plant and we appreciate your time today
um i'd like to just
say that i'm going to be as brief as
possible
but i think
before we get into
sb 271 and what it does i'd first like
to speak about what it doesn't do
sb 271 does not impose any new costs on
ratepayers and the bill does not ask for
any additional relief for burgess
biopower going forward
the costs under consideration have
already been collected
this bill is narrowly focused
legislation that was only introduced to
correct how sb 577 was implemented at
the public utilities commission
as senator bradley had mentioned the
purpose of 577 was to provide burgess
with limited financial relief for a
finite period of time
it did that by suspending the operation
of the cap on the cost override
mechanism in burgess's power purchase
agreement for three years
in passing that bill the legislature
intended that the costs that were
accrued during the three-year suspension
period would be borne by rate payers not
burgess
which is supported by the fiscal note
attached to the bill when it passed as
well as other testimony and supporting
documents
the regulatory process to implement sb
577 took over 18 months
during which the facility reached its
100 million dollar cap
burgess was then faced with a choice
between either accepting a settlement
that didn't reflect the legislative
intent of sb 577 or suffer the economic
damage that the legislation was supposed
to have prevented
burgess reluctantly accepted a
settlement that deferred costs during
the three-year period but did not
forgive them
the final order on that proceeding was
issued in february of 2020 and i think
that we all know what happened after
that
when the world changed
probably irrevocably
and our focus shifted immediately to our
role as an essential energy
infrastructure
now burgess must repay the sb 577
three-year suspension costs in a single
year beginning this december which will
financially devastate the plant
the repayment will occur in monthly
increments where the amount due will be
withheld from burgess's monthly energy
payment
the monthly repayment amount will be
millions of dollars more than burgess's
monthly revenue which means the facility
would operate at an unsustainable loss
each month and would be forced to close
i'd like to just once again reiterated
that costs associated with sb 577 have
already been collected from from
ratepayers
sb 271 imposes no new costs and to
answer representative rose's previous
question burgess is not requesting any
additional support we assume the full
risk and responsibility going forward
any future over market costs would be
burgess's responsibility and i think
it's important to note that burgess
returns more than three times its cost
and economic benefit to the entire state
each year
passage of 271 will help ensure burgess
biopower's ongoing operation and the
energy economic and environmental
benefits that the facility provides
which damon will describe in more detail
thank you sarah
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to be with
you this afternoon and speak on behalf
of sb271 uh on behalf of burgess
biopower as sarah indicated i am the
asset manager for the facility i have
the technical fiscal and regulatory
responsibility for the execution of the
plan on a day-to-day basis
um
i think that some of the speakers that
have come before us and some that will
come after us have done a really good
job and will do an even better job and
speaking to the myriad of benefits that
the project brings to the state uh
energy economic environmental um and
employment
i think what i'd like to try to do is
try to put some of that into perspective
right
so burgess is the fourth largest
generator of power in new hampshire the
three generators that are larger rely
upon natural gas and nuclear power so
it's the only plant that is providing
500 000 megawatt hours of class 1
renewable energy to the state of new
hampshire on a very very reliable basis
and to representative harrington's
question about is it 100
no it averages about 92
which according to black beach
management consulting one of the largest
consulting organizations on earth is
among the five percent top performing
power plants in the country
the power that burgess produces is
sufficient to power 67 000 new hampshire
homes so it's not a trivial piece it's
about 10 percent of
of the homes in new hampshire
and as senator bradley pointed out it is
base load power uh that is dispatchable
by iso
it can be called upon and we run pretty
much 24 7. we do take two weeks of
outage every year to maintain the plant
we basically tear it apart and rebuild
it so it can run another six months
um
so it's a critical source of energy
diversity and and grid stability that's
a really important piece um from the
energy sector it's not powered on
natural gas so that when consumers
residents here in new hampshire need gas
to heat their homes burgess isn't
consuming that gas and it's available to
them and the grid operators we've all
heard and read numerous times has warned
us about the over alliance 60 of our
fleet right now in new england that is
powered by natural gas
burgess also has a significant
environmental benefit
and i know that sheila conley from
resource management is here
and we'll speak to that further but rmi
recycles the fly ash that we produce in
our boiler um so in
um we recycled over 20 000 tons of fly
ash from our boiler that was
beneficially reused as an agricultural
amendment on farmers farms over 4 000
acres of farms 70 different farms
around the area
so again
it's not this is not just a north
country issue and it's not just a
forestry
harvester trucker issue it impacts a
number of businesses in a very wide
geographic reach
and i'll let jason stock speak more to
the overall forestry management but
again to put things in perspective
burgess buys about 800 000 tons of
low-grade wood a year that's in excess
of 25 million dollars that gets injected
into the forestry economy and with our
testimony you'll see a map of the great
state of new hampshire with a bunch of
trees on it
those trees represent every single
location from which burgess biopower
received wood in 2021
the little burgess icon is way up here
in the north country but boy by the
amount of trees down here you'd think we
were probably located in concord
i'd say that this facility has a much
greater impact upon land managers and
landowners
in the southern tier of the state than
it does in the northern tier
and again jason can speak to it with
more authority than myself but
one of the challenges that those land
managers have is getting the money
that's necessary to properly maintain
their land or else they can just sell it
for development and that's what's
happened to a lot of the forestry that
is a lot of the forest that is no longer
forest
um
we've heard a lot about the economic
impacts of the facility
70 million dollars in annual economic
activity to the state so we are looking
to
erase a
58 million dollar number um so that the
state can continue to have 70 million
dollars of economic activity in
perpetuity for the life of the plant
on a cost benefit analysis i wouldn't
say i would say that that's probably not
too bad a deal
um burgess injects
about five million dollars into the city
of berlin in taxes and fees and
interestingly burgess is the only power
plant that i know of and i've been doing
power projects for 35 years that shares
its revenue with the toast community so
we take a portion of the revenue that we
generate from the sale of renewable
energy certificates and we give that to
the city of berlin that's totaled about
1.5 million dollars over the past three
years
and really we're trying to do something
more than just be
a power generator right my colleagues
have heard me say this expression too
many times that
we like to say we're doing something
besides just chewing chips and making
megawatts
we're trying to be a good active member
of our community
and facilitate economic development in
the community we've worked very
diligently with the city for about a
three year period now to design a system
that can extract thermal energy from our
cooling water system and heat the city
streets in the winter time that may
sound like a far-fetched notion but it's
been done in several locations across
the country
including the university of michigan and
east lansing
and so we continue to be very interested
in that we have talked with what was
gore and paper and tissue now white
mountain tissue about supplying them
with a portion of our cooling water loop
that is warm water one of the greatest
costs in paper making is heating water
so we're still continuing uh we continue
to be very interested in doing that as
well
we cleared land we did explorations we
did all kinds of work to facilitate the
development of a greenhouse
unfortunately that company
decided that they had other projects
that they needed to focus on first and
foremost we worked with a number of
cryptocurrency miners in developing site
plans and figuring out how they could
inter connect to us and and and get
power from us
we're continuing to do those things we
want to do those things um to help us
with our overall economics but to help
the region
um
and and continue to grow and i think the
most important point
or piece of this whole thing to me
is the guy who's responsible for 29
people that work at the plan are the
people
so we have 29 people that work at our
plant many of them came to us
from the closure of the pulp mill
and we have several families that now
have multiple generations at our plant
so
the senior person in the family said
sarah i know a great place for you to
work um and we have multiple generations
so we're doing one of the things that we
wanted to do which is to attract younger
people into the area to to try to stem
the brain drain from people leaving the
region that have a good place to work
that is a challenging interesting
high-tech place to work
and i think we're doing that fairly well
and those people are they function as a
family they watch each other's back it's
a closely knit group it's a great group
to be involved with but in addition to
those 29 people in their families
there's over 150 different companies
that cross our truck scales every year
delivering wood to burgess biopower
those are small typically family-owned
businesses that are truckers and
foresters and harvesters that have
reaped all the challenges of the other
closures of the biomass plants and the
like
and then in 240 jobs statewide and so
that's the most important part from my
perspective and we urge you to support
sp2 sb 271 as ought to pass as sarah
pointed out the legislation has a very
limited scope it has no additional cost
the costs have been paid for and the
impact to new hampshire is critically
important
thank you
thank you i have two questions one for
mr
um
frecker and one for miss boone
first question for mr frecker
you mentioned that 800 000 tons of wood
were brought to the plant every year how
many
uh
truck
trucking
uh visits does that represent
and
is there any way you could
estimate how much
uh co2 emissions are generated by all
those truck trips
i have not done the uh the co2 calculus
mr chairman um but if you consider that
we had 800 000 tons of wood delivered
and truck loads of wood are about 33
tons i don't have my calculator with me
but you can do that math 33 tons you
said yeah
okay thank you and for ms boone i have a
question you said that
um
that
uh
in 2018
the company agreed to the settlement
agreement with the puc
if you didn't think that that settle
agreement was correct why did you agree
to it
because we didn't feel like we had
another choice we had reached the 100
million dollar cap during the 18-month
long puc process and it was either
agreed to a settlement that we didn't
feel reflected the actual intent of the
bill or to shut down at that time
so the consumer advocate has written
that if order number 26233
was misinterpreting
the 2018 legislation
burgess biopower should not have
explicitly agreed to these terms instead
the company should have sought appellate
relief at the new hampshire supreme
court did you consider doing that so we
have a response prepared to that letter
i we have not submitted it yet uh our
our regulatory i'm sorry our regulatory
attorney is here and can speak to those
issues in more detail if you would like
her to but i think um as someone who is
certainly not an attorney i can say that
the um the way the order was written the
commission did not rule on the issue of
cost recovery which is what would have
been appealable and there was nothing to
appeal and we were out of time
it was agree or go away
does your attorney maybe i should ask
the attorney this but
is there any
concern
that if the legislature
essentially overrules a puc
decision
with this legislation
that that could interfere with
contractual rights secured to ever
source rate payers under article 1
section 10 of the united states
constitution and article or part 1
article 23 of the new hampshire
constitution good afternoon
representative vo's carol hollahan from
the law firm of foley hoag i serve as
regulatory counsel
for burgess i represented burgess in the
puc hearing these issues were briefed
for the public utilities commission in
docket 10 195 right after senate bill
577 the puc declined to rule on them
that included both the constitutional
issues and the cost recovery issue
within the legislation by the time the
settlement was agreed was reached it was
almost december of 2019 the cap had been
reached and there was nothing appealable
at that time so sarah's testimony is
absolutely accurate that they were
forced into a corner of uh accepting a
settlement that was not beneficial to
them um or excuse me accepting a
settlement that did not reflect what
they felt or we felt was the intent of
senate bill 577
and
be faced with immediate economic
hardship or to take what we could get to
live to fight another day with respect
to the constitutional issues burgess
does not believe this
the legislature is
entitled according to the new hampshire
supreme court to
enact legislation that affects cons that
affects private contractual rights
provided that there is a legitimate and
specific purpose and provided that the
um
the remedy it has chosen is reasonable
and necessary
i don't think there's any question that
the findings section of senate bill 577
demonstrates a legitimate
purpose to which the legislature was
responding and i think the
solution it shows by enacting
relief for a discrete three year period
of time that was very narrow both in
time and
or very narrow in time
would pass the supreme court's test of
necessary
reasonable and necessary okay thank you
for that explanation
we have six more people who want to
speak on this bill i just want to alert
everyone to that uh reality uh
representative thomas has a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um first of all a very good testimony
thank you
and i agree with most of what you're
saying having been raised
somewhat in north country in orford but
being very familiar with the forest
industry as well
and i particularly heard you very
clearly when you said that
this bill would only
relieve you of the three years of
payments and that you would expect or
get anything else going forward and was
i correct in that yes
follow please
so um what i'm concerned about not so
much with you but with this bill
is that
on the near the bottom of the first page
it
implies that that we would be directing
the puc
to
basically amend any orders as necessary
to protect the continued operation of
burgers buyer plant
so
my concern is
if the puc and we don't know what's
going to happen because they're in a
flux of change now with doe coming
forward we don't know who's going to be
there making decisions by the time this
comes forward
if the puc were to say
oh we think this should be permanent and
that you should never have to make a
payment
um
would you accept that or would you say
no we'll we'll rely on what we said here
and that will only you know pay back the
three years or uh i'm concerned that
this that what what might happen at the
pc is they may make a ruling that may be
more in your favor where the ratepayers
would continue to pay forever um and
that wouldn't be on you on puc but i'm
concerned if what what would be your
response
of to this bill the way it's worded is
is that a possibility that you would
consider
well i think we've been
quite explicit in what we're asking for
here
and that is
what we believe the intent of sb 577 was
was that we would not be accruing those
charges during the three year suspension
period we have no attention to overreach
from what we believe the legislature
proposed before we are simply trying to
follow
what sbc 577
we believe it was supposed to do and
that's all we want to do and we'll go
away
thank you
okay next up representative uh
harrington
thank you mr chairman thank you thank my
question i have about 50 questions but
obviously i'm not going to ask that many
because of time factor so i'll try to
limit it to just two
do you have a
capacity supply obligation in the
forward capacity market in the future
yes we do and what year would that be
for
we
renew our capacity supply obligation in
every fcm
and it's
65.2 megawatts
for
2024. as as the years go forward
thank you the second question uh it
follow up to what representative thomas
said
you're very explicit here uh
this bill imposes no new cost on rate
payers and burgess is not requesting any
additional support we assume full risk
and responsibility going forward
so having read that i could assume then
we could
change or take out some of the portions
of this bill where it says the public
utilities commissions open the document
mending the orders as necessary to
protect the continued operation of
burge's bible power plant provided there
is no additional cost to the ratepayers
and then at the end we could amend it by
saying in just getting rid of this line
that says any relief ordered by the
public utilities commission not
otherwise funded by federal funds and
pursuant to this section shall be fully
recovered from rate payers because
you're saying there's no additional cost
so you would have no objection to
removing those sections of amending the
bill as such
i believe that the the last phrase that
you
described was actually specifically
requested to be included in the bill by
eversource so that is probably a better
question for them
well okay getting back can follow up
getting back to the the first part about
it then if it was i'll leave that
forever source but the part that says
the puc shall do whatever is necessary
and we if you would object to saying
provided there's no additional cost to
the ratepayers would you agree with that
language if you're not going to if
you're saying you're going to take full
responsibility and risk going forward
i think i'd like to have the opportunity
to confer with our council before enough
fair enough thank you oh she's right
there
clearly
clearly representative that is our
intent
okay
uh representative lowicky is recognized
for a question uh thank you mr chairman
and just for information that's 24 000
trucks
and my question is um i was looking at
an email from last january
and
recently prior to that the price of oil
had gone negative in the market you
could they were paying you 37 a barrel
to take oil away and we're now somewhere
in the range of 100 so we've got this
137 dollar swing
plus and minus of zero
at what
price of oil gas or some other uh fossil
fuel would you be able to break
even can't really tie it to a
fuel price representative because it
depends upon what assets within the
overall
iso new england fleet are operating on
those fuels and what their efficiencies
are and myriad other issues about node
connections and the like um but your
point is extremely well taken right you
know a a week ago just one week ago oil
was sitting at 110 a barrel and gas was
just under five
one week later
oil is at 94 and gas has increased by
over 25 percent
recognizing that 60 percent of the fleet
is powered on that fuel that has a
significant impact to the overall cost
of power
yeah please
and
how does that affect you if uh for
instance gas plants are running
uneconomically does that mean that you
can charge more money for your
electricity it doesn't
our power price is is fixed over the
long the 20-year ppa so even when power
prices are skyrocketing we do not
financially benefit from that our ppa
provides price certainty over a long
period of time for a certain amount of
power
okay we have
18 minutes left in this public hearing
and i very much want to hear from the
department of energy
so i think uh we will thank you for your
testimony on this legislation and ask mr
franz of the department of energy to
speak to us
could you speak with him offline
will it be a quick question
okay ask your question very quickly
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um earlier in
testimony there was discussion about uh
where the node is located as far as its
input into the grid and i understand
that you're an asset of the iso new
england i don't know
where all the other assets are located
in new hampshire and juxtaposition to
each other but i did note that there was
also an allusion to the fact that um
that that power was going into the grid
lower than
other
power entering the grid and there was
also a discussion of the the valuation
of that power being valued appropriately
so i i think before we lose you on the
stand i would like to know if you have
anything to say about that that accurate
valuation that maybe we are not aware of
i could simply show you the information
from
iso's data files that show the
locational marginal price at various
nodes and you'll see that the berlin
node is typically five plus percent
lower than all of the other nodes if i
was whitefield if i was bridgepower
bridgewater if i was tamworth um all of
those are getting
above us and how does that help us
though can you just explain what that
means well
what it does is it it essentially
artificially devalues the power that
burgess generates when compared to the
rest of the market
thank you okay now let's hear from the
department of energy and mr tom franz
welcome mr franz good to see you good to
see you too chairman bose
good afternoon and good afternoon to the
members of
st e
for those who don't know me i'm tom
france the director of regulatory
support at the new hampshire department
of energy
most of you probably knew me before when
i was at the public utilities commission
and director of electricity
the department of energy appreciates the
opportunity to provide comments today on
senate bill 271.
as you know back in 2018 senate bill 577
was signed into law which directed the
puc to amend its order that approved the
ppa between psnh
and berlin biopower we'll just say
burgess at this point senate bill 577
suspended the operation of the cap on
the cumulative reduction factor for
three years as you've heard throughout
testimony today
that excess amount over the cumulative
reduction factor
is about 50.7 million as of the end of
and eversource forecasts in a recent
filing with the puc and and with the
department of energy that that would
go to about 58
59 million dollars by the end of
november of 2022. as you know the way
the ppa works that
excess amount over the 100 million
dollars would be re
funded essentially through a reduction
in in the price of energy in the ppa
over the following 12 months power year
as stated earlier that money has been
collected or is being collected from
ratepayers
and so
they've paid it um
it would go back to customers if the
plant continued to operate it's uh
questionable whether that would occur
and that that's been raised also
previously
our position however is that however
well intentioned senate bill 577 was and
i could take issue with that the puc at
the time did not understand
the intent of the of the bill uh that's
and for the record i will take issue
with that i think the order is clear
about what would happen at the end of
the three years and the commission
stated so in the order
and
uh as you've heard nobody appealed it we
could talk about why or that didn't
happen but we are where we are
the question now though is
this was in five senate senate bill 577
was intended to be a bridge
and and
we should ask today a bridge to wear a
bridge to what
there's no indication that these above
energy costs
uh
although
lower today than they were will go away
um i wish that were the fact
although we'd have high
wholesale market prices if that were in
fact the case
but
we see no
rosy picture here
um
we do appreciate that this won't
increase rates that this is a simple
bill that actually just
keeps the ppa in place
but it doesn't
nothing but postpone what's going to
happen a year from now
uh it's very likely that
we'll be at the same place with
the
100 million dollars cumulative reduction
factor being triggered
and a question about whether the plant
will run and how much that will be and
what will happen at that time
so for those reasons
the department of energy opposes senate
bill 271 as amended
and i'm happy to take
any questions you may have
thank you
representative harrington has a question
thank you mr chairman i think you've
taken my question uh mr franz maybe you
can give us just a little way of
background about how this came about i
know obviously the plant was built
uh
it didn't have at its inception of this
guaranteed purchase power contract but
then it negotiated one uh i believe you
were intimately involved in those
negotiations as a matter of fact and how
is that set up and what's the payment
structure and why is it different than
say
the londonderry gas plant or the
seabrook nuclear plant is how they sell
their power
uh we're going back over over a decade
uh
representative harrington but
the original proposal for this plant was
a was a contract
agreement between psnh and a company
called blade law
and it was for a 20-year term
uh
during the proceeding at the time
a new owner came in
purchased
the
contractual rights to the ppa from
laid law
the commission had extensive hearings at
the time concerning the costs the
benefits the terms of the contract
the commission ultimately approved this
contract it's a 20-year term with set
conditions for energy purchases
it limits
how much
eversource is obligated to purchase for
energy 500 000 megawatt hours per year
it sets the price of those energy
purchases by year for the 20-year term
it has a renewable energy credit
piece to it also that's 400 000 wrecks
of purchase per year at class 1
uh prices and those prices were under
the original rps statute
and it has a capacity segment also and
the capacity is
was set
back
at the original time of the contract
based on the best information what
capacity prices would be for each of the
20 years the commission actually
reconfigured the revenue stream somewhat
for each of those pieces
and the contract was uh approved
and then
there was a legal case taken to the
supreme court by the small wood powered
uh generators
there was then
some
negotiations to
work with the wood power generators
which i led the negotiations for the
state and for the puc on uh along with
many others including
uh
senator bradley and and and and others
so
that ended up
resolving
the
legal case of the new hampshire supreme
court the small power wood generators
withdrew their case
this project got built and uh
off and running we were
that's a short history of of this
project follow up mr chairman follow up
i'll try to make this real quick so when
that was put into place the concept was
that that would be
provide for the financial stability for
this plant to continue operating under
that ppa without any additional
subsidies or changes to the contract
to build a project of this size requires
i think uh at least it did for this
project some financial guarantees and
that's what the ppa
gives
this owner
the financial guarantee the commission
concerned at the time about over market
costs and with a history of the
qualifying facilities going back to 1986
1987 and 1988 and those orders that
fixed prices for a 20-year term for
those small wood power producers
basically put in a cap the 100 million
dollar cumulative reduction factor which
was meant to
to some degree minimize the risk of this
project on the energy portion being
well over market
um and
so 100 million dollars was there to say
if it gets above 100 million dollars
that additional
money would be returned to customers
through a reduction in the energy price
over the following 12 months and do you
believe they could operate once they get
beyond the cap and get to the point
where they have to return those funds
my personal opinion is not if it's 56 or
55 or 58 or 80 million dollars over a
12-year period that they'd be operating
at a loss for every megawatt hour they
produce and
no one that's rational would probably do
that
thank you i think a different question
perhaps is what would happen if they
were at 2 million or 3 million or 4
million over the cap because that's a
lot smaller amount and and i mentioned
it earlier but
the
wreck prices are uh
basically there as the missing money for
the difference between
traditional power plant generation and
what it costs for them to run in a
market versus a renewable project this
is a class one renewable project
and so it gets four hundred thousand
wrecks per year those four hundred
thousand wrecks per year basically bring
in 20 to 22 23 million dollars per year
at about 55 dollars per wreck
okay thank you
uh
representative i mean uh mr franz
the the
consumer advocate said that it would be
simply
profoundly unfair
for the general court to retroactively
overrule a puc decision
what do you think the long-term
consequences of that happening could be
well i'm not an attorney as mr crease is
and uh i have a high regard for his
legal capabilities but
in general just as someone who's been in
the regulatory world for a very long
time now
i don't think it's a very good idea to
keep going back and overturning
puc decisions i think that sends
uncertainty to all the players that are
involved at the puc
and
it may help someone at one point but it
may hurt them at another point and i
think certainty is fairly important to
markets and
actors that are that appear before the
puc there is a process at the puc
and and someone can ask for ask file a
motion for a hearing or clarification
and they have the appeal rights to go to
the new hampshire supreme court if they
really think the puc got it wrong okay
thank you representative callie fitz
thank you mr france
back again
um good to see you
maybe not
i i wanted to ask you do you do you
what would be or what do you believe
might be the impact
of this plant
closing its doors
would that money be recoverable should
they declare bankruptcy
and what would be the
effect on the rates of the people of new
hampshire so it would be a war it'd be
gone
um do you have any inkling what that
might be
uh
it's an excellent question
i i i don't think if they don't run that
the customers and ratepayers in new
hampshire will see that
56 million dollars with 156 million
dollars that have been over market from
the beginning of the power year till
today
at the same time if the plant closes
customers will also not be paying
the wreck prices
also so
and class one wrecks
in the market today
are
substantially less than what what the
customers of eversource are paying for
those class one
wrecks under the ppa the ppa price is
i don't know around 53 to 55 dollars per
rec
uh you can go out and purchase class one
wrecks in the market
they
it's been a while since i looked but
they were trading around fifteen to
twenty dollars per class one record for
new hampshire rex a while back so
you know that's
a savings from that perspective
i'm gonna file to put that
in
simplistic terms for me
if
this plant closes
goes away
money's not returned because it can't be
can't not collectible
and the timing right now is bad because
of what the
situation is with power in general
and fuel
what
do you estimate would be the actual
effect
on me
the customer am i gonna see
a three cent increase in my bill or a
two cent decrease in my bill
that's very simplistic but that
according to what things are now
there are assumptions built into that
but let's assume that
we'll follow your assumption and that
the plan closes the money that's already
paid doesn't come back that's some cost
some costs
are are costs that we really as
economists don't worry too much about
they're they're gone
on going forward uh
this plant
despite being the fourth largest in new
hampshire and produces a fair amount of
output is small and as far as even new
hampshire new hampshire has
almost 4 000 megawatts of installed
generation the region has 31 000
megawatts of install generation on the
margin it would have a very very small
effect on the overall clearing price
in new hampshire or in the region that's
clear
you'd replace the 400 000 wrecks
that are purchased by eversource with uh
renewable energy credits probably from
the market at a much lower price there'd
be savings there and this will have
uh and you won't be paying the price for
the ppa for energy and that energy price
is about 73 to 75 dollars per megawatt
hour right now
um
the eversource files with the puc on an
annual basis
through its strain of costs what the
over market costs of the purchase
facility are in 2019 the over market
costs one could argue with it but the
over market costs were 41 million
dollars
if that's lower today because of higher
prices
we're still probably talking about
over market costs of anywhere from 25 to
30 million dollars that's that's about
four mils per kilowatt hour
on a a on a bill and a reduction in
stranded costs four mils per kilowatt
hour times 650 you're talking about two
dollars and fifty cents perhaps as much
as three dollars per month on a
residential bill back
that that's return or is that spent
that would be money you would save on
your bill about three dollars a month
maybe it could be
two it could be 250 but it's in that
range about two bucks yep thank you two
to three two three is the plant's power
undervalued
by whom
uh
you know it's a contractual price that
people at the time thought was
representative of what future market
prices were and was fair in the uh going
forward and met the public interest
it's easy in hindsight to say
how things turned out
uh
honestly things turned out a lot like
what a puc colleague of mine testified
in that proceeding
he testified that this project would
would
be
way way way
over market
and uh
create a lot of
additional costs for customers that
colleague is george mccluskey who just
retired he was also
our
lead expert in wholesale markets at iso
new england
um
i think if you went to market today
and negotiated a ppa for this price for
this power
it would not be at
75 a megawatt hour um and it would not
be it
in my opinion at 55
per wreck
the capacity has been
actually a winner at times for customers
and even the energy during certain
periods of time it's it's it's
certainly been a winner also this past
winter is a good example of that there
are many hours i'm sure as
the folks behind me could tell you that
they ran
in the money for
for uh
eversource customers when we had many
many many hours this winter of above
150 to 200 per megawatt-hour clearing
prices
in iceland england spot market
that'll probably also be true next
winter
however
this plant runs at a 92 capacity factor
and that's a whole lot of hours where
the clearing price is in the 30s and 40s
and 50s and the market price of the
power under the ppa is in the 70s
representatives samsung has a question
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr france for
for being here
um
so
i'm still a little
fuzzy about the problem at hand
we just heard testimony from the people
from burgess who said
they will this will not increase rates
at all and they are not going to be
asking for any more money in the future
you just confirmed that
there is no request through this bill
for an increase in the rates
but you also said that
that doesn't solve the problem
so
can you really flesh out a little bit
for me what is the problem actually
in my opinion the problem is that this
is a ppa that has a
market price for power for energy i'm
not talking about the wrecks i'm not
talking about capacity i'm talking about
just the energy the megawatt hours
delivered to eversource
that is at a price that
for many many many hours of the year
appears above what the nodal price in
northern new hampshire clears at
and that difference
creates and and goes toward the excess
of over the hundred million dollars of
the cumulative reduction factor and
under the ppa unless the ppa is to be
changed and agreed to by numerous
parties including eversource and burgess
that
money needs to be returned under the ppa
following
uh in the following power year
so that let's say that it's
an additional five million dollars over
over market the way it's calculated that
5 million gets returned over the next 12
months in the following power year which
reduces the
power price
of that ppa
now
if it's one or two million every year
perhaps they keep running
and and and they
they
eat the lower price of energy instead of
selling at seventy five dollars make it
a megawatt hour maybe they sell at 70 or
72 dollars per megawatt hour
if that number is
too large as it is based on senate bill
there's no way that they really can run
because they're just going to lose
lose a lot of money and i seriously
doubt the investors would appreciate
that
okay
i would like to move on because
we have um
five more people who would like to speak
and uh what i'm going to do right now is
i'm going to
open a public hearing on senate bill 321
and recess that hearing
until we finish this hearing the
previous hearing on 271.
earlier i neck neglected to
bring forward a
another public official
and i want to apologize to
paul grenier for uh
not bringing him to the table
more promptly
um
but i would like to have him come talk
to us at this point
if my memory serves you are the mayor of
berlin
thank you sir i have written testimony
from
very very fun
great thank you
so this is the mayor of berlin paul
grenier
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is paul grenier and i recently took
my oath of office to serve as a seventh
term as berlin's mayor
i rise today in support of uh senate
bill 271 for a variety of reasons
the future economic survival of my city
depends on the continued operation of
burgess biopower
perhaps this sounds a bit dramatic but
that's how critically important burgess
biopower is to the city
our economy in berlin is unlike that of
any other large
any other city or large town in our
state
every population center in new hampshire
has either an interstate or four-lane
connector highway
within 10 miles of their border
i-93 the closest to berlin is 50 miles
away and must navigate franconia notch
parkway
this really limits berlin's ability to
grow its economy and attract the young
people so vital to our area
but i'm here to tell you we've begun to
do just that
when i was first sworn in as mayor in
broome was hanging by a thread the
bureau of prisons facility in berlin
have not yet been built
the pulp mill has been closed for three
years
and the gorham paper mill was in
bankruptcy and not operating without
good prospects at home our best and
brightest citizens
were forced to seek work elsewhere
leaving a community they loved in order
to raise their families
but then burgess biopower came along
burgess and berlin burgess was berlin's
first real economic development success
story in 40 years
and at the time was enthusiastically
supported by the state
then
psnh local governments and businesses
many of the young people hired during
construction are still working in the
building trades or have found various
vocations they learned while at burgess
and many have stayed in berlin as a
result
at a time when berlin desperately needed
it burgess biopower provided economic
stability good long-term employment and
perhaps most importantly a spark of hope
that the city could thrive once again we
no longer have the luxury of being able
to withstand another human exodus
if once again we have to rebuild our
economy
property values are rising large
businesses like white mountain paper
company north country growers are
investing in our community
and brilliant has become an outdoor
recreation destination for thousands of
visitors each year
but none of this would be possible
without burgess as an economic anchor
the financial impact burgess has on the
city of berlin is significant
burgess accounts for nearly 12 percent
of our real estate taxes
for blowing water works the impact on a
percentage basis is even greater
burgess from fees from burgess total 25
percent of their revenue which covers
broad waterworks annual debt service
equally important is the fact that
burgess keeps our working forests
healthy and available for recreation
activities
by creating a market for low-grade wood
losing burgess would cause tax and water
rates to skyrocket community confidence
to plummet
and could very well place berlin in a
receivership the death spiral of any
community begins with realization
that the future is bleak at best
in closing on behalf of my city the
communities that surround berlin and the
forest land owners in coast county in
the state of new hampshire
i plead with you to recommend passage of
271 a unanimous vote from this committee
the continued revelance of our area is
truly at stake
and if you look in the packet
i don't like giving testimony to
any committee in the legislature
without giving you some background
information
as you can see
i i gave you the dra breakdown of our
tax rate our tax rate is 36.54
so you take two million dollars out of
property tax revenue out of the city
we're done
i gave you the proposed uh waterworks
budget and you can see that in fact
burgess is 25
of the water works budget
and
at the very end i kept my
testimony from senate bill 577 which
really digs into the weeds
of why we were here in the first place
and
i know there are a lot of smart people
in this room and i know there's a lot of
people here
who will try to work out a solution to
try to make this work
burgess is very very important to the
city it's important to me as mayor
i'm very proud of my relationship with
the folks who run the power plant
no community should be so lucky as to
have people of burgess's magnitude in
their backyard they've been great
corporate citizens
so and i know you're pressed for time mr
chairman uh i would take any questions
or i can meet with you after i know you
want to move things along
thank you mr mayor we really appreciate
you being here
uh
we will forego questions at this point
in time but we do appreciate you being
here providing great information
we have four more people who want to
testify on this bill and i'm going to
have to regretfully limit everyone to
two minutes
be prepared for that and the first
person i will call on is
drew klein representing the josiah
bartles center
i know you requested four minutes but
i'm gonna have to
cut you to two sorry drew i can
improvise
you don't want me to do that trust me
i can talk very fast um
drew klein president of the josiah
bartlett center we're in new hampshire's
free market think tank i'm just going to
stray from my notes here for the
interest of time and say that what we
really have here in the purchase power
agreement is a jobs program it is a jobs
subsidy it is not
a it is not an energy issue this isn't
about energy this is about jobs it's
about protecting the timber industry
that's been clear from the very
beginning
the wrong way to do that is to raise
electricity rates on new hampshire
ratepayers the the problem is you have a
couple of different issues here that
you're trying to solve you're trying to
solve a reduction in timber industry
jobs
the
disappearance of the market for pulpwood
and your and um you know berlin's
economic issues those are the three
things you're really trying to solve
with
a biomass plant but the biomass plan is
not the right way to solve those
problems so you're forcing rate payers
to subsidize a biomass plant as a
through path to subsidizing timber
industry jobs that's what this scheme is
is doing
um
the the bartlett center opposes all such
subsidies and also schemes no industry
should get a subsidy from the state
but if you're going to
subsidize an industry you don't do it by
raising the already the seventh highest
in the country
electricity prices we we are in the top
seven right now we're usually in the top
five so you're literally making grandma
you're making low-income families you're
making um other folks pay higher
electricity rates so you heard estimated
money today that it's about two to three
dollars
um
increased monthly cost that's that's
upwards of 360 dollars for a family a
year to subsidize timber industry jobs
right that's not the right way to do it
if you're going to subsidize timber
industry jobs 30 seconds then
okay
36 okay sorry uh misspoke a little
different
um
we've already spent 158 million dollars
the plant costs 275 million dollars to
build
right we've almost bought the plant
by overpayment rate payers have
we shouldn't be subsidizing this if you
want to extend the 12-month period at
which they need to pay back the 58
million dollars that's a better option
than
um the language in the bill seems to
suggest that that puc has vague broad
powers to do whatever it wants you need
to narrow it down give them a longer
time to pay this back that's the right
option
great thank you very much any questions
for
mr klein
representative oxenam and thank you
representative uh oxford for the math
clarification there i appreciate it
if you could just repeat your last
sentence because it was
i think exactly to the point but i it
went by really too fast for me i'm sorry
i was flying so fast i'm not even sure
what my last sentence was
um
it was kind of your proposal of how we
would right right so if you're
like so so the issue is the cliff as
senator bradley said you got 58 million
dollars to pay back in 12 months i'm not
sure why that can't be changed to extend
that payment period
so that it's not all falling in one year
another option would be uh you know
instead of forcing rate payers to pay
this the irs has had a checkbox for
years for the presidential campaign fund
you could put a check box on on rate on
bills to say
do you want to pay three dollars a month
to subsidize this plan and let
ratepayers choose right that's better
than forcing them to do that
so anyway okay thank you thank you very
much all right all right let's move on
next
will be kristen koch from the business
and industry association
ms coke i'm going to have to give you
two minutes
but i know you have written testimony so
that will help yes no problem
i'm so good afternoon mr chair members
of the committee my name is kirsten koch
and i'm the director of public policy
for bia
i'm here today to express bia's concerns
regarding senate bill 271 while baa
supports economic development in general
we do not believe that it should come at
such a significant cost for rate payers
senate bill 271 potentially sets up rate
payers to face a large increase in the
future
this bill artificially inflates energy
prices for the benefit of a single
business and establishes that unless
covered by federal covet 19 relief funds
the costs would be fully recovered from
rate payers the core responsibility of
the new hampshire public utilities
commission is to protect the interest of
the rate payers but senate bill 271
attempts to override the puc's authority
in this instance
the bia respectfully requests the
committee to find senate bill 271
inexpedient to legislate thank you for
your consideration and i'd be happy to
try to answer any questions from the
committee
okay any questions representative
occident
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
such a significant expense to rate
payers
are you in agreement with the preceding
speaker that we're talking
up 36
a year
increase a three two to three dollar
increase
on a bill per month per rate payer
thank you for your question i'm talking
about the additional 20 million dollars
per year that eversource ratepayers
would be
facing
so all the ratepayers paying that amount
of money comes to
a significant amount but it's not a
significant amount for the ratepayer
no debates just questions thank you
excuse me okay thank you very much
representative kelly pitts
i guess i'm a bit confused because i i
thought there would be no additional
charges to the ratepayers so i would
ask you if you could
um
give
us as a committee
where your figures came from by tuesday
because i believe this will be on the
docket for tuesday
mr chair
are we going to exact this on tuesday
uh next tuesday the 19th so if if by the
end of the week on monday maybe you
could uh forward how you calculated
your figures as an increase for the
attack the ratepayers because i don't
i've heard more testimony that there
would be no increase
thank you for your question um there
would be an increase and this is about
when burgess sells energy at an above
market rate that's when the
ratepayers are forced to subsidize it
and pay that additional cost
okay
any additional questions
thank you very much appreciate it
next up is jason stock and jason i know
you have
a ton that you could say about this
subject but
please give us your
best
attempt at a two-minute overview
we love paper mills
all right well yesterday i was at 2 37
i'm going to try and beat that
for the record my name is jason stock
i'm the executive director of the new
hampshire timberland owners association
you've heard a lot today about timber
forestry and i wanted to just kind of
put a couple things in context i'm
providing you a copy of our testimony we
provided to the senate on this bill
it has some has a couple economic
analysis in it you can pour over that at
your leisure but i wanted to just put a
couple things like i said in context
in may 2020 there was a a forest
economic analysis looking at the entire
state
and so
the total forest products industry is
about 2.5 billion dollars in economic
activity this is not an insignificant
little boutique industry
we're the second most forested state in
the nation and two-thirds of all that's
growing out there on our landscape is
low-grade it's junk wood it can't be
turned into a a two by four it can't be
turned into veneer
um it's pretty to look at when you leaf
peep et cetera but it's it is for all
intents and purposes and from a
landowner's perspective or a land
manager's perspective it's wood that's
consuming valuable air space in that
solar capturing canopy
annually about 2500 timber sales occur
across the state of new hampshire
almost every town in the state even
portsmouth occasionally has timber
harvest so this is a statewide issue and
annually we cut about 2.5 million tons
of wood all species all products
firewood saw logs and yes biomass
and
so when you hear 800 000 green tons put
that in context of 2.5 million all cut
across the state it's a big piece of the
pie
it is a very big piece of the pie
when we lost the existing biomass power
plants that was about 1.3 million
tons so the forest products industry has
taken a pretty good shot the last couple
years in our low grade markets
folks are scrambling
we've seen contraction and logging in
infrastructure
and the impacts are even 30 seconds 30
seconds gotcha impacts are even
trickling down to solid wood sawmills
having difficulty managing their waste
and having difficulty procuring saw logs
because of the
capacity
i want to
just wrap up i'm going to use my last 25
and a half seconds here to wrap up and
just say yesterday in the renewable
energy renewable gas bill we had a
pretty good discussion
about looking forward and looking
prospectively and looking at
opportunities
forward
um senator thomas and senator vote
signed on to a bill to house bill 1005
to look forward
looking at opportunities for low-grade
markets
if we lose capacity if we lose
infrastructure
it gets very difficult to encourage
someone to come to the state and say hey
we're a state we support forest products
we support the industry
and if there is if there if the logging
capacity and land management capacity is
a fraction of what it is today it gets
very difficult to do that so this is
this all kind of fits together we we
need to maintain that capacity and that
critical mass
thank you
thank you very much
i don't think we need to ask jason any
questions at this point because we've
asked him
hundreds over the course of the last
couple of years but we appreciate your
testimony and thanks for this written uh
testimony too that's all right what a
great information for what is good thank
you thank you okay the last word on this
bill
goes to
and i'm apologize for getting this uh
name wrong
shayla connolly of holderness thank you
did i get that right it's just sheila
yeah gila oh it's a little gaelic trick
my parents played on me
and sheila represents rmi which you're
going to tell us what that is right yes
sir
so sheila conley from resource
management inc rmi is my company with my
partner charlie who's handing out
information for you and the last word of
the day is wood ash
so charlie is giving you samples of wood
ash this is what is generated as one of
the
other green products that comes from the
plant so it's not just green electricity
it's black wood ash this is black gold
this is a potassium fertilizer that is
used throughout new hampshire for farms
to grow crops
potash is scarce
it's even more scarce now due to the
horrific situation in ukraine and russia
that is one of the major sources of
potash in in the uh agricultural world
so um i just to to give you a little
background i've been recycling wood ash
since
1988. i was around when these first
biomass plants were
built and up and running
and i was there when burgess began and
we've been recycling a hundred percent
of their ash ever since
our company is located in holderness new
hampshire
we have 30 employees
and we have an environmental commitment
as a small business to do the right
thing
we work with farms several hundred farms
throughout the northeast
and
the loss of this potash to those farmers
would be tremendous
i just
can't even begin to explain how
difficult it is to be a farm these days
and the wood ash provides relief because
it's cost effective it's local and it's
really really good for growing their
crops i'll just point out that these
other sources of power you can't spread
seabrook's leftovers on farms you can't
spread the coal ash on farms but you can
spread this really beautiful wood ash on
farms
so you know we've lost the biomass plant
in bethlehem we've lost the biomass
plant in alexandria we are
hopeful that the springfield plant will
run more than not it has been running
and we're recycling their ash the
tamworth plant is up and running a
little bit we're hoping that they'll
stay around um
i just want to close with i i agree with
all of the things talked about earlier
relative to the benefits of this but i
just i don't so much think of these as
power plants i think of a more as an
economic hub
with spokes that support the forest
products industry local truck mechanics
local restaurants
gas stations trail users
and farmers
and i don't use the word subsidy i use
the word investment
thank you
thank you very much
and you did get the last word and uh we
appreciate you bringing us that uh
fine gift as well
so with that i'm going to close the
public hearing on senate bill 271
you can put in about a four inch pot and
it's really good for cherry tomatoes
okay and i'll ask mr chairman i'll ask
for uh representative white to give us
the blue sheet total
chairman can i inquire i think there was
reference made to to uh eversource
testifying are they not going to testify
they did not sign up to testify now okay
i thought they were going to clarify
some of the issues that came up
i've looked through all the pink cards
up here and i don't see one from
eversource
okay
so
we will now
resume the public hearing that i started
about
25 minutes ago on senate bill 371 and
ask senator david waters the prime
sponsor of the bill to present the bill
to us
so once again
right before you start uh i'd like to
get representative white to tell us
about the blue sheet on the last bill
all right uh blue sheet we've got online
we have 39 support
10 opposed and then we have five support
and two posts
okay thank you
all right
representative waters
it's all yours
thank you mr chairman
i feel like i'm playing ping-pong today
i'm bouncing from here into here and
we're in the middle of the 10-year
highway plan down in transportation so
i'm glad i made it up here i know you've
had a busy day so i'll try to be
brief i'm senator david waters
introducing senate bill
21. and um
essentially this bill tries to update
what we have done now for quite some
time first in 1979 and then again in
1998 in terms of net metering in new
hampshire
and also the progress that we certainly
made over the last year or so
um
and you know a lot of questions have
risen over the years that we've been
endeavoring uh in to do this um
you know how can we enable market-based
alternatives to that metering
and then specifically how do we avoid
a rate payer
across subsidies or cost shiftings and
that's of course been a great uh area of
interest for this committee and for all
of us
and so one of the
ways to address that was try to enable
in-state distributed generation and
storage of less than five
megawatts that produce power for sale
and resale to new hampshire customers
and how do we let that be accurately
credited and
so you get into credit because you're
not increasing
cost shifting
um the bill builds on what was passed
last year in senate bill 91 and part
four
and i know that you know after that the
house
wanted to study uh mr chairman we had
the committee last
summer on
the issue of cost shifting and and leap
and uh that was i thought really you
know a terrific
and compressed uh
study of of the issues and a great
report that you
um put put together and the question
kept coming up um okay
well what happens if someone removed
themselves from just from distribution
uh from iso
new england and uh if you're if you do
that would it not mean that you are not
cost
shifting
and um so the bill tries to clarify
that it's it is kind of a what if if we
did this to ensure
that they were out of that system
then not cost shifting
would that work
and um
you know as i was working on this in
this uh this bill and remembering
you know the efforts we made in the leap
committee about wanting to be cautious
these issues are getting studied
so that if we brought anything forward
it ought to be a pilot program
so that's what this bill does and i will
point to a few things in the first page
here
and really all follow us from that and
then i just as soon after that let um
mr bilo uh take it from there
so i took it on page one of the bill
um here is where we get at it on line
six
does not participate in net energy
metering non-participation and net
energy metering may be achieved
by cancelling participation and such
upon assuming limited production
b is not registered as a generator asset
or network resource within iso new
england that's key
c does not otherwise participate in any
ferc jurisdictional wholesale
electricity markets
except as an alternative technology
regulation resource
to the extent
atrs are deemed by iso new england to
function as retail or network oil
reducers
for all other iso new england such
non-participation and ferc
jurisdictional interstate wholesale
markets may be achieved by retirement
from such markets
so there it is it takes the premise that
was developed
um you know arising out of our
experience of that metering and was
discussed in the leap and says okay this
is this is a bill that would do that
and um
help not shift costs and also enable the
communities that are interested in doing
this and the producers are interested
into it to be able to go ahead and make
their investments in their and their
projects um
now mr chairman i just i just said to
start you know i is we've had a lot of
conversations about this over the last
couple years haven't we and it's just
it's fascinating you know things are
changing and um
you know it's hard to tell the leader i
mean there's a lot there we don't know
um but i think that a pilot makes a lot
of sense and i don't know i do know my
conversation with you that you did
comment as well if it's really a pilot
why aren't there end dates and so on and
i i agree with you and i didn't really
think in those ways because we kind of
said was going to be one you know one
some people can get together with just
you know utility and so on but i think
it would uh in the spirit of pilots
which i really respect from the leap
committee report if you thought that it
would uh make sense to say okay let's
really make it a pilot put some dates
and some other kinds of guardrails
around it
i want to honor the kind of agreement we
all came to out of that committee last
summer so thank you mr chairman
thank you senator for introducing the
bill
do we want to ask the senator questions
or do we want to wait and ask
clifton below the man who has all the
information the questions
i guess the sense of the committee is
that we're going to uh move on to
the honorable clifton bilo so i will see
you in an hour okay well thank you in an
hour mr chairman members of the
committee
so cliff the floor is yours
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
uh this bill what this bill is about is
creating a
trying to pilot the idea
of a update uh to the limited electrical
producer statute
to allow
another form of customer and community
choice of um local
uh power generation and storage um it is
it would be
a market-based alternative
to net metering for under 5 megawatt
generators
it might particularly um
[Music]
fill a niche
um for one to five megawatt generators
that don't qualify for the current
expansion program
it is intended or structured
to try to
do this without
any cross subsidies
and
by sending price signals that are
are actual market based and reflect
actual value uh produced as actually
measured and documented so let me just
walk you through some of the
details about the bill um it does
you may remember house bill 1635 which
you heard earlier this year and you sent
to interim study um that representative
mcgee sponsored that was sort of an
attempt to revamp the the existing
362 a 2a
instead of doing that
and the bill is introduced in the senate
tried to update that language to reflect
some of the study committee's work but
instead of
trying to modify that part of the
existing uh
statute it creates a new 362 a 2b
that's only about pilots so it takes
sort of that language
that was in the bill is introduced and
puts it all in the context of only a
pilot
and so starting on the first page at 20
lines 24 through 27
it authorizes the puc to approve
one or more proposed pilots uh pursuant
to an adjudicated proceeding so a pilot
would not be approved until it went
through an adjudicated proceeding they
wouldn't have to adopt rules because
this would not be of general application
it does give them the ability to waive
some existing provisions of
a 2a which is a parallel section that
exists in law today that allows a
limited producer
to sell directly
to a limited number of customers
um
yeah but with some complications that
are a little archaic which is why i
think it hasn't ever come into use
um
i i would mention that the section one
and two of the bills that uh modified
definitions in the chapter they're not
specifically pilot but they're
appropriate uh definitions to go ahead
and change because right now
in theory a limited producer could be
operating at exactly five megawatts
could be participating in iso new
england markets in fact they'd be
required to at five megawatts uh but
could also argue that they could sell
under the existing 2a uh part of the
chapter uh which which really should not
be the case so
that's that's a helpful thing and it
brings uh storage which didn't really
exist uh when this legislation this
chapter was originally enacted in into
the definition of a limited producer
um
turning to the second page of the bill
[Music]
it um
there's a really key part here
uh which is
um to address the fact that
uh for any generator or storage facility
to participate in a potential pilot
um
they would need to be making a choice
not to participate in um
group net metering for instance um and
i'll just take the city of lebanon has a
one megawatt landfill gas energy project
under development now it has proved
interconnection agreement with liberty
utilities
right now the intent would do that with
groupnet metering
and we would the numbers work for that
project we would get paid the full
default service energy rate for all of
our output to the grid uh that would
create a large cost to liberty utilities
that they would charge to default
service rate payers we couldn't actually
use it to offset the load obligation of
whoever supplying
uh city facilities or other members of
the group um the group members would
just kind of get a subsidy off of of
something of a discount off of the
default service rate even if they were
on a competitive supplier
like hopefully in a year or so lebanon
community power um whereas the pilot
would allow that gen that same generator
to sell directly
potentially to lebanon community power
to serve the load of customers in the
community or
directly to what otherwise might be
group members retail customers that
would want to take the power and and use
it to help meet their um load
uh and and we have a bunch of very large
users for whom we could portion it out
and they they would always have load in
excess so this would just offset part of
that load so the real issue is uh for
their you know for instance if you know
if there's a termination date and if you
put one into it you know these projects
typically require
uh financing that goes for a period of
time in the case of our landfill gas
project
the portion of it that's that's uh debt
finance it's over 20-year uh payback
period
um we know the numbers now work with
with group net metering uh so this would
allow if the pilot uh ends before
december 31st 2040 which is when current
net metering tariffs are grandfathered
to uh both by statute and by puc order
um so if you if you got into group net
metering now you would be able to count
on that through
2040. so this simply would say that if
if the pilot terminates before that time
uh that you could go
and revert back to what you otherwise
would have been uh
uh qualified for
you know i did have a brief conversation
with department of energy folks that
that that was maybe something of a
concern uh that they should maybe have
to go on to whatever is in effect at
that time the problem with that is i
don't think we'll have a pilot if if you
said you have to go on to something that
you don't know what it's going to be
when you can lock into something now
that you know what it is and you you
know your numbers work with it
um
so that that's uh
something to think about um
at line seven roman four uh says each
electric distribution utility may
propose and participate in a pilot
so it doesn't contemplate that there'd
be more than one pilot per distribution
utility and
quite honestly i've only had
conversations with liberty utilities and
they're
receptive to considering a proposal that
there's no guarantees that they would
actually commit to doing a pilot uh but
they're at least willing to consider it
i'm not sure about the other utility so
i would just caution that um it it may
be that we only get one or two um pilots
out of this uh you know if if we're
lucky um
in part because it's sort of the devil
you know versus the one you don't and
they're comfortable with the way group
net mirroring works now and they know
how to operate that this introduces some
new concepts although i think ultimately
we would be better off introducing these
concepts and mechanisms because they
create
a market dynamic in which prices price
signals become uh drivers of uh of
investment decisions and and choices
about how to operate your storage or
your generation facilities and and i
think those uh price signals as a driver
of um
dispatch and such is is is uh is very
valuable compared to sort of subsidized
arrangements or mandated arrangements um
going down to romans 6 um
[Music]
i would point out at line 16 the
purchasers may be any non-residential
retail electric customers
[Music]
and what that means
or any electricity suppliers serving
retail load within the same area at line
18 it takes residential customers out of
the mix
so
there were some concerns about
residential ratepayer you know
protections in terms of they
got involved with something like this
this would residential retail customers
would not be able to participate in the
pilot so
concerns about impacts on residential
customers are sort of set aside so this
would only be uh suppliers buying this
with at interest rate within state
wholesale sales or potentially a retail
larger
commercial retail customer
non-residential
line 19 um
you know this parallels some of the
previous discussions that this would
have to be
facilitated and accounted for for by
load-serving entities
either competitive electricity suppliers
that are registered with the commission
or
municipler county aggregations that are
operating as or in conjunction with load
serving entities
and it also provides that line into line
that
electric distribution utility provided
default service is not required to
facilitate account for or otherwise
enable participation in these kinds of
sales so it shouldn't affect existing
default energy service
roman
8 at line 26 on page 2
makes a requirement that such any
facility uh participating in this would
have to have revenue grade interval
meterings that can accurately measure
their hourly imports and exports to the
distribution grid again of course that
would still be by puc and electric
utility approval of what that metering
is
and and
then it does provide at line 29 like is
the case now with with net metering
regular net metering exports to the
distribution grid by a limited producer
would be accounted for as a reduction or
an offset to the load obligation of the
load serving entity for the limited
producer for load settlement in the iso
new england wholesale electricity market
meaning just to take an example if
lebanon community power was getting 800
kw from the lebanon landfill gas to
energy project and they had a total load
uh that they were selling to customers
of uh three megawatts uh at in a given
hour then what they would have to buy
from iso new england is uh whatever i
said three three megawatts less 800 kw
they still have 2.2 megawatts to to
purchase uh to meet their load following
obligation
this would just be
you know an offset to what that would
otherwise be which is physically what
happens on the grid
and there's a parallel provision that if
a net meter customer is a customer of a
competitive supplier or community power
aggregation
their experts to the grid are used as an
offset to their load obligation of the
supplier
[Music]
roman 9a kind of gets into the heart of
it
it says the sponsors of pilot which
would have to include the participating
electric utility can petition the
commission to determine through an
adjudicated proceeding how credits for
actual avoided transmission costs are
made
and and then there's some more detail
about that that that continues on the
next page
um
and it it really at lines uh two three
and four it says the credit shall be
made pursuant to one of two paragraphs
as determined by the commission to be
for the public good paragraph b
subparagraph b
is essentially
sort of what happens in pennsylvania
which is to say
the transmission charges instead of
being charged through the distribution
utility
to customers as essentially distribution
utility charge right now it's mostly
flat
per kw
rate
even though it's charged to the
distribution utilities based on their
share of coincident peak demand each
month
this would allow
those transmission charges in their
entirety to be allocated to the load
serving entity that's part of the pilot
or at least for for a group of uh a
metering domain that is part of the
pilot um
and
instead what would happen is those
transmission costs would be charged by
the load serving entity to their retail
customers based on that group's actual
coincident
share of peak demand so it
this this is uh something that i said no
england tariffs
allow
it is actually done by eversource in
their western mass service area for
large cni customers their largest cni
customers who have demand meters
actually pay for transmission costs
based on their share of the monthly
coincident peak they just get they just
get a pass-through of that charge that
comes through this would replicate the
same thing except it would be the net
load at that hour of coincident peak net
of any limited producer
that they produce because then point of
fact that is not would not be counted um
towards
the transmission
coincident peak because it functions as
a load reducer relative to the
transmission system
that that's sort of the
uh i think the sort of ideal way to do
it it may be technically more difficult
and so it may not be
um uh
it may not
be easy to do in a pilot um so item c is
the other way to do it which is to
figure out a monetary credit that's
equivalent to what would be uh charged
um
or what the say what the actual savings
are from avoided transmission charges uh
based on the actual exports to the grid
at that hour of uh of coincident peak
demand
um for each month
um
that's uh just moving on because i know
there's not much time here um
uh
roman 10 just says you know the
purchases of a
power from limited producers you still
play the delivery tariff and all the
other charges that apply
um except for the energy service charge
obviously because you wouldn't be in
default service
or um transmission charges if they're
just to pursuant to the previous
paragraph
roman
deals with a very parallel situation to
transmission charges which is
capacity the forward capacity market
charges they get allocated
to
um
each load serving entity
based on the capacity tag that all the
meters that of the customers that
they're serving at a given point in time
have been assigned and capacity tags are
assigned to individual customers based
on either their own individual share of
the annual system peak if they have
hourly interval metering
um in our large customer
so for instance the city has two large
uh g1 customers water treatment
wastewater treatment their capacity tag
is actually based on their measured uh
annual
uh
load or
um in one case we brought it down to
zero because we had some solar behind
the meter and curtailed uh load um we
were able to reduce the capacity tag
down to zero
this would allow for the fact that um
if there were
um exports to the grid say our landfill
gas energy project was exporting a
megawatt at the annual hour of system
peak then that would actually have the
effect of reducing uh the capacity
tag total capacity attacks that are
charged to liberty by that full one
megawatt and it would actually reduce
the amount of capacity that that isone
england has to plan for because it's not
showing up as apparent load on the
transmission grid so this would just
provide a mechanism again it would have
to be pursue reviewed and approved by
the puc in an adjudicated proceeding
so the burden of proof is always on uh
the proposer of of in this case of a
pilot the burden of proof would be on
them
to show demonstrate to the puc that this
was actually um
uh a feasible thing to do and a fair uh
thing to do um that that's for the
public good or for the for the
common good
that's basically it it you know just
takes these concepts of saying uh
these values some of which are embedded
in in what the compensation
is for um
uh
in group net metering you get the full
default service rate which includes the
capacity cost this is just another way
to recognize
the value of that capacity
reduction and in a way that actually
aligns with the value actually produced
whereas with group net metering or net
metering it's just sort of um it's it's
an extremely rough justice it's like
okay we're supposing that these projects
help reduce capacity
which they may or may not and
uh
you know or they do to varying degrees
um and sometimes some projects produce
more
reduced capacity
more and others much less
this would actually align the actual
value produced with the um
uh
charges you know passed on to those
customers
and the final section section 4 is just
something that it's not per se part of
the pilot but it's an important concept
which is with storage projects
if you have battery storage uh right now
if if you
had a battery storage project that could
help shave peak demand and you were
getting charging it from the grid uh you
would in effect um
be getting a charge for
rps compliance
and then when you turn around um and uh
export to the grid the customers that
buy that power will also be charged for
the rps compliance so you'd actually
have a double rps compliance
for battery storage that gets charged
from the grid this would simply stay if
they can document if they have revenue
grade metering
that quantifies what they purchase from
the grid then that could be used to
adjust the rps charges
as provided by the commission
so you're not sort of double counting
there
the the
i think the one opportunity that exists
where i think this could have a um
where we see an opportunity on a small
scale pilot that might just involve a
handful of generators uh maybe maybe
three or four or something like that is
we have a couple sites that are really
well suited for dual access solar
trackers
and um solar trackers are are different
than
fixed-oriented ones the fixtorian ones
tend to have a parabola curve on a sunny
day the power goes up and and at the
middle of whatever or the orientation
they are power peaks and it immediately
starts dropping a dual axis tracker
follows the sun from sunrise to sunset
aiming at the sun adjusting typically
every 15 minutes or so to follow the sun
both angle
tilt and orientation so as soon as the
sun clears the horizon their production
goes up and it continues across the day
relatively flat and then right as the
sun drops below whatever the western
horizon is that's where the power drops
off so you have a production profile
that much closer matches load
and and yet under current net metering
all kilowatt hours are valued the same
we have a site that's you know ideal for
trackers because it's got basically 0.1
percent shading on far distant eastern
and western horizons one of them off in
vermont at our airport and i kind of ran
the numbers because we had a proposal
for dual access trackers and fixed
orientation south facing system
and
the the dual access trackers in terms of
we looked at the lmp the locational
marginal price of electricity the
coincidence with transmission and the
coincidence with the annual
capacity charges the value of those
kilowatt hours were on the order of 20
more across the board as a as an entire
group
than it was for doing the same system
just fixed orientation to optimize kwh
per year
the
but but because there's no
way to capture those values
it didn't it didn't really quite pencil
out because there's a little bit more
capital cost for the trackers than there
is for the fixed orientation system but
if we could capture those values and
this kind of pilot would allow us to do
that
we could potentially uh
do something like that that the numbers
would pencil out and actually
it may become apparent that that's
actually more advantageous
which when you think about it over the
long term would actually be
more advantageous for the system because
right now
if you if you like me you know keep
checking your phone and seeing what's
happening with electricity prices and
and demand what you keep seeing is this
um
uh cats here is i think what i what i
just saw it called instead of the duck
uh formation which is the way that um
load um
uh follows uh it goes oops up and down
over the course here it is um this is
our load duration curve um for today and
we're we're at the middle near the
bottom of that trough probably because a
lot of the pv in new england is starting
to produce because the sun's out
and uh
and we had a peak in the morning it was
cloudy rainy and we're gonna have a peak
um in the evening
and uh all the solar is going to be
going down just as loads going up later
in the afternoon dual axis tracker is
going to it
more closely match the production to the
load and then if you add storage to that
you can really push um your your ability
to capture these uh uh to shave these
peak demands and when we shave those
peak demands uh and and you know sort of
fill the troughs for instance with
battery storage taking power when
there's a surplus then we start to get a
system that makes more is more
economically efficient and technically
efficient so that
fundamentally is what this bill is about
is is kind of a baby step at this point
in terms of a potential pilot we might
get one or two of these
i think they'd be on a small scale um
and uh
they would be a step towards something
that i think could prove out to be more
economically and technically efficient
as we move forward and sort of reduces
some of the tensions around
subsidy questions
so thank you
happy to take questions
thank you
the most obvious question uh
based on the fact that this bill sets up
a pilot
is what would be a good duration period
for a pilot
and what would be a good
uh
cap on the size of a pilot
um
i i i think it would be fine to cap
i i don't know if you are you thinking
caps in terms of megawatts or projects i
would say a half a dozen or maybe five
projects in a pilot you know five excuse
me five generation or storage projects
or you know
up to maybe you know five projects what
size they would be um
i mean i think you'd want to allow
five or ten megawatts potentially to
participate because you might
it
it might be far less than that but but
just thinking of lebanon as an example
you know we got one megawatt with our
landfill gas to energy project and
uh it wouldn't be coming online until
next spring so i'm hopeful that we could
get it into a pilot
but but um
you know they'd like to leave some room
for some um
a few significant scale other projects
so
uh maybe two or three megawatts you know
maximum that could participate in a in a
given pilot with a given distribution
utility
uh would allow you know at least one or
two significant scale projects to happen
um duration
you know that that's a tough one because
you know if we didn't have group net
metering to fall back on
um and because we're right at one
megawatt we don't actually
you know we fall
in in the existing group metering not
the one that was expanded next last year
um
so any you know anybody who's a liberty
test customer could be a member of our
group um
you know that that's
there's going to be some appeal to to
want to stick with that just because
it's a known
i think this pilot would actually um
[Music]
could actually produce somewhat better
value but it's a little more speculative
but the problem is this project that
we've already made work um
uh financially
but if you were looking at a new project
say a project with you know a few dozen
dual access trackers
the developer would say well okay i can
make the numbers work under this scheme
i don't know if i'll qualify
you know if they were over 1 megawatt
for group net metering
um
[Music]
and they would probably need at least 10
years worth of certainty in in their
sort of terms
the rng bill that we heard yesterday
was also a pilot and it had a duration
of 15 years 15 years
would that be reasonable i i think that
gets into the reasonable realm because i
think um
[Music]
a solar project might uh
pay back within that period or be
financiable within that period
um or until 2040 is another possibility
um
i
you know
i think the uncertainty is we've talked
with a few developers who are
potentially interested in this but but
they're they're also
they want to understand better you know
how the terms would work and how
um
you know if they could really count on
it uh in terms of getting financing um
so that that's why i'm thinking you know
15 years or until 2040 that that's about
the same time frame
uh
would um should be enough to get
projects financed
okay with some uncertainty as to what
happens at the end of that period
representative mcgee has a question
thank you mr chairman to follow on your
point
um i i do understand you wanting to have
some certainty
for the pilot so people can understand
how to cost it out my question was
around to follow on duration and size
questions you said 5 to 10 megawatts i'm
wondering if you have any
sense of
of
a break point where
in other words uh the scale to which the
project would have to be at a minimum in
order to even be doing the pilot
you you said five to ten it would five
be reasonable or does it need to be
larger in order to do the proof of
concept that you're talking about for a
pilot of this type well
i think you'll hear um from another
person testifying with one solar
developer who who works specifically in
the one to five megawatt range
and and um
they
um
looked at this we discussed this with
them and they thought that this this
might make some of the projects they've
thought about in new hampshire pencil
out in a way that
um well they don't you know the group
net metering and that scale is difficult
to do at this point uh because there's
limited so-called off-takers
um
you know a project like that they might
say you know we we we need to do a three
or four megawatt project to make it to
make it work
um
i i know in vermont there have been
several because the utility was involved
in there have been several large uh dual
access tracker projects where green
mountain power is the off taker
because they could see the value of that
in in terms of the production um
uh
so so
you know i think
if the cap was at five megawatts then
and
there was one project that did most of
that then that at least would be a pilot
for one project if it
in our case i we have some sites that
could handle more than one megawatt um
for solar
not just in lebanon but in in other
areas communities that are thinking
about municipal aggregations uh where
there might be an interest in this
uh there are sites that can handle more
than one megawatt
um i would
you know it's funny in in other regions
of the country where the price
incentives have changed uh at least
single access trackers have become much
more common in other parts of the world
because they have a better production
curve that extends longer through the
day
[Music]
so this
you know we're going to continue to see
pressure for
the the single orientation fixed
orientation
solar because that's in new england
generally what's incentivized maximize
kwh all kwhs are treated as equal in
value i think this
uh
i guess we could revisit it i mean if
there was a cap put on at five megawatts
per pilot one pilot per per utility uh
and after year two we said this is going
great then you could come back and
exchange
uh change the pilot
you know
my my main concern is to create an
opportunity to at least demonstrate that
this can work and um that
and i suspect that any utility who
participates in it may have to do some
of the accounting on a manual basis um
and and you know what that'll have to be
paid for somehow um although if it's
just one or two or three or four
projects um
and they don't add up
to large numbers uh then i think that
might be manageable i mean that they've
sort of
done a certain amount of that for their
battery pilot for instance with liberty
or when they started off doing group net
metering credits they were doing some of
that on a manual basis um
so i don't know i'm just rambling sorry
okay so cliff
we could talk with you all day long
about this
but it is 304 yes
and uh so i am going to
open the public hearing on senate bill
448-fn
and recess that public hearing so we can
we can continue this hearing we have
four more people that we need to hear
from and the first of those will be
griffin roberge from the
new hampshire department of energy
oh i'm sorry i forgot you raised your
hand right representative sumpt just did
have a question thank you very much mr
chairman
it's actually just a brief clarification
if you agree with my clarification i'm
kind of a stickler on the technicalities
of of units of measure
so in this case we're talking about
battery storage
so when somebody sees something like
five megawatts
what that means is that you can
discharge five megawatts in one hour
right i should really say five megawatt
hours because you can also discharge one
megawatt over five hours so it's a
storage device it's not a you know
perpetual production right so just so
people understand when you see for
batteries when they don't leave out the
hours it's always normalized for one
hour so you can only get five megawatts
for one hour out of that battery and
that's it
right right i think it's theoretically
possible that a battery storage could
have even a higher momentary rating
which might be its interconnection
rating yeah you know that said it could
discharge six megawatts but it couldn't
do that for a whole hour that would be
their rated maximum output though so i
just want to clarify some people see
that and they think that's kind of okay
thank you i appreciate you doing that
okay mr robarge department of energy
and guests
uh thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record griffin roberge
from the department of energy joining me
up here today is david wiesner from the
department he is our legal counsel in
the department
the department is neutral on senator
waters senate bill 321
just as background and i'm sure it goes
over some ground that we touched on with
house bill 1635.
senate bill 91 from last year created
the
commission to study limited electric
energy producers or lipa commission as
i'm sure you've heard it
the commission filed a report on
november 1 of last year that noted
significant complexities uncertainties
and potential risks
associated with the proposal to expand
lipa retail sales
sales transactions and provide avoided
transmission charge credits to
participants in those transactions
the report did warn of unintended
consequences and the potential of cost
shifting from one class of electricity
customer to another
the report did recommend a few next
steps all of which essentially involve
further study of the many complex issues
that are involved
whether by
the new hampshire general court the
legislature
the department or through a limited
future pilot program with quote a
defined sunset date
senate bill 321 does permit the puc to
approve
pilot programs for certain limited
electricity
energy producers to engage in
intra-state retail
and wholesale
electricity sales transactions this bill
does have a more limited approach
compared to house bill 1635 which you
folks heard earlier
but the committee later decided to
interim study
regarding the bill in front of you today
the department did want to phrase a few
technical concerns
while it appears it was probably touched
on earlier
while the thrust of the bill is to
create a pilot program for these types
of transactions there is no defined
limits on size
scale
time periods or end dates for any pilot
nor are there any specific provisions
for study or reporting regardless of the
results of the approved pilot programs
again referencing senate bill 424 that
came up some of the kind of concepts
outlined in that bill
and additionally on page two of the bill
lines one
to six
um that would allow any limited producer
participating in an approved pilot that
ends before december 31 of 2040
to be eligible for the applicable net
metering tariff
to which it would have otherwise been
eligible at the start of the pilot
this was essentially grandfather limited
producer into a tariff that did not
originally seek advantage of and had not
relied upon in developing a project it
may be more
appropriate for that producer to be
eligible only for the net marine tariff
that is in effect at the time the pilot
ends
that concludes my testimony certainly
happy to take any questions but
any complex questions i'm going to punt
over to david here on to the side
okay thank you very much
since mr weissner is here
i do have a question for you
i'm sorry
i asked no iso new england has an open
access transmission tariff
and they also require utilities to sign
a transmission owner's
operators agreement
in order for these leap transactions as
described in this this bill to take
place
would that require
iso new england and ferc
to
change those existing tariffs and
operating agreements
and is there any
reason why they would want to do that
that's an interesting question mr
chairman i think the commission last
fall heard some testimony about that
and i think the premise of this bill is
that it's possible to structure these
transactions as holy interest date so
they would not be using the for
jurisdictional transmission system and
therefore presumably no
modifications to the isoterror for
procedures would be necessary
so would that restrict these
transactions just to local distribution
uh
networks
i mean again that's an interesting
question i'm not sure was fully resolved
and might be an issue in any pilot
adjudication before the puc
it may depend on the specifics of the
case where the generator is located
where the customer would be located what
facilities are involved
it's possible that every source or other
utilities would have more to contribute
to that analysis and i expect they would
uh in the context of a puc adjudication
okay great thank you any other questions
representative harrington has one
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
the issue that both you and cliff
brought up about the um what happens if
you want to revert back i i see both
sides of your argument i mean him saying
that people aren't going to agree to go
back to something if they don't know
what it is and you saying how can you go
back to something that um
it doesn't exist anymore
any
solutions out there that you see
possible
i mean i guess our perspective is we
typically think of grandfathering as
protecting a reliance interest so you
built a project on an assumption that
you'd have the benefit of a certain net
metering tariff design for example uh
and under the puc order and under the
statute prior to that
you would be grandfathered through 2040.
if i understand what's intended in this
bill it's preserving more of the
opportunity cost value you made a choice
to go with a lepa pilot rather than that
metering and when that pilot ends
whether it's 5 10 15 years down the road
the thought is you would be able to
revert to the benefits that you forwent
when you decided to to sign up for the
pilot and that's that's not the normal
concept of grandfathering i i might
offer um
and and it would in certain
circumstances require the utility to
preserve sort of an open net metering
tariff design for somebody who might
change their mind later
after the puc had revised net metering
going forward
and i'll also say that
to some extent grandfathering is to
protect the interest of a new developer
and as i read this bill it's not limited
to new development an existing hydro for
example under five megawatts uh could
seek to take advantage of this and and
then as i say you're not really
protecting the same reliance interest
because the plant was built in 1982 you
know
thank you follow-up
uh on the the question of that which is
phrase about the transmission because
what this came up and another bill on
the other day if it was inter interest
intrastate
meaning it could be let's say eversource
for example they said that they would
have areas where you could have a
generator in one location and a customer
on that one that connected with them on
this limited uh producer thing uh would
be
far enough away in the state that they
would actually use the transmission
system to get the power there so does
that then create go back to chairman
voice moses question about does that
mean we have to look at any implications
to the uh to the iso tariff
i mean i don't want to pretend to be an
expert
in this hearing but i think there are
probably are situations where a
generator in one location and a customer
and another
it's hard to see how the power would
flow to that customer without the use of
the
ferc jurisdictional
pool transmission facilities that will
be subject to the iso
there are other situations where it's
probably perfectly reasonable to assume
that there would be no use of
you know physical or financial no use of
the
wholesale bulk transmission system
thank you
additional questions for these gentlemen
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman
i just want to get back to what you just
said because i'm trying to understand
this um
my understanding was that
um the transmission is first
jurisdiction but distribution as a local
uh
distribution utility
but
who is responsible for the transmission
system in our state
i i thought that went across the state
lines that's when ferc is involved and
otherwise when it's in our state
by default or by contract uh the
distribution tool is also in charge
somehow the transmission system is there
where is the legal boundary there i i'm
not sure it's entirely clear
i think the premise of the bill is that
um if both the generator and the
customer are within the state yes then
any use of facilities within the state
to deliver the power would be an
intra-state transaction
and therefore not subject to iso new
england or ferc
and i'm not sure that's been tested i'm
not sure that's well established but
that is the premise and and as i say
those are some of the details that i
would assume would be worked out uh in a
particular proposal that would come
before the puc
thank you very much
okay
representative lowkey has a question
um might it be possible to add a
provision that essentially says that
uh
the tran the uh sender generator and the
user are within the same node off of the
uh major transmission thing then it
would be legit because that truly would
be interesting interesting
i mean that might be overly limiting
and and i
think i don't want to speak for mr bilo
but he would probably say that it might
be over overly limiting
um again i'm not sure those
jurisdictional lines are as clearly
established as any of us might like
in an approach like that
might seem like a safe harbor but it it
could also be overly limited
okay seeing no further questions we
thank you both for your
testimony here this afternoon thank you
and now i'd like to call up donna
gamache from eversource to testify on
this bill
good afternoon ms gamache
great to see you again nice to see you
all again thank you very much for the
record donna gamache with eversource
energy
um and right out of the gate i just want
to say that i wish i had um attorney
wiesner here to punt the difficult
questions too
i apologize that our ferc experts as
much as i tried to get it on their
calendar i just could not align it so
you have me today so without that ferc
expertise as a result i'd like to keep
my testimony as high level as possible
and if you do have any questions that i
cannot respond to i promise to get back
to you with answers so with that i just
want to say thank you to senator waters
and also to um mr bilo for trying to
address the concerns that we have raised
while this bill was going through the
senate
and one of the ways that they tried to
to do that was to turn this into a pilot
and
one of the biggest concerns that we have
is the issue of jurisdiction and as you
just heard from attorney wiesner
apparently in so many areas it's a gray
area so um this is very very complicated
and during the senate bill 91 uh
commission meetings i think it was
pretty clear it was complicated we had
the same issues we raised them during
senate bill 91 nothing has changed for
us since then um to now
but we do appreciate all the work that's
gone into this to try to address our
concerns
but i also want to say that as a company
we appreciate the idea of creating an
additional stream of revenue to try to
facilitate
new clean energy
development in the state
and we know that in so many of these
transactions
they they cannot they cannot get
financing unless they've got
certainty and over the years you as a
committee you know representative kelly
pitts seen them all
you guys have worked
tirelessly to try to make sure that
there was a way to ensure that these
projects would get off the ground
you were very committed you
created the renewable portfolio standard
net metering group net metering virtual
net metering and then just late last
year enhanced community aggregation so
that you know inherently that these
projects
tend to need help so there are you
you've stepped up to the plate and now
there's another potential opportunity
and we just want to make sure that
before you take the next leap on this
one like you had you had many years to
work out all the others that we take a
breather and make sure that it works for
somebody like us
we're opposed to this for the following
reasons
we believe that the state does not have
the jurisdiction over these types of
transactions you've heard about it
people have talked about it before me
i've chatted with our ferc experts
ad nauseum over this and they feel very
confident
that
that while the intent is that these are
intrastate transactions only using the
distribution system
eversource unlike the other utilities in
the state
we represent well over 70 percent of the
state in our service territory and it's
while we we will probably be able to
come up with um instances where a
project can come forward that only uses
our distribution
uh system we would have to make sure
that it was on the same distribution
feeder
and
but we'd have to be able to monitor that
because we are moving power around on a
regular basis as you know you've watched
us evolve as a company we're far more
reliable we have far more automation and
the whole purpose is to move power as
quickly as necessary so it is very very
difficult to monitor especially given
our geographic area so um and you
mentioned representative votes about the
um
the transmission owners operators
agreement and we fear that this unless
we can prove that it is specifically
using just our distribution
network that it would violate that
agreement that we have i with iso new
england
so now we do appreciate that the um that
the intent of the sponsors is that it
not violate that so we would you know
we'd be open to working with this
committee on language that would find in
some ways if we can come up with
language that we could all agree with
that would narrow this scope down as
much as possible
um
and so
i mean one i i did want to raise there's
a good reason why iso new england
manages the transmission system and the
transmission system whether it is in
state and out of state so how we see it
is if if there's a project say in nashua
within our service territory in nashua
selling to a customer or vice versa a
customer up in coast county it's pretty
hard to imagine a time when it wasn't
going to be using our transmission
system and with that iso new england has
jurisdiction
and as i said there's a good reason for
that it's to ensure reliability iso has
to know what's happening on the system
so that they can manage it but also for
charging for rate recovery and it's to
ensure that all who use our transmission
system are paying their fair share of it
so if we do get past all that and we
were to be able to come up with some
language that worked that gave us some
more comfort we
we think that there are some questions
that probably it's the public utilities
commission or the department of energy
would have to answer and that is if you
can prove that there are in fact savings
those savings would have to be bundled
and would they they would have to find a
way to calculate that to bundle it and
to get it back not those savings would
naturally go back to ratepayers if this
if if this were to happen but to find a
way to not only calculate it bundle it
but not to give it back to ratepayers
but instead to give it to the generator
and another question is if there are
really no savings is the intent of the
language to create saving to create a
credit to the generator where there
isn't savings already and thereby
uh
there would need to be a calculation
something would need to be created to
create to raise rates in order to give a
credit to those generators so anyway if
you do decide to move forward with this
bill those are kind of our questions
we'd love to be at the table with you to
find the solutions we agree with the
previous speakers that there should be a
cap there should be a reporting
requirement and there should be a
duration limit um
and and i think that would you know
much of the other stuff has been raised
before me so i i think i will end there
great thank you any questions for ms
gamache
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh miss gamache
um in the example you gave from nashua
to coast i think
one of the questions that i had since
you started out with discussing the
transmission and transmission costs and
applicability of those costs to these
projects
my understanding is that in our
surrounding states in new england that
are doing more investing than we are in
these types of
projects
that the the point really is to have
local generations serve local needs so
that
transmission
transmission costs are avoided
you know we've had reports in this
committee that new hampshire is going to
be picking up a higher share of
transmission costs in the future because
there's less investment here
in these types of generation projects so
i guess my question is i i don't know
how you come to the i understand the
concern of saying
we may not
know when transmission lines are
involved
but isn't there a way for us to
determine that if if a pilot like this
comes online and it's you know it's
going to be a
finite proposal that they're going to
work with whatever utility is involved
um to come up with so wouldn't wouldn't
that be something that would be answered
in the
speccing
game i'll end with the word specking and
you can go on from
well i think you raise uh very good
questions thank you for your questions
first i just want to start by saying
again we would i think the way you would
truly be able to do this is to make sure
that it is in its honest system on a
distribution feeder that we can prove is
really just on the distribution system
it is going to be hard to do but we
would be committed to to working with
the committee to find a way to see if we
can do that
i would say with regard to the
transmission costs um i i think that
over the years we've heard this bantered
about a bit and i think if you look at
how it is actually playing out in the
region
i'm not sure it's playing out that way
exactly and the reason is if you can
look you can see the the transmission
charges for each state they go up and
down and i'm not sure that you know if
you look over the last four or five
years that they probably haven't wound
their way back where they were
originally in many cases but because the
costs for transmission are the costs for
transmission and if every state in the
new england region reduce their tried to
reduce their transmission costs who
would be left to pay the transmission
bills there's just going to be another
way of allocating those costs so i just
wanted to raise that so i think it's a
noble exercise and at some point i mean
we should all try to do it but at some
point the transmission costs are what
they are and we're going to have to
cover those costs may i have a follow-up
i'd prefer you didn't
we have a couple of more people who need
to testify
and it's already almost 3 30.
uh do you need a question representative
samsic
representative callie pitts
okay
go ahead representative samsic
um
so thank you mr chairman and thank you
mr umash for being here um
we have heard so often and i think it's
well well deserved that eversource is
one of the outstanding utilities in the
country when it comes to energy
efficiency issues
battery storage and using energy
when it's most needed
is one of those techniques to
even out the demand
and provide a valuable energy when it's
most needed
it seems to me that even energy
efficiency is nothing different than a
load reducer
you're moving around demand so some
place you reduce your demand and moves
around and you guys manage the grid
based on what the demand is so is this
about the bill
yes so so i think uh to i would be
surprised if you don't have examples in
other states already where you've been
working of how to manage battery storage
in a way that doesn't violate the
transmission issues
i can tell you from what i know about
our
battery storage opportunities is where
we have we have one i
if it's not online yet it's pretty close
to being online
and it's in the cape
and it's intended to it's in a very
sensitive ecological area and they have
a need for another um distribution line
and so instead of constructing in a very
ecologically sensitive area we have a
battery uh storage uh project out there
and the hope is that we will show that
you know it does so much more than we
had hoped
and i think in some other areas of
massachusetts we're moving forward with
that as well
i think representative oxenam knows very
well that we tried to have a battery
storage project here in new hampshire as
well so we're not opposed to testing
those out as long as they work and we
can work with our regulators to make
them um feasible for our customers we're
always open to that
so you're saying it's an alternative to
transmission lines is the battery in the
case of cable well it's that's a
distribution line
um but i we believe that you know as
this technology um advances we'll be
using more batteries
instead of maybe an upgrade to a
substation or an additional line here
and there okay thank you you're welcome
okay thank you ms gamache appreciate
your testimony i'll now call on
rent
j
adlow
could you could you spell your last name
for me
a-a-l-t-o okay
like a soprano only an alto
uh
uh first uh i have uh
some
materials here that uh
that's uh
they're prepared for an article
for um
the concrete monitor and i had the
uh
thank you
i had the honor of sharing the opinion
page
uh
with the uh
chairman of the today here and
yes it was a contrasting opinion i think
uh for those that don't know who i am
my name is pentialto
i'm a consultant
i've been in the
and i live in pembroke new hampshire
i've been looking at the issue of
integrating
uh distributed generation
and active load
into the grid
since
the early 70s
when i realized
as an engineering person that i could
have a nice technical solution to a
problem that was irrelevant because of
policies
based on that i began to focus on
change in the electric industry
and
that led me to
initiate a project that became the
governor's commission on cogeneration in
massachusetts in the mid 70s
that
had an influence on the design of the
purple rules which
permitted
qualifying facilities to sell power to
utilities
um
and from there uh what became apparent
that
a restructuring of the industry was
necessary so i was part of
many
uh hearings on restructuring the
electric industry
particularly since we view it as we've
viewed it as a natural monopoly when it
wasn't
the paper that i submitted talks
primarily this was written many years
ago as you can see i'm dyslexic so
nobody can read what i write and this
took about a month to write
um it was written
looking at net metering
and i think these are very relative
issues here
in my view
we can simplify this by basically having
a transparent reversible price
to the customer whether they buy or sell
it is the same price
the issue with that of course is that
it's inefficient
in the sense that
it doesn't represent cost the pricing
structure we have doesn't represent cost
it doesn't represent value
except in a very loose way
that leads to
across subsidies
not just for the solar that may be
generating and i there was another term
to the duck curve called cat sears which
came from the
um
the executive running uh gordon van gli
running the iso
if you look at today's load curves
you'll see there's a morning spike and
an evening spike of about the same size
and
that's been there for well beyond the
times that solar has been around it's
always there
the the issue that comes from all of
this is that
ultimately we need to be able to see as
customers what's going on in the system
and then either contribute to that
controlling costs or not
the problem is if we do not control the
cost particularly of transmission and
distribution
with the advent of batteries more and
more people will find that they can
disconnect
and that would be a lost all of us it
would be much better if their equipment
and services that they provide can be
integrated into the system
so that we all benefit from it
um i believe this piece of legislation
moves us a step in that direction it
looks at the issue of transmission
as a potential
uh cost-saving area
i further look at going further than
that into the distribution system itself
to allow for variable pricing for
distribution service
both in location and in time
so if you're at the far end of a system
you would pay a little bit more for the
power you buy
and get a higher credit for if you sold
some at that point than if you were at
the substation end of it
because there's a lot of wire that cost
is
necessary to get the power to you
likewise if the wire is melting on an
august afternoon the price should be a
lot higher
if there's no load on the wire the price
should be zero with a hockey stick type
of price curve connecting them which is
what happens in
markets
when you get a shortage of capacity
you get that kind of shape
we are not there
and
experiments like this one pilots looking
at ways of
are beginning toward that
if we do not succeed
we will destroy the utility industry
it will go the way of railroads it will
go the way of wired telephone service
um
at any number of other activities that
we have if we can properly integrate
distributed generation into the grid in
a way that
still provides revenue recovery within
reason to utilities
then
we would all benefit from that
now the issue is that if a bunch of
generators begin to appear in
distribution that does reduce the
payments the revenue
for distribution and transmission
service
is that absolutely guaranteed that that
will be recovered no
the history of regulation has it that a
utility or any regulated entity is not
protected against competition
or changes in the market
um or changes in the economy generally
they have a reasonable opportunity to
recover their investment
with a reasonable return on that
investment
but if they can't maintain a price that
is in the public interest
they don't recover it
they go broke somebody else buys the
assets for a reduced price and continues
running it
cases like that can be found with market
street railway in the 40s
street railway was over invested
and it went away and was bought by
someone else who ran it for many years
i don't want to go that route we have a
substantial amount of money invested in
our systems can we come up with a way
that allows us to transition to a system
that provides efficiency in pricing for
all
mr bilo mentioned there that for this
one residentials probably would not be
included
i can point out that for 15 years
commonwealth edison has had a rate
available to residential customers
that it was hourly variable in one form
or another
the most recent rate is a real-time rate
it changes every hour
and they have to support that a
five-minute rate which is available
for control of the equipment that
customers have
those that choose to can support by
reducing load
turning on generation
and other things like that
their exposure
is as
mr bilo mentioned similar in that they
have a capacity obligation for
generation
excuse me i hate to interrupt you but
yes uh could you
relate what you're discussing to this
particular bill this particular bill is
a step in the way to get there
and i believe it's a good one because it
provides one more alternative
as a way of getting from where we have
been for 100 years and to where we need
to be if this is going to survive
okay excellent good any questions for
him
i'll leave it at that alta
seeing none
thank you i thank you for your testimony
and i call kelly buchanan to be the
final speaker on uh senate bill 3210
all right good afternoon folks or nearly
good evening um
i will be brief today but i thank you
for your time my name is kelly buchanan
i
am the director of legislative and
regulatory affairs for clean energy new
hampshire and we are glad to support
senate bill 321 which explores an
innovative policy through a limited
pilot program basis and that would be
appropriately vetted at the puc
and i want to draw folks back to um some
earlier remarks from eversource and
donna gamache that there are some
concerns and some disagreements
regarding whether ferc comes into this
discussion
and i would argue that these questions
really are most appropriately answered
at the public utilities commission and
that would be the venue in which we
would expect and
be assured that any concerns regarding
ferc jurisdiction on each of these pilot
programs would be resolved and if there
was an issue that those pilots would not
move forward and would not be approved
and so i think senate bill 321 really
places the appropriate guard rails in
place
and would help us expand the marketplace
for distributed energy resources locally
produced energy
in that one to five megawatt category
which is so important so
i will end with that i will also mention
that borrego is very interested in
expanding their business into new
hampshire they're already quite active
in massachusetts and maine they
apologize for not being able to be here
today
but they are very excited about the
opportunity for the
value of avoided transmission and
capacity costs to be recognized in new
hampshire so with that thank you very
much and i'd be glad to take with any of
your questions
thank you miss buchanan we appreciate
that any questions from ms buchanan
representative mcgee thank you mr
chairman
yes that was the question i had in
follow-up as well as whether the as a
pilot that these uh issues could be
addressed through the public utilities
commission and i wonder since you have
participated
in public utilities commission
dockets
uh whether you think even beyond the
transmission question there were several
questions that were raised at the time
that eversource was up testifying
that whether those would be the types of
things that would be addressed in a puc
proceeding
for a pilot sure i think
um there was some earlier mention from
the department of energy that a duration
a cap and a study and reporting
requirement would be useful in this bill
language and i think that is something
that we certainly agree with
and that would be fine to implement
anything else though beyond the
parameters of the pilot program i think
really could be decided at the public
utilities commission with the
appropriate
stakeholders involved i know uh miss
kamash mentioned
the ferc expertise i'm sure that they
would be accurately represented at the
public utilities commission
thank you
okay
seeing no further questions for ms
buchanan i would like to thank you for
your testimony thank you and i would
like to ask representative white for the
blue sheet count on senate bill 321
all right so we have one in support uh
on the sheet and then we have 74 online
in support and no opposing
okay thank you with that we'll close the
public hearing on
senate bill 321 and resume the already
open public hearing on senate bill 448
and i'll ask the prime sponsor senator
david waters to introduce this bill to
the committee
and i will alert everyone to the fact
that there is only one pink card before
me with regard to this bill
so if anybody else wants to testify you
need to submit a pink card
and senator waters is yours i don't know
what it is about senate bills but they
seem to take longer than house bills we
always get through our public hearings
on time but
senate bills i don't know we just don't
seem to be able to make it
thank you mr chairman senator david
water district 4 and i just say maybe
it's just because the senators don't
know what they're doing
is that what you're thinking
you have to clean up our messes all
right
um well thank you thank you mr chairman
i am senator david waters district 4
introducing senate bill 448 ready ready
relative energy reduction by state
agencies
um the bill does two things uh the first
part of the bill is a kind of a clean up
on our existing policy established by a
series of executive orders about the um
state
energy
committee
and as you'll see here this executive
order began in 2004
have continued been renewed for
four times and they have certain goals
so what has changed here is just to
clean up do some cleanup on reporting
procedures
uh line 13 you'll see
and then line 18 on the first page um
about
when this report should be done and uh
to whom
they should
uh should go
um
and you'll see that continue the
language at the top of page 2 is the
governing language for
the economic benefits of what the state
energy committee
has done
and this is in the this is language from
the executive orders so there's nothing
really new
uh there and um just to note uh that
this program has saved over 50 million
dollars for the state of new hampshire
in terms of what we've achieved for
energy efficiency and transitioning
uh through energy conservation
uh strategic electrification and you
know all the kinds of things that we see
for administrative services in the
um capital budget every year to try to
you know refit our buildings and so on
so it's been a a good
uh savings effort
so the rest of the bill is an
opportunity for us to extend
the capacity to save the state money
through
looking at and planning for the
transition of the state vehicle fleet to
electric
vehicles
and
what you'll see starting on page two on
line 17
are some definitions of light
duty trucks and passenger vehicles and
then a little bit later on you'll see a
definition of
heavy duty trucks as as well
and starting at the bottom of page two
it
says that as the state is purchasing
releasing vehicles
let's
get the lowest emission vehicles
available and then important words get
repeated again and again on the bill to
extend feasible feasible practicable and
cost effective based on total cost of
ownership exclusive of the cost of
energy vehicle supply equipment using
projected actual ownership time and
miles driven per year
so the heart of it is there it says
these vehicles are there we can help
meet energy consumption reduction goals
by transitioning to them as it's
practical and feasible and
cost-effective for various classes of
vehicles
um because you know certainly there are
some classes of vehicles this you know
right now might the cost of the the cost
in there or the kind of vehicle that's
being used isn't isn't there and
considering a lot of our heavy duty
vehicles have 20 30-year life spans it's
gonna be a long a long period of
transition
part of the timeliness of the bill is
that for the last couple of years now
the state fleet index which is produced
each year through administrative
services and the fleet manager which
lists the vehicles that may be purchased
by the state
and lists them in rank order of the best
bang for the buck and for the last you
know last year the top two vehicles were
electric vehicles
and um so it's clearly right now the
total cost of ownership and um you know
including operations savings on fuel
saving guns maintenance and so on that
we've overcome the differential there
may be because some of these vehicles
are a little more um expensive
now um
so
the other part of uh this you'll see it
can continue going into the
into page
three uh is the planning
function of this
uh and a large part of the reason for
this bill is that under the state energy
committee right now
there is not the capacity to bring all
the agencies together that are
purchasing or leasing vehicles and say
let's plan together
not just so that we can rationalize
where we're going in a vehicle fleet but
we've got to be able to plan rationally
for the charging infrastructure that we
are going going to need and so that's
the reason for
um asking agencies to make plans about
you know what what do you what do you
foresee for when you're going to want to
purchase what kind of vehicles how many
are going out of service how many are
you know getting certain age or what are
the what type are they and then if you
were to transition those to
electric if those you know practical
feasible etc and what kind of charging
infrastructure
are you going uh going to need and um
that that those plans would then feed in
as they do now for state vehicle
purchases into the um
into the capital budget where we
determine such things
um then
the other part of this is the charging
uh infrastructure
and uh
so we need to provide charging
infrastructure for our state agencies so
if they get these vehicles we've got a
little bit now
and so let me address that when we had
the volkswagen
fund settlement
the governor determined that the maximum
amount possible that we could spend
legally under that settlement that could
go to electric vehicle infrastructure
would go to that point and i think that
was a wise forward-looking decision i
applaud the governor for that and so
there is funding there for state agency
charging infrastructure
since that time
we have received an infrastructure bill
an additional 17 million dollars which
is the state of new hampshire's
part of the bucket for
vehicle charging infrastructure
in
another committee i have a bill that's
setting up a fund for our receiving that
fund and uh
as using the governor's criteria directs
how that money's going to go and a big
portion of that is going to go to state
agencies so they can get this
infrastructure
built in addition to that there is also
an infrastructure built 2.5 to 5 billion
dollar grant program that in the state
of new hampshire will be able to apply
to
in a large a big part of that is also
for electric vehicle
infrastructure
not just along our state vehicle
corridors but also for state agency use
so it's important to note that the bill
then
says the planning is not that we're
going to try to you know bust the budget
because we're going to be having to pay
for all this infrastructure but that
we've got funding there's a flow of
funding coming in so that if we
rationally plan
um we can
we can do do this um the amount of money
that we potentially can save per vehicle
um i've seen estimates of some like ten
thousand dollars for a typical light
duty vehicle you're gonna save
um moving forward i think for the heavy
duty vehicles when we get to that point
the subs these savings are going to be
much much more
uh substantial
but again practical reasonable
um
feasible for vehicle class
and uh and cost effective um with it
so the last part of the bill
um
says okay uh
you know
we're going to receive your plans
they're going to be reviewed
they're going to see what is good to go
what is operational and we're going to
get reports
about how this is how this is going and
of course through the capital
budget program that's another chance for
the legislature to scrutinize how this
is being done
i'll say one final word on the physical
note
um
that
you know part of the issue of the fiscal
note uh it did not and you know it says
okay uh we're going to spend some we're
going to be you know charging costs
especially if you're doing dc fast
chargers those are very expensive
and they have to you know be used for
fast charging and also for heavy
duty vehicles i could see some vehicles
where you've got to get them back right
back on the road after 15 20 minutes a
half an hour to get the charge back fast
charger is good heavy duty vehicle
because they're drawing so much
electricity fast charge is good a lot of
light duty vehicles though are going to
be
um level two charging and those
you know 600 dollars to fourteen hundred
dollars to put in
um uh charging for that and um that's
what we have already a little bit up to
go to the state office park or over here
to green street where those were
uh put in by the des and um those are
much much less expensive so um
you know i suppose it's gonna say
there's some unknowns out there that the
this you know the the ground is shifting
here we know that the major auto
manufacturers in the united states have
said that they're gonna phase out any
production of conventionally fueled
vehicles by 2030 2035.
the european nations have passed laws
saying that's the case massachusetts is
contemplating laws saying by 2035 you
can't buy
a
conventionally fueled vehicle um so we
know that all the new models that are
coming out and the costs will come down
because of that there'll be many more we
know in the heavy duty vehicles sue
cummings the largest manufacturers of
diesel
engine in the united states has said
they're going all-electric um peterbilt
mack lyon the other the other big ones
uh are saying they're heading this
direction too so i suspect we see a lot
of good usable uh vehicles of various
classes the price will be coming down so
um let's do some rational planning thank
you mr chairman
thank you senator
i think we have quite a few questions
for you about this bill we'll start with
uh representative callie pitts
thank you senator waters
um
my understanding was that the fleet is
now being
replaced with electric vehicles where
possible and that that was the order
i
looked at the fiscal note of 96
what is it 96 000 to 447
37 000 to replace the stations
uh
have we thought at all in conjunction
with all the departments have we thought
about
producing our own electricity on sites
where these are going to be
charged so i would imagine
check me if i'm wrong
i don't know much about the vehicles
except when i see them i want them to
operate
um
places where they're going to be charged
will be
stationed so they wouldn't be just
one
you'd be charging dot station across
from my house has several trucks and
other utility vehicles anything about
putting in perhaps solar powered
charging stations and batteries in there
so that we do the whole enchilada all at
once instead of doing it piecemeal
well thanks
for the several questions there and i'll
try to get through them
yes some electric vehicles are being
bought by the state
there's no program to do that
there's no there's no plan there's no
comprehensive plan to do it
that's why the bill is here
i wrote it you know i worked with
administrative services fleet manager
over the last couple years on on these
issues and this will be very
very helpful to them
to get various agencies to come together
and do this rationally and also
purchasing
cooperatively so that they can get
better deals let us note as well that
municipalities can buy
their vehicles
at the state fleet price
so that you know we have an opportunity
there to help our local municipalities
and i just as an aside we'll say that
some of the funding we're getting from
the infrastructure fund is going to help
is going to provide municipalities with
charging
and infrastructure and that funding we
have and the
247 another committee is going to you
know authorizes uh that
um now the second thing you mentioned
that ninety six thousand dollar figure i
tried to mention well you know there's
two things about that they just went to
the fast charge model we're gonna need
some fast charging dc fast charging
they're pretty expensive stations to to
put in but we're going to need a lot
more that are the the cheaper ones to
put in
but the point is that we're not going to
spend money we don't have we have money
coming in for charging infrastructure if
we plan for it we can rationally decide
where it should go how it's going to be
used
now in terms of generation of
electricity i don't know we're hearing
about these bills all the time community
solar is this and that and the other
thing and uh
i mean beats me you know i i think we
get we have some pretty good big
generators uh in the state like
eversource and so on that produce
electricity and uh
one side about though is that what these
what we're moving towards is vehicle to
grid technology
so that if you have a large fleet and i
mentioned merchants fleet there
merchants fleet i don't know if they're
the largest fleet company in the country
but they're based here in new hampshire
they're going all electric okay so you
know fleet managers see this is really a
way to go and another part of if you do
vehicle to grid technology you can
charge them up
when the electricity is cheap i saw last
week sometime that the we're in a
negative cost of electricity during the
day because so much was being produced
right
charge them up then
and then we hit those peaks we just
heard about the cat's ears and the ducks
and all that stuff
right um then at that point you can sell
it back into the grid you can monetize
your battery storage capacity that's why
merchants fleet and that's why
a lot of you know we have another bill
another committee about electric school
bus pilot program that has a provision
there that you could do the vehicle to
grid
so this is
we're just getting started this bill
says a lot is happening let's plan let's
do it cost effectively
and this will help the state move
forward
representative berezni has a question
thank you chairman and thank you senator
waters for taking my question you
mentioned that the costs will come down
over time
uh
what's the downside of being late to the
game on this and waiting until there's
more private charging stations thank you
well thanks for your question i mean
we're building out charging stations but
you know state fleeters we've got a
state fleet voter provide for charging
right i mean we fuel the state fleet now
um so that that's why and the thing is
um
you know the their cost they're cost
effective now i mean right now they're
the top two vehicles on the list
um so i don't you know we can get going
and um
the the what they call the learning you
know the more units produced the more
the cost comes down
we're just about to hit the point with
some vehicles where there's no cost
differential between the electric and
the conventionally
fueled and i think we're going to see
that
a lot more um so i i don't really see a
reason why there'd be an advantage to us
uh
to wait
representative harrington and thank you
mr chairman thank you senator for taking
my question senator i inadvertently
turned off your microphone
uh on the bottom of page
two as you rightly pointed out on
line 34 talks about to the extent
feasible practical and cost effect
effective based on total cost of
ownership
and
then we get over to page three
and you kind of do the same thing but we
leave out that cost effective part on
line eight with the ability the vehicles
to perform the intended function
and
we don't have that cost effective based
on total total ownership there
and then on line 18 again we have to the
extent feasible but cost effective gets
left out
and then online
where was this next one here
to the line 32 to the extent feasible
and again cost effective is left out any
reason why it was left out in those
three places and it was put in the other
one
it seems to be almost like the same line
to the extent feasible is used in
multiple times
well
you know if you want a belt and
suspenders did why not
when it comes to state spending yeah
yeah i mean no i mean really i i mean
the cost effective to me i think this is
a non-starter if we can't demonstrate
it's cost effective okay you know i mean
i i like to save the state money it's
taxpayer money right it's not my money
it's taxpayer money and so um i think in
some places i didn't do that because
like on line 32 it says such plans the
cost of electric vehicle supply
committed and so on and so forth but i i
think in detail counter than cost
analysis so um but i think the more we
put in cost effective please please add
it if you think that would help thank
you thanks for pointing that out
who's next representative lewicki
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
um one would
expect that state vehicles are going to
be used primarily during the day and
they aren't going to be able to you know
do we really want our state employees oh
i'd take a however long break while my
electric vehicle charges
so most of them are probably going to
get charged at the end of the day
and that would then
uh as in the previous bill
we have the issue of uh increasing load
on the grid so they would probably want
to put them on timers would we not
so that they're getting charged in the
middle of the night
um thanks for your question and um a
couple answers to it uh i say yes and no
um in that you know these vehicle range
250 300 miles 350 miles
um so you could kind of figure out it's
like you know it's like your cell phone
you don't wait until it gets all the way
to the bottom every time
right if you've come in off you're
running your route you throw a little
charge into it right so i think there'll
be some of that
but i bring this out too because they'll
have a computer that does it but they
will be able to track for every vehicle
that might be plugged in everywhere at
that moment what the cost of electricity
is and you can actually automate it so
that it pulls it in only when it's using
less expensive electricity
um and then the advantage is that if you
you know let's say you're leaving it
overnight
the vehicle comes in at four or five
o'clock we're hitting peak demand
do the vehicle to grid pull some power
out of it
we get to 4 a.m in the morning
um
power's cheap again charge it up so it's
good to go in the morning you can
already i mean i i can already do that
with my car you can do that so um this
is what we're you know
this is management of of it once you
have it and i think there will be ways
to
to monetize the batteries themselves and
to take care of you know figuring out
the charging schedule for a given
vehicle
all right thank you thank you
representative samsic
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question
right up front i want to say i think
this is a great bill and a great
initiative and i think the state should
lead the way on this
but i also agree that it needs to be
feasible and economically viable to do
it
uh i'm i i'll likewise assume that that
will be a test that will be used
i want to point out one thing however
and i don't know how that folds into
this issue but
what about the cost of the actual
electricity involved here because the
union of concerned scientists recently
reported that these charging stations
throughout the country
they can vary in price per kilowatt hour
dramatically some places are charging
like three dollars per kilowatt hour
which is a ridiculous price it's like
paying 30
a gallon for gasoline
so the price that's negotiated for the
state when they charge these vehicles
that will be very critical
uh then you can't get the prices when
you go to a charging station off i-93 or
something like that
thanks for your question and um in
indeed you're right you know when i
charge up at home i figure i'm paying
the equivalent of about a dollar ten a
gallon i do tonight if i charge up over
here in green street at the des facility
um depends on time of day you know i get
up here i might go over there and park a
photo while throwing some charge into it
and i might
if i get about 50 miles
um out of it and i might be paying 2.70
still a whole lot less than a gallon of
gas right now i might i might add
to your question particularly though
these are going to be state chargers
right
so the state will be able to negotiate
its cost of electricity
with the with the utilities and use the
mechanisms i've already described to
purchase cheap electricity when they can
i have a question for you senator do the
plans covered by this bill
include the building
infrastructure for charging stations
for example in d.o.t garages you're
going to need
substantial fire suppression equipment
because of the potential for
battery fires
which could do serious damage to
both the building and any vehicles
stored within the building so
does the plan
take into account those additional costs
well thanks for the question and um
you know i don't know if we have
somebody here from
becky i don't know maybe you can answer
some of these things but um you know if
you think about it mr chairman um we
have a lot of vehicles that are pretty
flammable right now they have a big
diesel tank or a big gas tank
all right and um the potential there for
for fire from those is there as well
and
i think the whole point of the planning
is that these considerations would be
there as you're trying to figure out the
feasibility
and the cost
um
and uh
the last thing i say about that too is
that you know i bet we all saw the
picture of that tesla that burst into
flames after the crash that was uh that
was really something you know i don't
know town is a merrimack or somewhere
manchester um you know and uh wow you
know and if a car burst in the flame wow
um
the battery technology is moving rapidly
towards um replacing
the lithium ion and the nickel
system um and uh coming to a battery
that won't won't do that in terms of the
large storage units i think they've
already pretty much gotten to one that
does that but they're moving towards um
sulfur and graphene batteries uh they're
moving towards iron
batteries solid-state batteries so um
you know i'd that's obviously miss
chairman a very important issue with the
safety around it but i think the
industry is moving towards
um
batteries uh that that are addressing
any concerns because there have been
some huh
yeah excellent thank you
representative callie pitts has another
question
may sound foolish but it's a question
that i'm just wondering about
um
i would think we have over a thousand
vehicles in the state fleet
add some zeros
add some zeros okay
so my question is basically it and it's
a maybe a foolish question does the
state pay
state road tax on its gasoline
it's just
i i i mean i i i guess so i mean why
everybody okay the reason i'm i'll tell
you the reason i'm wondering is i don't
know
but
we're going to eventually in the state
have a revenue problem for our roads
because of not being collecting state
gas taxes so
i was just wondering if the state pays
it and what kind of a impact that would
be and that again may sound foolish but
it's just something i've always wondered
about
well thank you i should know the answer
that i want senate transportation hey
but i i my mind is just blank um
but you you if you're worried about the
the increase in fuel efficiency and what
electric vehicles are going to do to our
revenues join everybody else in the
country that's wondering and have a
little conversation with representative
major
and he has some ideas about this
okay we have one other person who would
like to testify on this bill so i think
uh i'd like to
invite kelly buchanan to come up
mr chairman can i ask him one question
okay representative lang has a question
i realize you were even here yeah i i
came back i've been listening to my
office to the testimony and i came in i
so my question is along the lines of
representative kelly pitts is that i'm
concerned about the number of vehicles
we have what it might impact might be on
on the roads and the fact that we're
going to be reducing our revenues for
the state gas tax but
my other question i had was around if
we're talking about you said out of zero
when she said a thousand so yeah i'm
assuming you're talking about ten ten
thousand
i can find out i'm just sorry about that
my concern is about the grid itself and
the implication of adding all of this
new consumption on top of existing
consumption um and how that plays out
especially as it relates to the rate
payers if we have to upgrade
distribution um in the area due to the
increased load necessary for the number
of vehicles
thanks for that question i'm really glad
you brought that up um
we know that there is going to be an
enormous transition underway in america
because of electric vehicles
because of electrification of uh home
heating
and
so that you know
the the issue about generating capacity
and distribution this is why there is
such enormous
impetus behind offshore wind
because
there's a plan now 30 gigawatts of
offshore wind power by 2030 we're on
track for that the gulf of maine task
force which i sit on the governor asks
you know call for the establishment the
gulf of maine task force for off for
offshore wind
um we're meeting again in may
and it looks like leasing and auctions
will be in 2024 and it was steel in the
water a few years after that they're
being built up and down the east coast
the initial project in the gulf of maine
is going to be three to five gigawatts
um that's
what four seabrooks
uh and they anticipate 25 to 30
gigawatts in the gulf of maine alone
it's the saudi arabia wind
we are going to be generating a lot of
power we've got to on short we've got to
build distribution if eversource we're
here they will tell you that they are
concerned and you know looking forward
to a lot of costs to modernize the grid
it's why an infrastructure bill
and other bills in congress there's a
lot of money being put into grid
modernization
because you know we know this is
something we're going to do
i will say though a lot of people
electric vehicles and back to
representative callie pitts earlier
question about well can we generate our
own electricity at these sites and so on
and so forth if you've got solar and
you've got an inverter you can charge
off your own your own your own solar and
i think a lot of people electric
vehicles are who are also going to be
having heat pumps and inverters and so
on and so forth will be doing those
things complicated questions uh and and
issues but i think this is why you're
seeing so much conversation around new
sources of renewable energy generation
from offshore wind
follow-up
thank you mr chair so again i guess i'm
i
think i got the answer of not really but
i'm not positive um yeah the the
the infrastructure isn't actually the
electrical grid infrastructure is
nowhere in here we're talking about
increasing capacity for electric or
consumption of electricity but there's
no crazy perceived
cost in this build to what any in grid
improvements might be necessary in order
to achieve
this goal
we have no idea what that really looks
like um thanks for your question um so
you know part of it is uh you know
eversource if they do the make ready
work and bring in the power lines and
then charging station itself has a
certain cost and it's you know that's
what gets paid for about other
volkswagen fence or whatever
um
so
that's what the utilities are doing in
various states is the make ready work um
in terms of the scale of this
uh it's a kind of a we have 1.6 million
registered vehicles in the state of new
hampshire
so then you know if we have a few
thousand in a state fleet in and of
itself and you know a lot of these
garages already have heavy
um duty electrical wiring come into them
because they need that for for other
purposes so um
i think this in and of itself
those questions are
are relatively relatively minor because
it's the nature of the grid enhancements
that we're doing
all over the state for all kinds of
reasons
okay thank you senator and now kelly
buchanan can tell us how she feels about
this bill
all right thank you mr chair members of
the committee again for the record kelly
buchanan with clean energy new hampshire
um i will start with some questions that
we've already heard today i know there
was some concern about evs and role
tolls or alternative to world tolls
senator waters alluded to this but
representative major does have a bill
which is house bill 1040 that is
establishing a study commission to
examine exactly how we could address
that and we at clean energy new
hampshire do think it's a fairness issue
that evs should contribute to the use of
the roads in some way
the metric in the goal is to simply to
get to a solution so that will help us
find that and we expect that there will
be some sort of proposal out of that if
it passes so
that's item number one item number two
relates to grid modernization um and
some of the preparation that the
utilities have already gone underway at
the public utilities commission we've
been involved in
three separate dockets looking at ev
rates in terms of rates that they
receive when they purchase electricity
and ev make ready work
and so
we received an order in one of those
dockets we're still waiting on the
docket that pertains to unitil as well
as to eversource but the work is
underway and i will mention that a lot
of those grid modernization
improvements that would benefit our
capacity and our ability to serve an eb
market would also benefit most rate
payers because those investments
directly
reduce
inconveniences or
threats to life or comfort from outages
and
those sorts of events so grid
modernization is multi-faceted and can
be beneficial across an array of issues
i will say that this bill in particular
senate bill 448
is certainly one that we support and i
think it's really a cost saving
opportunity for the state that one must
recognize i'll throw out some numbers
here and say that the eb cost of
operation is about one dollar and
seventy cents per gallon of gas
equivalent ah when compared to a regular
vehicle which is about four dollars and
twelve cents and those numbers were
pulled from the department of
energy at the federal level
so we do not want to miss out on an
important opportunity to save taxpayer
money for the state and we can also
benefit from this federal funding that
is coming down to us to support the ev
charging infrastructure necessary for
those vehicles
uh so with that i know senator waters
really did an excellent job this
afternoon of covering the nitty gritty
details of the bill so i will conclude
and be happy to take any of your
questions
thank you
questions for ms buchanan
seeing none
we thank you so you can get home and get
your dinner
all right no other pink cards were
submitted so i assume nobody else wants
to testify on this bill
so
we will close the public hearing on
senate bill 448
and we will take a
five minute bio break and then we will
commence to
exec
six
i believe bills uh blue sheet on this
bill
representative white uh 44 in support
zero against
thank you
five minute break
it was like crispy
yeah
oh
um
i
so why not
this is
okay
i'm
i
there you go
[Music]
i know
oh
executive session starts in one minute
you
appreciate you being here today thank
you very much
okay
all right
oh
okay
gotta get gotta get to work
okay everybody i'm going to open an exec
session on senate bill 270
and i'm passing out
an amendment
which was
obtained for us by representative cali
pitts
this is the amendment that
the department of energy alerted us
to
[Music]
that we by oversight
forgot to adopt on senate bill 270.
so
i would like now for representative
kelly pitts
to give us a motion on the adoption of
the
amendment which is 2022-1444
h
could you turn on your mic please
i move that we adopt uh amendment
2022-1444-h
uh which are the minor amendments to
senate bill 271 270 that we agreed were
necessary and had to be passed
i think the second then amendment mr
chairman
representative harrington seconds the
amendment
is there any further discussion needed
representative callie pitts made the
motion
seeing none
i'll ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of adopting
amendment
2022-144 h
madam clerk
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative lange yes
representative mirner yes
clerk votes yes
representative berenshni
yes
representative bernardi
representative cambrils
yes
representative plojay yes representative
white
yes
representative somsich yes
representative callie pitts yes
representative mann yes
representative oxen m
i'm still looking for a copy um
of the amendment wait a second what's
this
that's the bill
nice to know what it is we're voting for
yes
uh representative lewicki yes
representative mcgee
yes
representative laflamme yes
pimentel yes
representative partial yes
representative vos yes
21-0
two the amendment
two one four four four h
is adopted representative loicke is
recognized for a motion thank you mr
chair i remove ought to pass as amended
for h uh senate bill 270.
it's been moved that we adopt as amended
senate bills 270 representative kim
brills is recognized for a motion
yeah thank you mr chair i would like to
second that motion okay it's moved and
seconded that we adopt as amended senate
bill 270 is there any further discussion
needed
seeing none i asked the clerk as soon as
she is
ready
to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended for senate
bill 270.
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative lange yes representative
mirner yes clark votes
yes representative berezni yes
representative bernardi
yes
representative cambrils yes
representative claudia yes
representative white
yes representative samsich yes
representative kelly pitts
representative mann yes representative
oxen
yes
representative lewicki yes
representative mcgee yes
representative gottling yes
representative leflamb yes
representative pementel yes
representative partial yes
representative vos yes
21-0
by a vote of 21 to nothing senate bill
270 is adopted as amended
and without consent will be placed on
the consent calendar
without objection i mean
objection
with our consent
michael you're just checking to see if
everyone was awake
apparently apparently you're paying
attention that's good
all right so we'll close that executive
session and will open an executive
session on senate bill 256
now this bill is relative to
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility of replacing the site
evaluation committee
and i will recognize
representative thomas for a motion
thank you miss chair uh on
sb 256 motion otp
and i recognize representative cambrils
thank you mr chair i would like to
second that motion
so it's been moved and seconded that we
pass
senate bill 256 establishing a committee
to study the feasibility of the
replacing the site evaluation committee
this is the
long-term solution
the short-term solution was
senate bill
and um
no this is the long term
the short-term solution
was the bill we heard earlier today or
was it earlier today
yesterday yeah
so this is the long-term solution which
just creates a study committee to
evaluate whether or not to replace this
the
site evaluation committee with a new
structure i sent everybody yesterday
an article by written by tom goetz that
was published in the new hampshire
business review that described his
vision of what
a revamped site evaluation committee
might look like i hope everybody had a
chance to take a peek at it
that would probably be the
the direction that the study committee
would move in
it's no guarantee
that they would move that way but it
would it would be a a road map for them
to begin their deliberations
are there any other comments
about this study committee
tom goetz is a
20-year veteran of the
public utilities commission and the site
evaluation committee he served as chair
as both
for
a dozen years or more and he's an energy
attorney
and very knowledgeable about the state
of
uh energy in new hampshire
yeah he's represented projects so he's
actually been on both sides been on the
side evaluation committee and
represented clients that were trying to
get approval so
he has a really vast uh
knowledge there
any additional comments about
is representative callie pitts
again the same comment i made was about
the date of october 15th when the house
can't officially we can't meet
july and august house members can't meet
so that's not giving very much time
considering this has to go you know
to the governor and get signed that's
all
it is a concern but
uh since this is the second year of a
session
there's not much else you can do you
can't create a study committee that
goes beyond the end of the session
a commission can go longer but a study
committee cannot
any further discussion
seeing none i'd ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of ought to
pass on senate bill 256.
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative lane yes representative
murder yes
clerk votes yes
representative berenshni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
representative samsich yes
representative kelly pitts
representative mann
yes
representative oxendine
representative lewicky yes
representative mcgee
yes
representative gotling yes
representative laflamme yes
representative pementel yes
representative partial yes
representative vos yes
so twenty one
twenty to one
twenty to one is there any objection to
putting this on the consent
calendar right we'll put it on consent
and let you take the heat if you pull it
off
if anybody can take it jackie it's you
okay so let's close the public hearing
on senate bill 256.
and uh
we already did 440.
exec session sorry
so next up would be
senate bill 259.
and
here i have an amendment
did i pass that did you pass that out
already i did
okay representative oxenom has passed
out an amendment
and uh
i'd like to make sure everybody has had
a chance to look at it
is this an amendment from
representative mick williams no no this
is from representative oxenom it's uh
2022 1359h
and it's something that we discussed at
the public hearing
which was the inconsistency between the
changes where we're adding in the state
of new hampshire we already have a
county as a
viable political subdivision for this
but we have this one sentence in here
that says a municipal host shall be
located in the same municipality as all
group members which cannot possibly
happen if it's the county and cannot
possibly happen if it's the state
and i passed out a map that shows the
kind of harm or obstacle
that this place is for many small towns
where
we have one place where we could put a
solar array
but it's in
in cornish and all of the group members
more
are in plainfield so that
by removing this one single sentence we
would make the statute consistent and we
would make it able to apply to more than
just one or two jurisdictions in the
state
okay has everybody had a chance to look
at the amendment
all right i'll recognize uh
representative bernardi for a motion on
this bill
on the amendment
no a motion on the bill
yes i'd like to make a motion for uh
interim study
i recognize representative lewicki
i second
so it's been moved and seconded that we
judge senate bill 259 to be
worthy of interim study
is there any further discussion
representative bernardi
yes uh thank you chairman mr mr chairman
um
so on the main
bill here we had language about the
state housing authorities and quasi
public entities as well as peace
development authority
uh
what causes
i think a need for for uh interim study
is because this this potentially greatly
expands
uh the opportunity for net metering we
don't know how much how big in
and because quasi-public entities are
considered
this needs to be flushed out
and makes it perfect for interim study
okay any further discussion
all right seeing none i'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the motion of
interim study for senate bill
2 5
9.
representative thomas yes
representative harrington yes
representative lange yes
representative murder yes clerk beauty s
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils yes
representative pleasure
yes
representative white yes
representative somsich no
representative callie pitts
representative mann
representative oxenon
no
representative lewicki
yes
representative mcgee
no
representative gottling no
representative luflam
no
representative pementel no
representative partial no
representative votes yes
14-7
by a vote of 14-7 the recommendation to
require to refer for interim study is
adopted on senate bill 259
so we will close that exact session
will there be a minority report
on interim study
i i don't think it's worth doing it's
probably not necessary all right
no minority report
okay thank you
so
close the public hearing on sb two five
and not the public during the exec
session on two five nine
senate bill 261
and i am
now distributing an amendment for 261.
oh let me have a copy for myself
all this amendment does is it adds one
sentence to the
text
that was supplied by the department of
energy and senator waters
as the
amendment
for this bill
that one sentence is the last sentence
on lines 12 and 13
that says the costs reasonably incurred
by a utility pursuant to this paragraph
shall be recoverable
and i will move the adoption of this
amendment which is amendment two zero
two two
one three
nine nine
h
and i'll recognize representative thomas
uh i moved to adopt 1399h
i was hoping for a second i already
looked at that
i moved the second
okay it's been moved and adopted and
seconded that we adopt amendment 2022
1399 h
is there any discussion
representative sausage mr chairman could
you explain this amendment to us a
little bit
yes
yes this amendment was requested by
senator waters and the department of
energy
and it is
this is the exact text that they
uh requested that we submit
the only thing that i did was i added
the sentence that starts on line 12
and ends on line 13. the costs
reasonably incurred by a utility
pursuant to this paragraph shall be
recoverable so the original bill
sought to
change the payment period from yearly to
quarterly
for net metering credits
and
the department of energy identified a
couple of technical issues with the
original bill
including the section of statute that it
amended and so they suggested that
this was the correct way to
to structure this bill and so they asked
us to amend it
to structure it
according to what they request what they
needed
representative callie pitts
okay it's ten to five i haven't had my
my dinner yet i would i'm confused about
this is this gonna that
again looking at the at the
bill and trying to look at this
are still
is the system of reimbursement still
going to change to quarterly
yes if it
exceeds
a hundred dollars
now at the end of the march billing
period
i i again i guess i don't understand
that at the end of the march billing
period or on a quarterly basis an amount
equal to the amount accrued
and a balance so in essence you're
changing this
to a quarterly reimbursement
yes that is correct may i ask
why the amendment
put in the dollar amounts which i don't
see in this bill
those were requested by senator waters
and the department of energy
do we have any commentary from anybody
else on these i mean i i guess did
somebody throw a
a dart at a dart but i don't understand
that it's not customary to call on other
people to speak during an exec session
but i will ask
griffin robarge from the department of
energy if he could clear up any
confusion about this amendment
thank
sorry
thank you chairman votes members of the
committee um i apologize i'd like to
impose upon the committee i don't have a
copy of the amendment i just want to be
sure i'm
looking at what everybody's looking at
i'm sorry
thank you very much everybody
i have a copy of the bill and it doesn't
seem to
forgive me sorry
so
sorry so uh chairman both members of the
committee for your
uh recollection uh the department noted
uh a technical concern with the bill
during the public hearing because the
way the bill came over
to the house from the senate
is that
it amended a section of statute
that would only apply to customer
generators who are grandfathered into
the net metering tariff that was
outlined in june of 2017. it would only
capture those customer generators who in
existence pre that order as i think the
committee might recall there was some
testimony here about wanting it to apply
to more modern customer generators those
post this uh post 2017 order um in
working with legal counsel in the
department this language
references that june 2017 order you see
on line seven of the amendment order
and so this would apply this would
codify
elements of the puc order into statute
now questions about where the numbers
come from
as part of the pucs order it was agreed
upon that amongst all parties in the pc
agreed that
utilities
would offer customer generators on a
yearly basis
a payout of any excess credit that they
had if that amount is in excess of a
hundred dollars so that's where that 100
uh amount comes from 25
keeping with
the logic of the pc order if it's 100
per year and we're shifting to a
quarterly basis
25 every every three months so that is
um where the language comes from we had
only
issued the language from line 6 to 12
to senator gray
the phrase on lines 12 to 13 that read
the cost reasonably occurred by utility
pursuance's paragraph shall be
recoverable was likely the result of
working with utilities
so any type of
um billing software updates that they
need to make in order to allow these
payments to occur on a more on a more
frequent basis or on a quarterly basis
would be recoverable from ratepayers
does that answer your question
representative callie pitts
representative oxenum
and i would just note that the
department
again
remains neutral so
of course
so
yes so
as we would expect yes
seeing no further discussion
or does uh representative thomas need to
make a comment
oh there's a handout
representative
you said you passed yes i did but i
actually remembered the questions
i asked your indulgence
um
you had a rather torturous turn of
phrase there where you said it only
captured the grandfathered price first
for the one that was prior to the order
in 2017. so could could you say that in
in a in a direct way we often talk about
net metering 1.0 and 2.0 yes are both of
those covered by this change yes that
thank you very much appreciate it that's
what they added i just wanted to be
certain
we just re there was a specific
reference obviously to the puc order i
think has been mentioned uh in the past
is that a lot of you'll find a lot of
net metering statute is outdated it's
been superseded by puc order this
explicitly referees references
more current puc thank you
okay any further discussion
seeing none
i'd now ask the clerk to call the role
on the question of adopting amendment
representative thomas yes
representative harrington
yes
representative lange yes representative
yes clerk votes yes
representative berezne
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils
jackie's on
i just turned everybody off
yes
representative cambrils
representative pleasure
yes representative white yes
representative samsich yes
representative kelly pitts
represent
representative mann
no
representative ox in him
yes
representative lewicki yes
representative mcgee
yes
representative gottling yes
representative laflamme yes
representative pimentel yes
representative partial yes
representative votes yes
19 1.
192 sorry
by a vote of 1902 amendment 2022 1399 h
is adopted i now move
ought to pass as amended on senate bill
261 and uh i will recognize
representative thomas second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt as amended
senate bill 261-fn
is there any further discussion required
seeing none ask the clerk to call the
world as soon as she's ready
representative thomas
yes representative harrington yes
representative lang yes representative
mirner yes
clerk votes yes
representative berge berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambriels yes
representative ploje
yes representative white yes
representative samsich yes
representative callie pitts
representative mann
representative oxenom
yes
representative lewicki
representative mcgee
yes
representative gottling yes
representative laflamme yes
representative pementel yes
representative partial yes
representative bose
yes
19 2
by a vote of 19 to 2
senate bill 261
is adopted as amended
so i will
oh yeah is there going to be a minority
report
representative callie pitts or
representative man
no no minority report okay
so we'll close the public hearing on
senate bill of the
session on senate bill 261 i've been
public hearing all day
um
consent any objection to putting this
bill on consent
representative man
no no no objection so it'll go on
consent
thank you
all right moving on
open an exact session on senate bill two
six
four
two six four is relative to certain
references to the department of energy
and transferring authority over the low
income electric electricity assistance
program
to the department of energy and i
recognize representative white for a
motion
thank you chairman i'd like to move that
uh we refer this to interim study
representative clojay is recognized
uh yes thank you i roll
second the motion on senate bill 264 for
intense study okay it's been moved and
seconded that we
judge senate bill 264 to be referred for
interim study is there any discussion
representative oxenom
thank you chair mr chair could could you
give us a short
explanation of why i i understand why i
think it should be an interim study but
what what's the motivating factor here
is there a particular provision that
you find issue with
or something you're going to force me to
dig out that yeah oh i'm i'm jerry bill
aren't you i am
representative harrington
yeah one of the main things on this is
the change from the
commission to the department changes the
methodology for awarding the awards and
the commission you have in the judiciary
process where everyone gets a chance to
go forward present their case and so
forth we're not exactly sure how it's
going to work in the department yet so
it's still being worked on so that's why
we wanted to find out more about it
before we made that change because it's
a rather substantial change in process
thank you um my if i might i've had a
particular concern about this
accumulated in excess of a million
dollars we have no idea what the funding
source is what's what's the normal
amount how quickly it moves through so i
i think interim study is is a very good
beginning to to really look at
other issues in this bill
thank you thank you agreed
okay any further discussion of the
motion to refer this bill to interim
study
seeing none asked the clerk to call the
role
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representative lange yes
representative mirner yes clerk votes
yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
rep representative samsich yes
representative callie pitts
representative
mann
representative oxendine yes
representative lewicki
yes
representative mcgee yes
representative gottling yes
representative laflands
representative pementel yes
representative partial yes
representative
yes
21-0
by a vote of 21 to nothing this bill is
referred for interim study that's sb 264
without objection it'll be placed on a
consent calendar
any objection seeing none
representative white we need a
committee report by noon tomorrow
okay
committee report on interim study
yeah
you still have to have a report
you still have to have a report yes
very short one do
i i might my question to the chair was
did the members of the committee realize
that interim study in the second session
is a slow death
yes we all realize that i believe
they're only i explained it the other
day there are only two outcomes for
interim study in the second session the
second year of a session one is
recommend for future legislation or the
other is not recommend for future
legislation those are the two choices so
we will have a meeting on this in the
fall and we'll choose one of those two
choices
for it and any other bills we send into
interim study
all right so let's
close the exact session on 264 and open
an exact session on senate bill 268 and
i will recognize representative brezhne
thank you chairman
i move that we adopt
amendment 14 12 h2sb to 68 and i can
speak to my motion
so the amount the
motion is to adopt amendment
2022-1
and copies of that amendment are
circulating around the table as we speak
and i recognize representative lewicki
while that is happening
uh i second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
amendment 20 0
20 22
1412 h
and i recognize representative brezhney
representative harrington uh yeah
mr chairman i think there might be a
technical issue with this that we i
probably should have caught in the
amendment and i just noticed it now but
in line 12 it says
uh it talks about notwithstanding the
provisions no state funds shall be
appropriated expended for planning
construction operation management of
offshore wind or tidal resources the
problem is the word planning we have the
offshore wind commission which is
actively involved in planning with that
it's ongoing uh we're a member of this
uh you know bone task force and so forth
so i mean just by virtue of the fact
that we have state employees attending
these meetings i think that's money
being spent on planning now i gave a
copy to griffin he's gonna run it back
to their council but maybe we could just
put this on hold until next week
i might hate to bring this up at the
last minute but i don't know how to get
around that otherwise
okay well thank you for pointing that
out i'm going to let representative
berezni speak to the amendment
uh even though you've brought up a
potential issue with it so
representative brezhney is recognized
okay i'll just point out that this
wouldn't uh this begins july 1st 2023 i
don't know if that helps but um the the
reason for the amendment is uh during
the hearing yesterday
uh representative pleasure brought up
the
title power generation so that was added
to this um bill and then
the second thing that's added is a
prohibition on using state funds for
wind
and tidal power and
the idea for that came from
hp 1432 which was a prohibition on using
state funds for the rail project which
passed the house by a decent majority
and the reason for that is just to add
guard rail this is an enabling bill
and it should have some some kind of uh
messaging of how far
we're looking to go so that's that's it
so representative brezhny where was the
reference to july 1st of 2023 i think
you said line 11
on the first page ah okay yeah beginning
on july 1st all right
good
further discussion of this amendment
representative mcgee
and i just i don't understand how either
we have a department of wind right an
office of wind um
which is planning and
there will be money expended if we are
going to participate whether we're going
to participate or not may still be
objectively unknown but it seems like
there's quite a lot of planning ongoing
with which the state is participating in
and to have a statutory cutoff date in
here whereby those resources would no
longer be able to participate seems to
be
counterproductive really to what we've
been working on
um so i just i don't
i think having a three-page amendment
come in at the last second to change a
bill that was for something
um
it had a very specific purpose right
which was to allow us to assert that
consistency in how we're
uh operating as a state in waters that
are going to be
looked at for
wind development so i think this bill
takes it in another direction that would
require a lot more discussion than we
had in the hearing
um and and i also think again
the idea that no state monies could be
expended is um
it's a non-starter that's how i would
say it
okay further discussion representative
samsic
yes i'm kind of surprised about this
amendment too
not just because of the timing at the
very last minute but because
i think there's a lot of misconceptions
here um maybe the idea is to somehow
stop the whole process of offshore wind
in which case i can say it will not stop
the other states will go ahead without
us
the whole idea is we need to be at the
table to
make sure that our interests as a state
are recognized including the fishing
industry and so forth
uh and uh unless we're at the table uh
we're not gonna have a say in this
uh the department of energy is currently
looking for a consultant to hire
for various projects associated with
offshore wind
that would bring that to a halt
and
in addition the issue of tidal resource
well i think it's a great idea there is
no idea to do anything at this point
nobody's willing no company is willing
to do anything about it it's not
necessarily a proven technology yet so
it's kind of hypothetical
even though i might think it's
interesting we have considered that in
portsmouth to seeing our ties go in and
out all the time be nice
so i think there's a lot of things in
this bill that don't make a lot of sense
the lack of funding for the legitimate
offshore wind projects which will
benefit new hampshire dramatically as we
were talking just briefly in
around electric car vehicles charging
and the need for extra electricity
this is going to be a huge energy
resource
and it's going to go on without us or
with us it doesn't matter what we say
because we're a relatively small player
but we're going to end up being
at the back of the line playing defense
and not having any say unless we get
involved and become actively involved in
it so
i think
without giving this a lot of thought or
a hearing or something i think this is
premature to come up with something like
this thank you
thank you
further discussion
representative oxenam
thank you mr chair um several things we
heard
repeatedly during the public hearing how
important it was for new hampshire to
protect its interests by establishing in
statute that this consistency argument
that we had to put these things in so
that we could therefore
be protective of the interests of the
state of new hampshire in secondarily
numerically secondly maybe not
secondarily
there are going to be enormous
job opportunities and investment
opportunities with this new industry
coming in and we're we're foreclosing
the door and saying new hampshire is not
open for business we're not interested
in what is probably the the biggest gold
mine of at least the coming half century
and
we have this going to be the landing of
power even if other states and the feds
are are producing from wind they've got
to bring that power on shore we've we've
got that um seabrook
facility that was never used as an
opportunity to to bring it in that
second that second um
reactor site
we are so posed to take advantage of
this economic development opportunity
and this just says no we're not
interested in in business if it has a
renewable tag
i'm amazed
thank you representative the way i read
this paragraph
it basically says that
any money expended for the planning
construction operation or management of
offshore wind
should be private money
not public money
what what this paragraph says to me is
that the private sector sector should be
investing in this technology
the private sector is frequently
or maybe frequently isn't the best word
maybe it's always
better at
accomplishing this kind of of work than
the public sector the public sector
tends to
be less efficient
at accomplishing this kind of work so
what this
paragraph says to me is we want the
private sector to take over this
this uh the build-out of this
win these wind energy resources without
encumbering
public money
representative partial
yes thank you chair votes i would agree
with you i would like the private sector
to become involved with this and do the
actual construction and building that's
the appropriate role
but the appropriate role for the private
sector is not to declare a 200 mile
contingency and that's what the original
bill did
i notice the date on this is uh july 1st
why can't this not be introduced as a
separate bill independent of this bill
so that we can get this states rights
bill passed
and then we can work on the logistics of
the details later
uh further comments representative
callie pitts
again
i don't think my brain is functioning
the way it should i'm looking at the the
section three that was in question
and
then i'm looking at
the same section that i see in
uh the original bill
of the of the monies the crew
collected for mitigation etc etc are
going to go to the des
so where is this bill
absolutely cutting out this amendment
absolutely cutting out use of private
funds
can you tell me which paragraph you were
referring to
i was referring to the paragraph on
lines 11 12 and 13.
on page one and that apparently there
was a quest there's a question about
that it was going to be changed i do
believe
there was a that that was that paragraph
in question
i have it circled that it was in
question and there was a technical
change on it or
i think paragraph three is a new
paragraph isn't it is that not
he brought up planning as an issue that
we are involved in planning
that no state fund should be appropriate
as for planning construction operation
or management of the offshore winning so
is
on this particular part
was con you're gonna will you leave
planning and
take out construction operation or
management
yeah but it's prohibited
representative harrington yeah and yeah
the intent was is to
not have planning be on the list of
things we couldn't spend money on we we
just passed 440 um this morning or
yesterday i can't remember anymore and
it says
you know the department of energy
offshore wind industry development it
advise the governments the governor of
state agencies the public utilities
commission and the legislature on the
development of clean energy resources in
the gulf of maine the purchase of power
by new hampshire public utilities from
these resources to me that's planning
and we have
this bill now the amendment like i say i
apologize for not catching this earlier
but the amendment's in conflict to the
bill we just passed and it's in fact in
conflict of what we're we're pursuing so
we're taking out just the word planning
well we we can't do we have to do
another amendment now in order to do
that but that's what you would do is yes
yes that's the word i have the problem
instruction operation or management
i have no problem with those words but i
do everyone was planning
representative bernardi
thank you mr chairman yes uh um first
off this amendment is still designed to
allow us to claim consistency that's
that's a primary goal
number one number number two
that is all the language that wasn't
changed it's on the second page it says
to develop a gld and identified partners
blah blah blah blah at the very bottom
of page two nothing is nothing has
changed there that's and that is the one
of the primary functions of this bill
the
the second point was to make
new hampshire keep new hampshire
involved in both wind and title okay if
we don't do anything on title fine but
be involved
as a as appropriate the third point is
is where we have we where we have this
difficulty
and as as chairman votes has pointed out
the purpose of the paragraph starting on
the first page
line 11 was to to fundamentally say we
should not be as new hampshire involved
in the ab the dedication of new
hampshire funds for the ownership
construction operation of any windmills
that are going out there if the state of
massachusetts wants to put their money
into it or maine that's fine but it
should be private money that's doing
this task as far as new hampshire is
concerned that's the that's the that's
the three purposes of this amendment
federal as well you weren't recognized
representative please uh so raise your
hand and i recognize ask to be
recognized before you speak
i think bottom line this bill this
amendment still addresses that primary
purpose of consistency
it adds
our involvement and potential title
power
i don't see anything wrong with that we
do have the issue of that
representative harrington's brought up
we stuck the word planning in here and
it shouldn't be in here
in that case i think that
this amendment probably isn't passable
as it's written
and i don't want to move this off to
april 19th
i'd like to pass this bill today
so
is there any
appetite
amongst the committee members for not
passing this amendment
the amendment or the bill sir the
amendment
right now we're just discussing the
amendment there's a motion on the floor
to adopt the amendment
yes who supports the amendment and who
opposes the amendment let's show it
let's let's show a uh a show of hands
for people who support the amendment
not
okay now let's see a show of hands for
people who don't support the amendment
it would appear that um we don't support
as a committee the amendment
so representative berezner would you be
interested in withdrawing your amendment
thank you mr chairman uh i would like to
withdraw amendment 14 12 h and make a
motion to adopt
um
hb or sb 269 to 68.
representative wiki
uh i second
okay so the amendment is withdrawn and a
motion is now on the floor to adopt
senate bill 2
as introduced to this committee
is there any further discussion on that
question
seeing none i'd ask the clerk to call
the role on
the question of ought to pass on sb 268
representative thomas
yes
representative harrington yes
representative lang yes representative
mirner yes clerk votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes
representative samsich yes
representative kelly pitts yeah
representative mann yes
representative oxenom yes representative
lewicki yes
representative mcgee yes representative
gottling yes representative lafland yes
representative pimento
yes
representative partial yes
representative vos yes 21-0
so by a count of 21 to zero
senate bill 268
is adopted
and without objection we'll put it on
the consent calendar
seeing no objections
it will go on consent
that concludes the executive session on
senate bill 268
and that brings us next to senate bill
269 and i recognize representative
cambrils for a motion
yes
thank you mr chairman uh
this doesn't
thank you representative cambrils has
been recognized thank you mr chair i
would like to make a motion
to uh put senate bill 269 into an
interim study
and i will give a brief rationale if it
is seconded
representative merner is recognized
i second
it's been moved and seconded that we
refer
senate bill 269 to interim study and
representative cambrils is recognized
yes thank you mr chair the reason for
putting senate bill 269 into an interim
study is that yesterday
we heard a lot of questions and concerns
from both sides of the aisle
that included
amongst other things the fact that the
commission was
the makeup of the commission was very
unbalanced
there was a
a big concern
over reducing the contractor
pre-qualifications
and what that meant
and also there was a
feeling that there was a need to better
understand
what the impact of the fiscal
participation expansion to new hampshire
users of propane and oil would be
given the already super high energy
prices that our citizens are currently
paying
okay thank you any further discussion
on the motion for interim study on
senate bill 269 representative mann
thank you chairman
um i've got an amendment that goes about
two pages and um substantially changes
the um
and refines i think the uh the bill
uh and i'd like to at least present the
amendment
um
we have a motion on the floor so
we have to dispose of that motion before
we can consider anything else okay so
all i'm saying is that i have an
amendment that that exists and that's
relevant to whether we
uh
vote for or against the interim study i
think there's a lot to be done here and
it's
never okay that's it
great any further discussion
representative bernardi
yes just to comment on representative
mann's amendment if we go to the interim
study that all all those points and
issues can be brought up at that point
in time
good point
any further
discussion on this bill
seeing none i asked the clerk to call
the role on the motion of interim study
for senate bill 269.
representative thomas yes representative
harrington yes representative lange yes
representative mirner yes clerk votes
yes
representative berezni yes
representative barack bernardi
yes
representative cambrils yes
representative bluge
yes
representative white yes
representative samsich
no
no no
representative callie pitts
no
representative man no
representative oxen no
representative lewicki yes
representative mcgee no
representative gottling no
representative of plan no
representative pimento
no
representative
and representative votes yes
uh 12 9
by a vote of 12 to 9 senate bill
269 will be referred to interim study
will there be a minority report
yes there will be a minority report
representative samsic will write it and
deliver it by noon tomorrow correct
okay
so that closes the executive session on
senate bill 269 and that actually closes
our activity for the day
almost
we have a couple of things left to do
one is to
everybody uh extend a vigorous thank you
to
our substitute clerk vanessa sheehan
she did a fantastic job thank you
vanessa we really appreciate you being
here
and we thank
all of our substitute representatives
today
representative laflamme representative
gotland representative lange
thanks to everyone for being here today
and helping us out
next order of business i want everybody
to be aware that on tuesday april the
19th
we will conduct another executive
session
at which time we will
exec senate bills 263
265. 271
and 262.
we we may not exec them in that order
but mr chairman will that will that list
of executive uh uh bills be listed in
the calendar this year yes it will okay
well indeed
representative
thank you very much mr chair i i noticed
yesterday um that that you mentioned the
sessions on april 21st and may 5th
yes is it your understanding that that
may 5th is the last session of that we
will be holding as the
no it will not be the last session there
will be a session on may 12th to form
committees of conference
and then there will be a final session
on may 26th to hear the reports of all
the committed committees of conference
thank you very much
and with that
i want to thank you all for a fantastic
day of work a long day of work but a
fantastic day of work
five let's see
eight and a half hours of work we did
today
so
you're you you pat yourselves on the
back
and uh i thank you we'll see you on
tuesday april 19.
you